So und wer skippst die iWatch? Von...
ist ja hübsch.
Auf der International Freak Ausstellung.
Die Freak Show stellt fest. Mit Umbenennung der Sendung in Freak Show dürfen sämtliche Wortspiele mit dem Wort Freak exklusiv nur in diesem Podcast verwendet werden. Dazu gehören Freakskasse, Atom aus Freak, Freak Apple, Besatzungsmitfreak, Sergeant Pepper's Lonely Freaks Club Band, Freak Us, das Freak entscheidet, Druck an Freak, die Spritze wird jetzt kurz Freaksen, der Freak dich, Freak und Poke, Champions Freak, der 100-jährige, der aus dem Fenster freak und verschwand, Freak der Sterne, Fluch der Cari Freak, Vicky Freaks, Freakma Gabriel, Black Eyed Freaks, Freak Larsson, Bundesrepo Freak Deutschland, Freak und Frieden und guten Appefreak. Zur Wiederhandlung sind gerne willkommen. Ihr Peter von Zahn.
Ganz schön was los im Internet Relay Freak.
Ich freak mich nicht ein. Das ist der Hammer.
Verflickst und zugefreakt. Hallo, wir haben euch schon gedacht, hier ist...
Du musst mal mehr in deinem Frikrofon sprechen.
Ja, Freak Vader, du bist endlich wieder da. Wollen wir uns jetzt nur noch in Outnames unterhalten? Ja, hier ist die Freak Show. Ich richtig gezählt habe, die 118. Ausgabe. Und wir sind komplett mal wieder alle da.
Servus.
Und ich bin direkt aus Frankreich.
Ja, ich bin wieder da.
Ich wurde aus Barcelona importiert.
Aber ich habe gar keine Bauchnummer.
Aber ich habe gar nicht in Frankreich gewesen.
Friedreich. Du hast gesagt, es darf gerne flach sein.
Probier mal die andere Seite aus.
Ach so, die nicht flachen.
Genau, die intellektuelle Abteilung.
Michael Frik-Randitski.
So flach auch wieder nicht, bitte.
Aber in gewisser Hinsicht, wir meinen das ja total positiv, für alle Leute, die sich aufregen über den Namen. Sollts ja geben und die da was weiß ich alles reindeuten. Ich sag nur, we define the terms. Naja, ich mein das einfach mal so ein Wort, das ist jetzt einfach...
Das wird jetzt neu definiert von uns.
Genau, in diesem Moment.
Dann machen wir das jetzt mal.
Hörerpost.
Wir fangen gleich damit an.
Ich würd sagen, oder? Ist doch schön zum Reinkommen eigentlich. Was weg ist, ist weg.
Also das ist gerade eben hier reingerauscht.
Aus Zürich.
Zollamtlich abgefertigt.
Frisch vom Zoll.
Es handelt sich dabei um eine Sendung, auf dessen schwizerischen Zollaufkleber Frikolade steht.
Ist da so Apothekengras drin?
Nee, Frikolade. Und es handelt sich dabei um lauter kleine Schokoladen, wie mir scheint, die in iPad-Mini-Form daherkommen.
Naja, eher so Nexus. Nexus 7.
Dennis, unser Schokoladenbeauftragter, wird das mal genau inspizieren.
Bad Chef. Dennis der Schoko-Werb.
Knister-Experte Dennis A. Mach mal Schmatzprobe.
Steht da was drauf?
Kann ich das gleich aufessen?
Was jetzt schon?
Also hier gibt es auf jeden Fall für jeden mindestens.
Aber ist eingepackt wie...
Oh, ist unterschiedlich.
Unterschiedlich, dann will ich noch mehr.
Oh, die ist kaputt gegangen.
Schick mal zurück.
Aber Tim, hat das schon mal hier irgendwie?
Nichts, die behalte ich.
Also ich hab jetzt noch zweier, wa?
Hühnerfreakassee.
Wow, die ist schwer.
Ist hier die Hühnerfreakassee?
Also ich bin sehr mäglich bei Schokolade, deswegen, ich hätte gern irgendwas.
Klingt mein Kanal eigentlich komisch, oder kommt mir das nur gerade so vor?
Nein, dein Kanal klingt eigentlich ganz... Klingt eigentlich ganz friekeig.
Also so wie sonst auch.
Also, es ist leider kein richtiger Absender hier, oder?
Wie ein Absender?
Lederach-Schokolatier-Swiss, also das scheint direkt von da geschickt zu werden.
Also entweder werden wir von einem Schokolatier gehört, oder der Schokolatier hat von jemandem einen Auftrag gekriegt.
Wir haben gesagt, wir wollen mehr Schoki, und jetzt hat einer die Drohung wahrgemacht.
Aber er hat den Namen vergessen, dem wir jetzt danken können. In dem Fall danken wir also dem anonymen Schokolatier.
Wir spielen jetzt mal jeder, der eins hat, soll... Jeder, der zwei hat, soll demjenigen, der eins hat, eins geben, damit der auch zwei hat.
Jeder, der vier hat und fünf, der soll noch...
Erst mal auspacken und ich will irgendwie die harmloseste Schokolade, also Vollmilch oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich hab hier was rosa-rotes.
Tim, noch ne Schoki auspacken.
Aber die ist ja 70%.
Freak Post International. Ich weiß nicht, sollte man die wirklich alle auspacken jetzt?
Natürlich.
Dann gib mir die kleine.
Die ist dark.
Wir müssen jetzt zumindest mal gucken, was uns hier... Ihr krallt mich jetzt gleich.
Mag jemand diese dunkle Schokolade?
Ich bin nicht so für dunkle.
70% Dings?
Oh, die sieht auch nicht schlecht aus.
Ich hab eine mit 70%. Guck mal. Wenn du noch dunkler willst.
Nee, ich will nicht noch dunkler. Ich will eigentlich heller.
Frischschokie.
Echt?
Bist du so ein hellschokie Mensch?
Wo steht denn was?
Ihr zahlt jetzt auf oder was?
Ich nehm dir die 70er locker ab.
Fatschkaramell.
Jetzt wird hier getauscht.
Na, der große Schokoladenhandel.
Aber du hast mir jetzt die 70er gegeben damit. Clemens soll denn nicht los wird oder was?
Clemens wollt auch keine 70er. Hat er nicht, er hat nur normale.
Die ist nur eine dunkle hier.
Ich hätt noch eine dunkle abzugeben.
An dieser schummeligen Beleuchtung hier liegen.
Wir kommen erstmal noch ganz geschmeidig hier. Die sind doch bekifft.
Freaking schockerlaut. Der Schocker des Tages ist so dahin, dass ich letzte Nacht an meinem Landsitz zwei Grad hatte, sagt er.
Haben wir die Faktenhöre eigentlich schon drauf jetzt?
Ja, die sind schon da.
Ach so, Entschuldigung.
Also ob die schon drauf sind, weiß ich nicht. Aber sie sind auf jeden Fall dabei.
Ach ja, naja, liebe Hörer, ihr merkt schon, wir müssen noch ein bisschen Zeit schinden, weil iOS 7 ist immer noch nicht so richtig angekommen.
Ist eigentlich iTunes 11.1, was man ja für iOS 7 braucht, schon draußen, weil sonst geht es nämlich nicht. Dann kann man seinen Backup nämlich nicht einspielen.
Ja, muss man seinen Backup einspielen?
Ich musste, ich hab für den Developer Bild.
Ich hab GM installiert und da muss man ja frisch von vorne anfangen.
Nee, muss man nicht unbedingt.
Hab ich aber. Warum muss man nicht?
Du kannst doch ein Update machen.
Echt? Ja, aber ich war ungeduldig, das erschien nicht in meinem Update und dann hab ich das Image runtergeladen und drüber gebügelt. Genau, ich auch.
Weil das GM erschien ja gar nicht.
Ja, aber man konnte es trotzdem updaten.
Aber schnell Alt-Update drücken und dann das Pfeil auswählen. Ja, jetzt haben wir was gesagt. Nächstes Mal.
Chat sagt, ist da. Seit 18 Uhr gibt es iTunes. Ja, jetzt muss nur dieser bekloppte Update-Zahler mir auch mal Bescheid sagen, weil es dauert so lange.
Die Diskussion hatten wir eben schon.
Nein, die Update-Checks fehlen einfach. Also das Erdbeerzeug ist okay. Das find ich durchaus.
Pass auf mein Stück Erdbeerzeug.
Das heißt, das 11.1b48 ist gerade das richtige, ja?
Software-Update. Updates are available for your computer. 11.1.
Ja, 11.1b48 steht bei mir. Das Beta 2 war das.
Heißt das, dass ich mich jetzt in diesen iOS 7 Zyklonstrom begebe?
Ja, und besser, zurück geht's dann nicht mehr.
Vorwärts immer, rückwärts immer. Die Frage, was die Beta 2 ist jetzt auch das...
Was ist das Final Commitment sozusagen?
Ist jetzt auch die GM von iTunes oder was? Was ist die GM? Was ist denn jetzt das von dem iTunes, was man runterladen kann, die...
11126 sagt hier einer, aber bei mir...
Ich dachte die Beta 2, die war einfach so gut.
Bei mir steht 48 in Klammern.
Bei mir auch. Aber ich hab ja auch die Beta 2.
Ich auch, aber es ist nicht die neueste, aber es...
Wollen wir mal ein bisschen Spur hier in die Sendung kriegen?
Schmeiß mal bei mir rein.
Also ihr merkt schon, diese Sendung steht unter maximalem Einfluss. Dennis!
Nur weil du zweimal gefehlt hast, musst du nicht gleich von Anfang an alles zuwählen.
Ja, ist irgendwas passiert. iOS 7 kommt raus und zwar während wir mit unserer Sendung beginnen. Hier ist es noch nicht angekommen auf diesem Computer, auf diesem iPhone 4. Das ist alles, was ich bereit bin, dem iOS 7 Drachen als Opfergabe erstmal vor die Füße zu schmeißen.
Wir probieren auch mal ein iPad. Den Klass wird mal krachen heute.
Hat sich ja überhaupt keiner mit dem User hinterfest auseinandergesetzt.
Doch, ich hab's seit ein paar Tagen drauf. Also eigentlich seit es den GM gibt, hab ich das auf dem iPad. Also muss ich sagen, das gefällt mir auf dem iPad deutlich besser als auf dem iPhone.
Und soll ich dir was sagen?
Ich bin nicht überrascht. Weil dieses ganze Design von diesem iOS 7, das will einfach mehr Platz haben.
Ja, das halt ich aber gerade nicht.
Doch, das drückt sich überall in jede Ecke rein und wo noch gerade mal ein Pixel zu holen ist, schiebt sich das so rein.
Wo man keinen Platz hat, holt's mehr raus. So rum musst du das sehen.
Ja, aber es wirkt trotzdem so, als will's eigentlich noch mehr haben, bevor es wirklich zufrieden ist. Ja, das ist so ein... dieses iOS 7 UI, das hat einfach Überdruck.
Verstehst du, das drückt von innen gegen dein iPhone Das einzige, was wirklich eine Katastrophe ist, ist dieser Music Player, was mal iPod App hier ist oder so.
Oder wie viel haben wir Katastrophen?
Weil das ist so, ich weiß nicht...
Aber der war doch schon vorher schlecht.
Ja, aber es ist gefühlt noch schlechter geworden.
Was vorher schlecht war, wird auch mit iOS 7 nicht besser, so heißt das.
Vorher konnte man noch erkennen, was ein Button ist. Also im Prinzip kann man sie auch erkennen. Alles, was rote Schrift ist, ist auch ein Button, aber es ist halt alles rot. Also das ist irgendwie... ja. Und wenn man den zufällig Button drückt, dann steht da alle zufällig.
Entschuldigung, Roddy, ich muss gerade mal deinen Kompressor irgendwie einstellen und ich stelle gerade fest, so ein Gerät unterm Tisch zu haben, ist eigentlich keine gute Idee.
Wieso musst du meinen Kompressor einstellen?
Weil du da ein bisschen gegen segelst.
Ich segel gegen?
Du segelst gegen den Kompressor.
Und du werdest es schon wirklich wieder.
Ich schreie!
Wenn du schreist, klingt es zu platt. Also ich meine, das liegt nicht an dir. So, wo waren wir? iOS 7 kommt raus und Freak Show 118 startet live in Farbe. Und während dieser Sendung werde ich versuchen, ein iPhone 4 live auf iOS 7 zu installieren. Das Ganze fing an mit dem App Store, der mir 49 Ups zum Update vorschlug. Das ist jetzt etwas verzerrt. Das ist nicht so, dass ich gestern auch schon alles aktuell gehabt hätte. Sondern das Ding kommt mehr oder weniger aus der Schublade und vielleicht mal so vor dem Monatsletzten mal im Internet gewesen.
Wie war das? iOS 7 ist jetzt schon drauf oder nicht? Noch nicht? Dann update nicht und mach erst mal iOS 7.
Wie was? Ich soll nicht iOS 7 installieren, sondern erst iOS 7 installieren?
Nein, diese anderen Updates alle nicht machen.
Ja, aber die passieren wenigstens jetzt, während dieses iOS 7 Update mir ja noch nicht mal angeboten wird. Also das ist mir dann, hätte ich auch vorher anders gemacht.
Aber die haben nicht auf der Blacklist.
Ich finde das aber auch ganz interessant, weil ich habe jetzt schon die ersten Ups nach Updates installiert, auf iOS 6 gestartet und sie sahen halt aus wie iOS 7. Und das ist genau das, das ist einfach nicht mein Ding, weißt du? Bäm, dieses Programm, was so wunderbar hineingepasst hat, passt ab jetzt nicht mehr hier hinein. Ich hab Angst.
Jetzt kann man aber wieder alte Apps, ne? Hast du gelesen, ne?
Ich bin alt und ich bin dem neuen verschlossen.
Apple erlaubt jetzt genetigerweise, dass irgendwelche Up-Developer jetzt auch wieder alte Ups reintun können, damit die alten Geräte nicht...
Haben sie gesagt, dass sie wieder alte Ups reintun können?
Oder binden sie die nicht einfach aus dem... Sonst wird ja uninteressant.
Sie haben doch alle Versionen davon.
Nein, aber ich vermute mal, jetzt muss man wie die Up-Developer hier sagen, ich vermute mal, dass das jetzt auch noch Updates reinschieben kann, so Sicherheits-Updates.
Das ist eine große Frage.
Das wär ja mal cool.
Also Apple hat den Developer nicht Bescheid gesagt.
Nein, also tropft noch die Nachricht. Nein, nein, nein.
Hätten sie, wenn sie bereit gewesen wären, es ihnen zu sagen, wenn sie es auch wirklich gewollt hätten, hätten sie das vielleicht auf der WWDC schon gemacht. Nach dem Motto, bereitet euch darauf vor, alte Versionen anzubieten, weil unser OS-Wechsel und Gerätewechsel ist etwas ruppig und wir wollen sie nicht alle total vor den Kopf stoßen. Wir sehen ein, dass mittlerweile Leute diese Computer so benutzen, wie sie sind.
Mit den 64-Bit haben sie ja auch den Developer nichts gesagt und da geht es jetzt auch gerade erst los.
Ja, hast du nicht ein Thema auf der WWDC an einer Stelle?
64-Bit nicht, dass ich wüsste. Nö, das hat niemand kommen sehen.
Naja, es hat niemand kommen sehen auf der anderen Seite.
Du hast gesagt, wir bringen nächstes Jahr Geräte mit 64-Bit. Das war so die Botschaft der letzten Monate.
Naja, ich sag mal so, unter Mac OS ist ja 64-Bit jetzt ein alter Hut. Das haben irgendwie alle einmal mitgemacht und wissen, was zu beachten ist. Und zumindest die Developer, die so ein bisschen über den iOS-Tellerrand hinausgeguckt haben, wussten, dass wenn da mal 64-Bit kommt, dass man gewisse Dinge in gewisser Art und Weise machen muss, dann hat man eigentlich kein Problem. Und ich hab zwar letztes Mal mich darauf verstiegen zu sagen, das wird ein großer Spaß, aber eigentlich ist es kein Problem.
Irgendjemand meinte bei der VUGA-Firma, wo ich arbeite, da war auch im Frontend-Channel irgendwie große Debatte darüber, weil irgendwie, wie war denn das, irgendwie benutzt man ein NS Integer oder irgendwie casten die da sich irgendwelches Zeug und das ändert sich dann halt so unter der AP sozusagen drunter weg.
NS Integer ist ein Define, was je nachdem, ob du unter 32-Bit oder unter 64-Bit kompilierst, halt auf einen anderen Basic-Type match.
Das sich automatisch auf die richtige Größe anpasst. Aber wenn du Printf machst oder NS-Log hier mit, wie heißen diese, Prozent D und I und so, dann musst du den Wert dahinter immer casten auf Standard und so. Aber C lang und so macht alles automatisch, deswegen ist es egal.
Wir fassen zusammen, sollte eigentlich kein Problem sein.
Das sagen ja auch die meisten, kurz neu kompiliert und ein bisschen hier und da und fertig.
Ich habe auch eine größere Code-Paste einfach mal kompiliert.
Über welches Thema wollen wir jetzt als erstes reden? Ich versuche gerade so ein bisschen Ordnung reinzukriegen, weil es nur weil du mit deinem Workflow spielen willst. Was?
Nö. Ja auch. Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine irgendwie muss man ja auch mal was experimentieren. Ich finde zwar grundsätzlich, dass sich zu detaillierte Themenablauflisten machen für einen Podcast ist eigentlich eher hinwehlich.
Besonders bei uns.
Aber es gibt Ausnahmen. Ich will nicht, dass wir da jetzt sozusagen Punkt für Punkt in der Reihenfolge durchgehen. Das ist einfach nur unser Notizblatt.
Wir können ja erstmal über das Essen sprechen.
Wobei wir das aber auch ausführlich gemacht haben.
Dennis hat heute aus dem Forsthaus Falkenau gegessen.
Pizza Frickhaus. Stand da von nicht noch Azuri oder so? Hab ich geändert. You change your mind. Online.
Ja, Roddy nimmt immer die Pizza von oben auf der Hauptseite. Clemens nimmt das, was Roddy nimmt. Und du fängst jetzt wahrscheinlich an mit, ich nehme das, was Clemens nimmt.
Ich hab die Forsthaus auch schon seit einer Weile immer gegessen.
Außerdem hat er die mit Eis, ich hab die ohne Eis.
Solange der Vorrat reicht.
Wenn es nach mir ginge, können wir jetzt über iOS reden oder über die neuen Phones. Aber irgendwie, das gehört schon auch so zusammen.
Lass erst mal iOS, weil das gibt es jetzt schon. Und neue Phones gibt es noch nicht.
Aber da kannst du doch noch gar nicht mitreden.
Wer? Ich muss ja auch nicht mitreden. Ich sitze hier einfach grumpy und...
Grumpy old Tim.
Ich warte auf ihr in der Lage...
Also ich bin jetzt... Meine Rolle ist einfach die eines zickigen iOS 6-Users, der das geil findet, der glücklich mit ist. Das ist super. Das ist genau das, was ich haben wollte. Alles prima. Ich hab mich jetzt auch dran gewöhnt.
Kann man immer zurückspulen, was Tim damals bei iOS 5 gesagt hat, als er sich vor 6 gegruselt hat oder so?
Kein Update war jemals für mich irgendein psychologisches Problem, ever.
Bisher.
Und dann kam iOS 7.
Na, es kam ja noch nicht. Jetzt kommt's grad.
Ich hab's schon.
Und jetzt ist es sozusagen anders als sonst, dass ich mir sozusagen über die Auswirkungen noch nicht vollständig im Klaransehen. 4. Uncertainty and doubt.
Ich könnte jetzt immer noch 6.1.3 interessieren, wenn mich Maps-Updates für Japan interessieren würden. Er bietet mir 6.1.3 an. Als wenn du sagst, du guckst jetzt unbedingt die tollen neuen Maps für Japan an. Vorher gibt's keine neuen Updates. Wenn du guckst, Apple ab und zu lassen die Hosen runter und sagen, was da drin sein soll. So ein 6.1.3 behebt ein Problem, bei dem die Telefon-Up ohne Eingabe des Codes benutzt werden konnte und Verbesserung für Maps in Japan. Da komm ich nicht dran vorbei. Den direkt muss ich offensichtlich erst mal installieren, bevor ich irgendetwas anderes installieren kann.
Das Leben ist hart, ja. Kannste glauben. Aber wie gesagt, wir haben es ja auch schon. Wir fragen uns alle, warum du es noch nicht hast.
Weil ich kein Apple-Developer bin.
Aber Dennis hat 99 Devices, die er da in seinem Account zum Beispiel machen kann. Wie hast denn du es installiert?
Aber ich hab diese Fetzen der SEK sicher?
Ich hab auch gar keine iPhone-Dings, ich hab nur für Mac OS.
Aber ich hab in meinem Account noch Devices frei.
Er winkt ab.
Außerdem brauchte man gar keinen Account, ihr Schlaumeier. Da war da gesagt.
Was? Doch, ich brauchte einen.
Also wie hast du es denn installiert?
Na, ich suche die richtigen Dings. 1429 war es, A1429.
Das ist aus dem Bild da rund geladen.
Als was kam das runter?
Das ist als IPFW oder wie die Dinge heißen.
Aber ich konnte das halt nicht aktivieren, ohne dass mein Gerät...
Aber viele haben geschrieben, also bei den ersten Betas schon, dass es so gehen würde.
Aber die Golden Master wollten sie ja wieder beim neuen Verlieren aktiviert haben.
Ja, aber mein iPhone ist auch bei meinem Kumpel im Dings drin.
Na ja, jetzt kommt's raus, verstehe. Also doch.
Aber sie haben geschrieben, dass die ersten Betas, dass man die nicht...
Dass man auch alles anders macht.
Ich bin seit der ersten Beta dabei. Und das mit dem Anmelden musste ich gleich vom Anfang an machen.
Wie auch immer wir stellen fest, iOS 7 ist auf dem Weg in dieses Studio, auf ein Jutser-Szenario.
Ist hier nicht unterwegs.
Ist das ein 4 oder ein 5?
Na doch, also in gewisser Hinsicht. Ich versuche jetzt sozusagen als Kunde, der bisher glücklich war und dem in der Werbung jetzt versprochen wurde und von seinen ganzen Nordfreunden, dass iOS 7 das Geilste unter der Sonne ist. Und das musst du unbedingt haben, dann wird alles viel toller. Diese Person X, nichts ahnd, stößt dann auf dieses OS und innerhalb von sieben Tagen auf eine Myriade von Updates. Ich frage mich, wie die sich fühlen, wenn dann so die Hälfte auf einmal anders ist, als das bisher war, ohne dass es irgendwas anderes...
Also ich weiß nur eins, ich würde nie wieder zurück wollen.
Warum?
Weil das einfach schicker und moderner aussieht.
Ja, das andere sieht jetzt wirklich schon... Also jetzt das Alte, das Sexier krieg ich schon Zustände.
Das ist wie damals wahrscheinlich, als die schwarz-weiß geguckt haben und dann haben sie ein Farbfernseher gekauft. Da geht's einfach nicht mehr zurück.
Na, ich weiß nicht. Also es sieht schicker aus.
Das ist echt mal kein Argument für mich.
Momentan ist es noch ein Umbruch.
Du bist der Typ, der immer an den Geräten rumleckt. Und jetzt kommst du mit, mit schicker aus ist kein Argument für mich.
Ja, erstens finde ich nicht, dass es schicker aussieht.
Du hast es ja noch nicht mal. Du hast es ja noch nicht mal. Und auf Bildern, die du sehen, ist ja was anderes als es mal zu benutzen.
Ich habe auch schon dran rumgeleckt.
Ja, ich weiß schon, in zwei Wochen erzählt er, wie geil alles ist.
Dennis klingt so, als würde er manchmal, wenn er so ein bisschen laut spricht, als würde er durch die Klosche sprechen.
Da segle ich auch gegen den Kompressor.
Ja, wir segeln alle gerade ein bisschen gegen den Kompressor.
War der von Behringer?
Die Hörer müssen ein bisschen Verständnis haben. Wir haben das alle noch nie gemacht. Meinst du, da war drin in dem Forsthaus?
Ja, Pilze waren da drauf.
Oder in der Schoki. Deswegen reden wir ja auch so. Eigentlich hat er schon ein Stück Schokolade genascht?
In wenigen Minuten, nachdem er in der Schweizer Schokolade genascht hatte, begann er menschenwürdige Forderungen aufzustellen. Leute, die Internet für alle fordern, müssen sowieso an die Wand gestellt werden. Internet-Kommunisten. Lass uns mal bei den Facts bleiben. Was ist passiert? Also vor einer Woche war Kino, 10. September. Was habt ihr da gemacht? Wo wart ihr am 10. September?
Ich war an das für einen Tag.
War ich im Proberaum, glaub ich.
Das war der Tag als... Das iPhone vorgestellt worden.
Proberaum.
Das ist ja nicht schlecht. Das passt doch alles wunderbar zur Verkündigung. Dann kam erst mal wieder dieser...
Tim?
Ich hab die Kino übrigens noch nicht geguckt, weil ich dachte, so wenig, wie da jetzt der Announce wurde...
Tim Cook ist und bleibt einfach eine Schnarchnase. Der versaut mir irgendwie. Doch jetzt mittelfristig schon so ein bisschen den Spaß. Das kann irgendwie Phil Schiller alles gar nicht richtig rausholen.
Aber ich finde, er ist schon von zwei Valium auf eine Valium runter.
Er wird ja auch älter.
Er mag ja ein korrekter CEO sein und irgendwie diese Bude führen. Aber unter der Kategorie Charismatic Leader... Ich finde ihn jetzt nicht uncharismatisch. Tatsächlich mag ich ihn in seiner Art als Typ. Ist völlig in Ordnung. Die Frage ist nur, welche Rolle kann er in der Öffentlichkeit spielen? Er muss halt als Erster raus, weil er ist der fucking CEO.
Er schiebt aber viele Leute vor.
Aber ich finde, dass er für die Choreografie nicht unbedingt optimal ist. Johnny Ive ist ja...
Der war noch nie auf der Bühne, oder?
Der war noch nie auf der Bühne. Der sitzt in der ersten Reihe, der stellt sich da nicht hin, der macht nichts mal auf und ich frag mich ehrlich gesagt, warum eigentlich?
Du kannst ja nicht antun.
Vielleicht hat er... Vielleicht stottert er. In diesen ganzen Videos schneiden sie ihn immer wieder zusammen oder so. Man weiß es nicht.
Du meinst, er ist die ganze Zeit geremixed, dann wird er irgendwie so...
Er spricht immer so total ruhig. Der ist offenbar im Level.
Ja, den will ich auch nicht auf der Bühne sehen. Er geht auch immer mit seinen Händen und so. Ganz bedächtige, bedeutungsschwangere Blicke und so.
Mir hat einer ein Bild geschickt, wo man so sieht, wie er beide Hände so vorm Gesicht hat und drunter stand nur Clear Color. Ja, aber es sieht so aus, als hätte er ein Device in der Hand, was man halt nicht sieht, weil es ist Clear Color.
Ja, aber kannst du dir Tim Cook vorstellen, der wirklich ein Produkt dieses Unternehmens mal in die Hand nimmt und zeigt? Das hat er noch nie gemacht.
Das Einzige, was er zeigt, sind Zahlen.
Und Phil Schiller darf irgendwie die Geräte zeigen. Aber der CEO fasst seine eigene Scheiße nicht an. Das wäre Steve Jobs niemals passiert.
Ja, aber er lässt halt die anderen auch vor. Na gut, Phil Schiller durfte früher immer diesen Shootout gegen den PC machen.
Fass es an, wir sollten gleich eine Petition starten.
Wie soll die? Die sind Federico oder wie heißt der? Der macht es auch ganz gut. Der musste auch noch ein bisschen mehr Pep kriegen und seine Sachen. Er müsste ein bisschen mehr Niveau kriegen, aber ansonsten?
Ich fand die Witze ganz okay. Der war am Anfang ja ein bisschen zittrig.
Old Shatterhand.
War das der? Da gab es auch noch andere Namen.
Nee, das war der.
Doch, das war, wo er die Mausgesten vorführen sollte. Das passierte, das funktionierte irgendwie gar nichts. Und er wurde immer nervöser.
Schönen Gruß nach München, da bin ich natürlich Fanboys verseucht. Da heißt das Verpincher. Weil er halt den Pinch verkackt hat.
Der Verpincher, genau.
Bei uns heißt er Old Shatterhand.
Wer verkackt die Demo mehr? Nee, das war schon ein bisschen traurig. Er hat halt irgendwie die Gesten nicht hinbekommen, weil er so aufgeregt war. Aber mittlerweile ist er, glaube ich, irgendwie ordentlich Chef.
Also hier wird gerade ein Chat gepostet. Hier zeigt Cook iOS 6, aber er zeigt es uns halt fest nicht an, weil David Grohl hat es nämlich in der Hand.
He doesn't touch it.
Wir starten jetzt diese Conspiracy.
Genau, Aufgabe für den Chat. Sucht ein Bild mit Tim Cook, wo er ein Apple-Produkt in der Hand hält. Gibt es das überhaupt? Ich wäre jetzt auch ein bisschen bedrückt, wenn es wirklich gar keins ist.
Es war aber keine Keynote.
Also auf einer Keynote bin ich mir relativ sicher, dass er das noch nie gemacht hat. Oder könnt ihr euch an sowas erinnern, dass Tim Cook ein Apple-Device in der Hand gehabt hat?
Vielleicht hat er auch noch so ein Lenovo.
Ich meine, Steve Jobs hat auch so angefangen. Na, mit einem Syncpad, als er zu Apple wieder zurückkam.
Ja, aber der lief ja auch so ein Next-Step drauf.
Ja, genau.
Der hat gesagt, er gibt das nicht aus der Hand, bevor er nicht irgendwie... Mit der Presse wird also rumgemuckelt.
Das ist rein gefotoshoppt. Guck mal, der Kopf, der sieht nicht echt aus.
Das ist doch nicht Tim Cook.
Das ist gefotoshoppt.
Ich als Profi sehe das sofort. Also er hält ein iPad Mini in der Hand. Jetzt wird aber hier geguckt. Weiterleitungshinweis.
Blah, mein Gott, was ist denn das schon wieder? Google.
Ja, das ist komisch. Es soll mittlerweile sogar Leute geben, die might work and also arbeiten und da auch was essen. Also das ist ein ganz neuer Trend, dass die Leute ihre eigenen Produkte jetzt wieder...
Wahrscheinlich, weil man da Spreadsheets drauf fahren kann.
Auf den Burger?
Okay, noch ein bisschen mehr mit Inhalt hier.
Hat er sich auf der Keynote nicht verplappert? Und hat irgendwie von Pages und Spreadsheets gesprochen? Wobei, so ganz falsch war das auch nicht. Wie auch immer. Keynote fand statt, iOS 7, bla bla bla. Alles toll, erscheint jetzt. Und ist übrigens 64-Bit. Und...
Ja, nicht bei uns.
Nicht bei uns?
Ja, erst mit den neuen Geräten.
Das 5S ist 64-Bit.
Genau.
Und der Rest nicht.
Aber es ist halt sozusagen, Programmierer bedeutet das irgendwie ab jetzt auch 64-Bit, bitteschön. Und dann haben sie irgendwie noch... Was sind da hergeschmissen? Die komplette iWork-Suit und noch iPhoto.
Aber die bekommt man doch nur, wenn man ein neues Device kauft. Also du kriegst sie nicht, wenn du jetzt auf iOS 7 Updates kriegst, kannst du sie runterladen oder so, da kosten sie nach wie vor Geld.
Ja, wenn du jetzt nicht ein neues Gerät kaufst, dann musst du sie halt im App-Store kaufen.
Und wann wollte Microsoft jetzt ihr Office-Dings rausbringen? War gerade? Oder wie war das? Sind die nicht dann so ein bisschen gefreakt?
Ich weiß nicht, ist das draußen?
Ja, oder soll gerade kommen oder irgendwie so? Das heißt, die machen jetzt so die Google-Strategie, irgendwie die Sachen der Konkurrenz einfach für umsonst rauszutun.
Ja, das Timing ist vielleicht gar nicht das Schlechteste jetzt, wo wirklich so was gemunkelt wird, dass Microsoft mit irgendwas Office-mäßigen kommt.
Aber die munkeln doch seit Gefühlten, seitdem es iOS gibt, irgendwie, dass es mal ein Office dafür gibt.
Ja, aber es ist ja noch fieser, du lässt den Gegner erstmal richtig machen und die stecken ja da auch voll Geld und Zeit und alles rein. Und kurz bevor er fertig ist, da sagst du dann, ja, bringen wir jetzt auch raus. Sonst hätten sie ja gar nicht erst angefangen, weißt du? Und so haben sie dann nochmal ein paar Millionen mehr versenkt.
Interessant finde ich aber, dass es noch am alten iOS 6 Design gibt. Also irgendwie so, als würden sie sich jetzt nicht mehr trauen, das zu verkaufen, weil es nicht im iOS 7 Design ist.
Das Office-Zeugs?
Das iOS-Zeugs und diese ganzen Programme.
Also wie ist das noch schon?
Naja, das, was sie umsonst haben wollen.
Also das, was es jetzt auch schon gab, gibt es nach wie vor nur kostenlos. Mit einem neuen Gerät.
Das Apple-Zeugs, nicht das Microsoft-Zeugs.
Ja, Microsoft so kehrt.
Ich meine, Microsoft hat den größten Fehler seiner Unternehmensgeschichte gemacht und die Stärke des iPads nicht erkannt. Und jetzt sind sie mit Office so spät, dass einfach...
Ist immer noch genug Leute kaufen werden.
Ja, gar keine Frage. Aber sie haben diesen Nimbus eingebüßt, dass eine Plattform nur dann erfolgreich sein kann, wenn sie auch Office hat. Und iOS hat nun wirklich mal bewiesen, die am stärksten wachsende Plattform zu sein mit unglaublichen User-Zahlen. Was haben sie jetzt gesagt? 700 Millionen iOS-Devices. Das sind nicht unbedingt 700 Millionen User, aber... Plattform vor allem auch als Computing-Plattform, also auch mit seiner ganzen Abökonomie. Vorher musste immer irgendwie Office dabei sein. Was hat die Linux-Szene gemacht, um ihre Plattform für Behörden und für Firmen attraktiv zu machen? Open Office. Und es musste irgendwie das alles lesen und aufkönnen und so weiter.
Na ja, aber Open Office... Also ich hab das immer so verstanden, als wäre das der Versuch von Sun gewesen, Microsoft einen vor den Bug zu schießen. Das kam ja nicht aus der Linux-Community. Nee, nee, das stimmt.
Es kam trotzdem aus der Non-Microsoft.
Ja, aber auch Sun...
Ja gut, alle anderen sind Non-Microsoft.
Ich hab mich etwas undeutlich ausgedrückt, aber genau diese Einschätzung, dass du diese Plattform dann im Business erfolgreich machen kannst, wenn du da eben auch diesen Bereich abdecken kannst. Aber der Gewinner war bisher immer Microsoft. Es war einfach eine Plattform, die keinen durchschlagenden Erfolg hatte, ohne das. Und das ist halt hier nicht so, wie auch immer. Ja, was gibt es denn sonst noch Schönes zu sagen? Wie ist denn das mit dem 64-Bit?
Warum machen sie das?
Weil jetzt nutzen die gerade ARMv7 heißt das, die Architektur. Und bei ARMv8 ist jetzt eine komplett neue Architektur. Und die 64-Bit sind eigentlich gar nicht so entscheidend, sondern die Architektur selbst. Also die haben einfach alles neu redesigned und das ist das große Ding. Sie hätten ja auch die neue Architektur ohne 64-Bit nehmen können, aber die haben sich wahrscheinlich gedacht, wenn schon, dann schon, machen wir gleich einmal alles.
Aber haben die nicht jetzt vielleicht auch einfach Speicher, der mehr als vier Gigabyte annimmt?
Ich hab's mir ein bisschen näher angeguckt.
Ich auch, aber ich wollte es mal zusammenfassen.
Das ist aber ein interessanter Blickwinkel, den du da eröffnest, finde ich. Dass sie quasi einen Architekturwechsel machen, der aus ihren Augen signifikant ist. Und wo sie dann auch sagen, wenn wir jetzt auf die hier ein Minimum setzen, dann setzen wir das Minimum auch gleich auf 64-Bit. Wir fangen gar nicht alles an, auf dieser Code-Plattform so ein Legacy 32-Bit-Kram auszubauen.
Ja, aber einen ähnlichen Wechsel war ja auch die AMD 64-Plattform. Das ist ja im Prinzip auch ein komplett neues Design. Und ich glaube, sie haben auch den gesamten Instruction Set anders gemacht und so ähnlich macht das Arm auch nicht ganz so krass. Aber sie schmeißen halt sehr viel Zeug raus, die sie seit Arm 4 oder was das war irgendwie unterstützen.
Sie haben einmal komplett alles, also das komplettes Refactoring von der Hardware-Architektur, würde ich mal behaupten, so grob.
Und das eigentlich Interessanteste, so habe ich das verstanden, ist, das Arm war immer ein, oh Gott, wie hieß das? Das Arm hatte ein Weak Memory Model. Und zwar heißt es, dass der Prozessor beim Laden und Speichern von Daten die Reihenfolge der Lade- und Speicheroperationen vertauschen kann. Das hat zur Folge, dass wenn du als Programmierer sicherstellen willst, muss, dass irgendwas irgendwo im Speicher ankommt, bevor du es wieder neu liest, also gerade bei Multiprozessor-Architekturen, dass du dann mit irgendwelchen speziellen Befehlen, mit so Barrikaden und so ein Kram da irgendwie arbeiten musst. Und das kann sehr aufwendig werden. Und PowerPC war so ein Weak Memory Model. ARM ist so ein Weak Memory Model. Und was sie zu der Architektur 64 eingeführt haben, ist, dass es also auch Load- und Store-Operationen gibt, die nicht weak sind, sondern die strong sind und deren Reihenfolge nicht vertauscht wird. Weil das irgendwie, also ich muss jetzt ein bisschen passen bei den Details, weil das dem C- und C++-Modell, wie man Dinge macht, stärker entgegenkommt als dieses Weak-Modell, wo...
Weil sie nicht so viel absichern müssen. Es ist einfach performanter, es ist einfach gesichert, so zu machen, kann keine Seiteneffekte haben in dem kurzen Bereich sozusagen.
Also ich hab da so einen Artikel von diesen Herb-Sutter gelesen. Das ist doch dieser C++-Super-Freak, der immer die Bücher schreibt, was man im C++ nicht machen darf. Und der hat halt geschrieben, dass seiner Meinung nach das ist halt so eine Tendenz in dem Prozessorbau weg von der Weak-Architektur zur Strong-Memory-Architektur und dass die Arm-8-Architektur halt jetzt dieses Strong-Modell einführt. Ein ganz klarer Hinweis seiner Meinung nach, dass die überlegen ist.
Den Begriff kannte ich als solches noch gar nicht.
Das war in dem Paper, das du da verlinkt hast, war das drin und deswegen habe ich da mal geguckt und gesucht. Ach du hast das verlinkt? Dieses Arm-8-Architektur PDF.
Ich hab mal fleißig da vollgemüllt alles.
Ja, da müssen wir uns sozusagen vorher nochmal darüber unterhalten, was jetzt wirklich drin gelandet ist.
Also das Ding ist auch, dass sie die Arm-Architektur nicht einfach um 64-Bit- Befehle erweitert haben, sonst wär's halt wirklich nicht so doll, sondern du hast halt jetzt doppelt so viele Integer-Register, doppelt so viele Floating-Point-Register, dann ist noch Krypto-Support dazugekommen, und zwar irgendwie Kommandos für AES und Shard 256 und so. Und ja, all sowas. Und Parameterübergabe oder was hab ich gelesen ist auch irgendwie anders. Aber da hab ich jetzt nicht ganz genau geguckt. Aber auf jeden Fall ist das der Grund, warum es halt insgesamt auch einen Speed-Gewinn gibt. Weil nur 64-Bit würde ja einfach heißen, dass nur die Pointer doppelt so groß sind und mehr Memory verbraucht wird. Das heißt, es würde ganz bisschen langsamer werden. Aber durch mehr Register und den ganzen anderen Kram ist da deutlich was zu holen und ist schneller.
Also was ich auch extrem interessant fand, waren diese Exception-Levels. Ich weiß nicht, ob es die unter ARM V7 auch schon gab. Aber irgendwie haben die dieses Intel-Ring-Ding übernommen, dass der Prozessor verschiedene Betriebsmodi hat, die immer weniger dürfen. Bei denen ist es nur andersrum. Also Exception-Level 0 ist quasi der User-Space. Und Exception-Level 3 ist so der unterste Kernel-Space. Und die beschreiben dann in dem Paper auch noch, dass man da irgendwie ein Virtual Machine Monitor oder Hypervisor irgendwie im Exception-Level 2 unterbringen kann und solche Sachen. Also da ist wirklich einiges passiert.
Also Virtualisierung sozusagen, Support.
Virtualisierung auf Prozessorebene, Support, ja. Und das sieht so ein bisschen aus, als wollten sie mit der Architektur auch eher Richtung Desktop als ewig irgendwie in dem Mobile Space bleiben.
Das heißt, wir warten jetzt auf irgendwie VMWare für das iPhone, in dem denn Windows 8-Phone läuft oder so?
Oder eine VMWare für ARM 8, was in einem MacBook Air läuft, wo trotzdem noch Intel-Windows-Performant.
Nee, ich finde so eine VMWare-Phone, wo man denn Android drauf laufen lassen kann, auch lustig. Oder Windows-Phone 8.
Ja, du meinst sozusagen, du fährst beides.
Country und Western sozusagen.
Country und Western.
Intel, ja, interessanter Punkt. Es gab ja jetzt die Gerüchte, dass, oder sagen wir mal so, es gibt eine ziemliche Klarheit, dass diese 64-Bit-Architektur, also diese, wie heißt er, A7-Prozessor, nicht von Samsung gebaut ist, sondern von jemand anders. Und da gibt es irgendwie diese taiwanesische Bude, wie heißt die nochmal? War das das? Irgendwie sowas, ja. Und naja, jetzt gab es hier diesen anderen Artikel, da ist auf Daring Fireball, wo dann jemand so ein bisschen nachgerechnet hat, meinte ja, TSMC meint zwar, dass sie 2014 so weit werden, diesen Prozess, der hier verwendet wurde, nämlich irgendwie 20 Nanometer in den Größenordnungen dann auch in der Produktionsstraße zu haben, weil sie sprechen ja von einer Milliarde Transistoren auf einem 102, was soll man die Maßeinheit, Quadratmillimeter?
Mikro.
Wahrscheinlich Quadratmillimeter.
Wird das hin? 10 Millimeter, wie groß ist denn der Stein? Zentimeter, wie groß ist diese A7? Der ist doch schon relativ groß, so der in der Mitte.
Also 100 müsste ein Zentimeter mal ein Zentimeter sein.
Der ist bestimmt nicht Zentimeter groß, der ist bestimmt Inches groß oder so.
Die hier angegebene Größe oder die festgestellte Größe mit der versprochenen Dichte, also Menge an Transistoren, liegt nahe, dass das Ding irgendwie auf 20 oder 22 Nanometer gebaut werden sollte, müsste. Aber dass diese taiwanesische Bruder es nicht kann. Wer es aber kann, ist Intel. Weil Intel im Prinzip jetzt mit Haswell genau an diesen Dichten angekommen ist, nur dass sie sehr viel größere und leistungsfähigere Transistoren bauen. Und wenn du halt so was wie den A7 bauen würdest, ist es halt viel kleiner. Aber wenn du denselben Prozess verwendest, würdest du eben auf diese Milliardentransistoren kommen auf der Fläche, die der A7 bietet. Und das ist halt neben Samsung eine der Unternehmen, die sowas halt bauen können. Weil sonst kann ja auch nicht jeder bauen. Du gehst ja nicht irgendwie nach Norwegen und sagst, ich bin da nicht im Tag.
Aber da haben die Intel Leute da gar keinen Bock drauf. Die wollen doch ihre eigenen Chips verkaufen.
Intel ist so froh, wenn sie im Mobile Space irgendwie ihre FAPs ausgenutzt bekommen. Ich meine, die verkaufen ja auch... Ich meine, diese Zeit, wo ein CPU-Hersteller seine CPUs baut und die unter der eigenen Namen auf den Markt bringt, die sind halt auch ein bisschen vorbei. Das macht halt Intel. Aber die allermeisten Buden, die Prozessoren bauen, bauen das sozusagen im Auftrag von und meistens halt irgendwelche Buden, die einfach das Arm-Design nehmen oder einen fertigen Arm-Chip, der mal von einer anderen Firma designt wurde. Dann gehen sie dahin und sagen ja guten Tag und hier nochmal bitte das IO dazu und wir hätten gerne noch hier die Ports und so weiter. Also ein System-on-a-Chip zusätzlich zu dieser fertigen Prozessor-Architektur. Wir heißen die Snapdragon und diese ganzen Sachen, die halt auch in den Android-Phones häufig drin sind, Qualcomm baut die, ne? Und das kommt halt so, Fab sagt, also guten Tag, ich hätte hier einen Prozessor-Design in der Tasche, kann ich hier meinen OS-Bere-Stick reinstecken und dann drucken wir das halt irgendwie hinten im Keller. So, mit dem 3D-Penta. Er ist halt ein bisschen aufwendiger.
Ich werde dann der Kiste Mate.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass der Chip nicht von Intel ist.
Nein, der ist nicht von Intel. Auch nicht in deren Fab gemacht. Na ja, es könnte halt sein.
Ich wette dagegen.
Mit dem Prozessorvolumen, was Apple auf den Tisch bringt, da sagen die aber Dankeschön für das Geld.
Ja, würden sie sagen, aber die haben halt auch genug Geld und wollen ihre eigenen Atoms irgendwie in den Mobilmarkt kriegen. Und das kriegen sie nicht, wenn sie noch irgendwie schicker A7s machen, dann gibt es ja noch weniger Grund, dass man jemals ein Atom bringt.
Ja, aber die A7 kriegt Apple ohnehin gebaut. Die Frage ist nur, ob sie die Kohle mitnehmen oder nicht.
Ja, das kann sein, das ist eine politische Entscheidung, sondern keine marktwirtschaftliche. Aber ich sag dir, die sind nicht von Intel.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Intel den Auftrag schon allein deswegen annehmen würde, weil sie dann an die Pläne kommen von dem Scheißding.
Nö, der Grund ist einfach ein anderer. Der Punkt ist, dass auch sich für Intel das Business ändert. Und auch Intel wird einen großen Teil seines Geldes mit dem Bauen von Prozessoren von was weiß ich für SOTs.
Hält nicht Intel auch einen gewissen Anteil an Arm?
Ja, die haben doch diese Strong-Arm gekauft oder so was.
Nein.
Also hergestellt und ich weiß nicht, ob sie die abgestoßen haben.
Ja, haben sie. Und zwar vor langer, langer Zeit hat Intel seine Armlizenzen verkauft. War wahrscheinlich auch...
An, zurück oder?
Sehr lange her. Müsste ich nachschlagen. Sicherlich im Strong-Arm.
Das heißt, die haben da gar kein, wie sagt man, ein Bein mehr im Boot?
Nee, sie haben halt gedacht, hier unsere Architektur gewinnt sowieso alles. Und Windows Everywhere und Pipapo, die sind Microsoft da genauso auf den Leim gegangen. Und sie haben natürlich irgendwie immer versucht, stromsparend zu sein, aber sie sind halt niemals auch nur im Ansatz in die Richtung gekommen, wo sich...
Also hier postet einer, der sagt, es ist ziemlich...
Was?...
probably pretty safe to say that the A7 SoC ist built by Samsung. Anand Tek sagt das und die sind eigentlich nicht so schlecht. Und zwar 28 Nanometer und nicht 22. Ja, nicht. Ich denke, die bei Intel, vor allem die 22 Nanometer Fab, da hat Intel, die ist einfach gut ausgelassen. Die baut jetzt halt Hasbels und allen anderen Scheißen, die ein Intel halt so braucht. Also da haben die gar keinen Platz.
17. September?
Aber er weiß es ja auch nicht, ne? Also die rätseln noch. Aber wie gesagt, ich glaub nicht, dass das Apple damit...
Nein, steht's ja auf den Slides.
Also ein Zentimeter mal ein Zentimeter, was schon relativ viel ist.
Na ja, passt halt schon noch rein in so ein Telefon.
Ja, wenn man den Screen größer macht, kann man auch einen Prozessor größer machen.
Grummel, grummel.
Na gut, ich meine, für den CPU wäre es eine Menge Platz mittlerweile, aber für den SoC...
Interessante Frage war ja auch noch, wie macht Apple das eigentlich? Liefern die 32-Bit-Libraries und 64-Bit-Libraries aus? Und halten sie beides im Speicher oder nicht?
Also bei Mac OS ist es so.
Bei Mac OS ist es auch genug Platz. Da ist es dann auch egal.
Ja, das bedeutet aber, wenn du dann ein Mix drauf hast auf den Dingern, selbst wenn du die sharen, musst du halt dieselben Libraries doppelt drauf haben. Einmal als 64-Bit, einmal 32-Bit-Variante.
Bei iOS 7 auch diese Compression-Geschichte, wie bei Mavericks?
So, und jetzt hab ich in diesem Paper nochmal genau nachgeguckt, weil ich fand die Frage eigentlich spannend. Und zwar, wenn die Libraries tatsächlich im gleichen Exception-Level aufgerufen werden, wie die App, die selber läuft, dann geht's nicht, weil sie schreiben hier eindeutig a no-branch and link between 32-Bit und 64-Bit-Architecture. Also du kannst nicht einfach in 64-Bit-Code springen und wieder zurück, das geht nicht. Von 32-Bit aus. Aber wenn man einen der Exception-Levels wechselt, dann kannst du auch von 32-Bit in 64-Bit-Code reinspringen und nach dem Rückwechseln wieder zurück in den 32-Bit-Code. Die Frage ist, machen sie das? Liefern sie die ganzen Libraries so aus, dass sie in einem anderen Exception-Level laufen oder nicht? Keine Ahnung, wird wahrscheinlich nächste Zeit zeigen.
Was heißt das eigentlich bei diesem A7? Ich meine, wenn das Ding jetzt einen komplett neuen Instruktionssatz hat auf 64-Bit, heißt das, dass sie in 32-Bit den alten haben? Ja.
Der ist auf 32-Bit komplett kompatibel und hat sogar unter 32-Bit auch noch Enhancements.
Also der kann auch ARMv8 in 32-Bit, aber wahrscheinlich kann er auch noch ARMv7 in 32-Bit.
Also hier in dem Paper, das ist irgendwie, genau, dritte Slide, 32-Bit Architektur und 64-Bit Architektur nebeneinander.
Was?
Ja, von diesem ARM Architektur.
Ach so, hier, das Teil. Wir entschuldigen uns bei den Hörern hier. Also wir reden von diesem PDF hier.
Von dem PDF, genau.
Hier in den Links übrigens.
Und auf der dritten Seite, noch eine weiter, noch eine weiter, gibt's die große Übersicht. Von ARMv5, v6, v7 auf ARMv8. Und in ARMv8 ist eindeutig zu sehen, dass er 32-Bit und 64-Bit-Architektur komplett unterstützt. Und dann hat er noch irgendwelche Krypto-Modi.
A ist der neue, sozusagen. A-Profil.
Nee, AARCH64 ist der neue und AARCH32 ist der alte.
Sicher?
Ja, aber das heißt, dass sie den nur in 32-Bit anbieten.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass sie diese Sachen, also Thumb 2 noch unter AARCH32 machen, aber den ganzen anderen Kram nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Was ist denn das alles für ein Name? SIMD, ach so hieß es dann wirklich die ersten.
NEON ist das, was sozusagen so der SSD von ARM, SSD, SSE, schuldigung.
SIMD Advanced, das ist die zweite Version von der ersten SIMD. Genau, das hatten sie schon bei V6 und jetzt haben sie es auch noch bei V7 neu. Blablabla, alles sehr unübersichtlich, wenn man jetzt nicht dieses PDF vor der Nase hat. Wir fassen zusammen, diese Architektur, die entwickelt sich weiter.
Und auf dieser Hardware ist entwickelt sich Genossenbauern.
Super zusammenfasst.
Was viele Leute nicht verstehen, und ich wackele jetzt nämlich auch gerade wieder, ist so dieser relativ komplexe Zusammenhang zwischen den Architekturen, die definiert sind, also der Instruction Set, den ARM, die Firma ARM selber festlegt.
Instruction Set Architecture, genau.
Instruction Set Architecture, so, dann gibt es die von ihnen beschriebenen System-Designs, die du da lizenzieren und dann in einen konkreten Chip hinein selber implementieren darfst, bauen lassen darfst, dann hast du was, was so funktioniert, wie das gedacht ist dafür. Das sind diese V-Architekturen da unten, V5, V6.
Nee, V bezieht sich auch auf den Instructionset.
Der teilt sich dann in zwei Architekturen sozusagen.
Genau.
In 32 und in 64. Genau. Aber dann gibt es noch eine Bezeichnung für die eigentlichen, jetzt komme ich wieder selber ins Schleudel. Auf jeden Fall kannst du das ja auch alles selber implementieren.
Für die eigentlichen Verdrahtungen gibt es ja diese Bezeichnung Cortex so und so viel, Cortex so und so viel, Cortex so und so viel. Das sind dann wiederum die Designs, die ARM ausliefert, die du dann dir anpassen lassen kannst.
Davon macht sich Apple aber ein eigenes Design und keinen Cortex, richtig? Und dafür brauchen sie eine Volllizenz bei ARM, die richtig teuer ist.
Oh Gott, das weiß ich nicht.
Ja genau.
Aber sie haben die Leute, die das können.
Ja, also die ersten Prozessoren, die sie in den iPhones hatten, das waren halt fertige Designs von anderen, die sie dann mit ihrem System Environment angereichert haben. Und das war dann ihre konkrete Implementierung.
Ich glaub, bis 3GS inklusive iOS Support Matrix hatten wir das letzte Mal schon.
Genau, bis es dann halt A4 hieß. Und A4 heißt halt auch, wir haben uns jetzt auch den Prozessor ausgedacht. Wir haben jetzt eine eigene CPU-Abteilung und die baut halt diesen Scheiß.
Warum sie beide sich ausdenken?
Bei vier Anfangen, das wird wahrscheinlich immer ein Rätsel bleiben.
Vielleicht weil sie früher schon mal welche gemacht haben, weil die haben ja Arme halt mitgegründet.
Du hast ja auch nicht IPv1 benutzt, ne?
Es kann sein, dass sie zum Beispiel ihre internen Designs... Sie nennen es erst öffentlich vielleicht A4, nachdem alles von ihnen ist. Und als vorher noch Sachen von anderen drin waren, hieß das nur internen Architektur 1, 2, 3.
Gut, kann sein.
Ich glaube, das war dann nämlich auch der vierte Schritt. Na ja, also auf jeden Fall, da passiert eine ganze Menge. Und wenn ich das aber jetzt richtig lese, ist, wenn du ein 64-Bit-Programm hast, muss es zwangsläufig den neuen Instruktionssatz nehmen.
Ja, weil der 64-Bit-Instruktionssatz ist halt anders als der 32-Bit-Instruktionssatz.
Genau, und wenn 32, dann ist es quasi der alte, plus noch so ein paar spezifische Erweiterungen, die jetzt auch nicht geschadet haben.
Du, keine Ahnung. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie aus auch ein 32-Bit-Instruktionssatz am V8 abgespeckt irgendwann mal rausbringen. Momentan sieht es nicht danach aus, aber frage man sich so vorstellen, wie bei den 64-Bit-Chips von Intel, wo der AMD 64-Befehlssatz auch komplett anders ist. Und wenn du ein 64-Bit-Programm kompilierst, dann ist es der AMD 64-Befehlssatz. Ansonsten ist es der gute X86-Befehlssatz für 32-Bit.
Die Frage ist, hätten sie auch einen Weg gehabt, den neuen Prozessor doppelt so schnell zu machen, und der ist immer noch 32-Bit?
Die Argumentation ist ja, dass dieses Überholen des Instruktionssets und anderer architektureller Sachen eben so viel Speed rausgeholt hat, dass das 64-Bit-Machen, was tendenziell eher die Sache langsamer macht, weil du ja mehr Daten laden musst in den Prozessor, ist ja plötzlich alles größer, mehr als wegmacht.
Ja, wenn deine Memo-Architektur dahinter ist.
Du, wenn Pointer nicht mehr 32-Bit, sondern 64-Bit lang sind, musst du doppelt so viel Zeug laden.
Ja, aber wenn deine Memo-Architektur eh so breit ist, ist das ein Clock-Cycle. Dann lädst du halt immer 64-Bit.
Du brauchst mehr Speicher.
Du brauchst mehr Speicher und musst mehr Speicher laden.
Du brauchst mehr Speicher, dadurch wird es nicht notwendigerweise langsamer. Der wird ja nicht seriell geladen.
Der hat ja auch mehr Speicher, das 5S. Na ja, also ich wollte auch was anderes hinaus.
Ist das nicht die Erkenntnis, dass es mehr Speicher hat?
Nein, Moment, Moment. Aber deine Argumentation ist insofern nicht richtig, dass unter der PowerPC-Architektur war das ja so, dass die PowerPC-64-Architektur ziemlich genau die gleiche Architektur war, wie die PowerPC-32-Architektur.
Weil die halt schon gut vorbereitet waren.
Weil die vorher schon gut waren, so gut wie sie halt waren.
Die hatten den Gewinn sozusagen vorher schon.
Genau, die hatten den Gewinn vorher schon in 32 Bit reingeholt und haben dann nur alles verdoppelt. Und sind dadurch dann aber nur einige wenige Prozent. Aber sie sind hinterher langsamer gewesen. In 64 Bit-Code als in 32 Bit-Code.
Nochmal, wenn deine Memory-Architektur hinten dran an dem Ding bloß 32 Bit breit ist, dann brauchst du natürlich bei einer 64 Bit-Architektur immer zwei Clock-Cycles. Ging ja früher schon. Du konntest ja schon auf 32 Bit-Prozessoren auch 64 Bit-Werte aus dem Speicher lesen. Nur, das muss da halt ein bisschen, das muss da halt dem doppelt machen.
Das hat aber damit nichts zu tun, weil du ja auch einen 32 Bit-Prozessor mit 64 Bit in dein Speicher anbieten kannst.
Ja, aber du tust jetzt so, als würden die jetzt seriell gelesen werden. Dann dauert das natürlich doppelt so lange. Aber warum sollte das bei, wenn du die ganze Architektur breiter machst, warum sollte das langsamer werden?
Du machst aber nicht die ganze Architektur breiter, du machst ja erstmal nur das Instruction-Set breiter.
Ja, dann wird es natürlich langsamer.
Wenn du lange Reste mit Pointer hast und du musst da langfahren, dann ist auch dein Cash ja gleich groß und dann wird es langsamer.
Wenn du das Memory-Model und deine Cashes auch breiter machst, wird es nicht langsamer.
Aber das ist ja das, was nicht in real life passiert.
Ich lasse mich mal anders aufziehen, weil diese Debatte, ob es jetzt schneller oder langsamer ist, ist vollkommen egal. Die Frage ist nur, Apple wollte auf 64 bit, weil sie da verschiedene strategische Vorteile sehen. Es gibt eine echte Verbesserung des Befehlssatzes, was in the long run Dinge einfacher macht. Und besser skaliert und vielleicht bestimmte Arten.
Nicht in the long run. In the short run ist er einfach doppelt mal so schnell.
Stopp, stopp, stopp. Ich rede von der Architektur. Ich rede nicht von diesem Prozessor. Wenn du jetzt die Aufgabe gehabt hättest, das iPhone 5S zu planen. Und die Entscheidung steht an, bauen wir einen 32-Bit Prozessor oder bauen wir einen 64-Bit Prozessor. Diese Entscheidung muss irgendwann vor zwei Jahren gefallen sein. Als keiner von uns sich über sowas überhaupt auch nur annähernd unterhalten hat. Dann ist halt die Frage, was versprichst du dir davon? Von dem Wechsel der Architektur langfristig, dass du das Risiko oder die Herausforderungen in Kauf nimmst, vielleicht schon deutlich früher auf 64-Bit zu gehen, als es wirklich nötig wäre, weil nötig ist es nicht. Man könnte wahrscheinlich auch einen schnelleren 32-Bit-Prozessor bauen. Vielleicht wäre der nur 1,7-mal so schnell gewesen, aber vielleicht wäre er auch viel, viel, viel billiger gewesen.
Aber auf lange Zeit willst du doch eh umstellen und in zwei Jahren kommen iPhones mit 4 GB und dann brauchst du das.
Jetzt mixen wir aber auch zwei unterschiedliche Dinge. Also das eine ist natürlich klar, mit 64-Bit kannst du mehr Speicher adressieren und spätestens bei 4 GB ist die Diskussion erreicht, wo man sagen muss, jetzt muss ich auf 64-Bit gehen, weil mehr kann ich nicht adressieren. Punkt. Da sind wir aber noch nicht. Da sind wir vielleicht in zwei Jahren, vielleicht schon vorher, man weiß es nicht.
Na ja, also...
Zu sagen, ich mache das jetzt, damit ich in zwei Jahren kein Problem hab, ist schön und gut, aber die Übergangszeit hast du eh. Also ich denke mal, das war jetzt nicht unbedingt die treibende Kraft, sondern die treibende Kraft ist wirklich, der 64-Bit-Teil von diesem Chip ist so viel besser, dass es sich lohnt, jetzt auf 64-Bit zu gehen, weil du damit, weiß ich nicht, nach irgendwelchen Benchmarks jetzt mal eben das schnellste Smartphone auf dem Markt bauen kannst, weil die anderen halt alle diesen Prozessor nicht haben, der so unglaublich schnell ist. Und das ist, denke ich mal, die Hauptentscheidung gewesen.
Das schnellste Teil zu haben. Ja gut, aber wenn sie vor zwei Jahren geglaubt hätten, dass sie vielleicht mit dem Auskitzeln von den üblichen Skalierfaktoren auf dem selben Instruction Set auch dieses Ziel der Geschwindigkeit erreicht hätten, aber halt ein Jahr später den 64-Bit-Architekturwechsel gemacht hätten.
Na wie, du willst ja schon wieder die Architekturwechsel, willst du gerade am Abend vor 8 wechseln?
Nein, versteht mich doch mal. Ich versuche, die Strategie nachzuvollziehen, die jetzt abläuft in so einem Unternehmen, wenn sie sich dafür entscheiden, machen wir es so oder machen wir es so. Also was ist sozusagen die Verheißung an 64-Bit? Die ganze Verheißung ist doppelt so schnell, das ist super, aber wir wissen, es hat auch eine ganze Menge andere.
Du, Chef, ich bin Techniker und ich sagte, wir können dieses Jahr die Architektur wechseln und nächstes Jahr wechseln wir dann nochmal auf 64-Bit oder wir können gleich beides auf einmal machen. Was würdest du denn sagen, was wir machen?
Ja, würde ich sagen, was kostet uns denn dieser Prozess und welche Firmen können das in der Skalierung bauen, die wir unbedingt brauchen? Ja, welchen Laden suchen wir uns da und machen wir das immer noch mit Samsung?
Also ich glaube, dass die Entscheidung, auf 64-Bit zu gehen, die war natürlich da. Das will man natürlich irgendwann machen. Das müssen jetzt die anderen auch leisten. War glaube ich für Apple nicht so schwierig. Weil Apple hat in den letzten zehn Jahren, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Architekturen gewechselt. Die haben da inzwischen Übung drin, Architekturen zu wechseln. Also das ist irgendwie jetzt nicht so ein Ding. Aber zu sagen, da verspricht uns jemand einen Chip. Wenn wir den gebaut kriegen und an den Start kriegen, dann ist der so viel schneller als alles, was die Konkurrenz kann. Weil die Konkurrenz hat nicht das Instruction Set, was so schnell ist. Ich hab noch ein ganz anderes Chip.
Moment, bist du dir sicher, dass das jetzt so ist, dass dieser Prozessor sehr viel schneller ist, als all das, was jetzt noch auf 32-Bit-Basis in der Android-Welt vor allem auf den Markt kommt?
Irgendwo hatte ich das gelesen. Ich glaube, auf Derrick Fireball hatte da was.
Ich hab noch ein ganz großes Grund, warum es wichtig ist. Und zwar, weil sie den A7 auch für OS X Sachen benutzen können. Weil das schon alles 64-Bit und Mavericks wird nicht, oder was auch immer da kommt, wird nicht wieder plötzlich 32-Bit machen. Und wenn die da irgendeinen Mini-Rechner, das nächste MacBook Air, vielleicht mit einem A7 irgendwie ausstatten, der vielleicht quattert oder ein bisschen mehr Gigahertz.
Na ja, das sehe ich jetzt noch nicht so, aber... Aber vielleicht...
Schnell, das ist billig, verbraucht noch weniger Strom.
Ja, aber welchen Vorteil hätten sie davon? Schlauftzeit. Schneller als die Fortschritte. Meinst du, dass das Arm jetzt schon in der Lage ist, Intel einzuholen?
Also der Gruber meint irgendwie, das iPhone 5S von den Speed-Vergleichen wäre schon ein Stück schneller als sein 2008er MacBook Pro.
Er hat es schon. Er hat es schon.
Ganz schön krass, so ein kleines Telefon. Was hat er geschrieben? In your fucking pocket.
Ja, er hat irgendwie JavaScript-Performance verantwortet unter verschiedenen Browsern verglichen, soweit ich weiß.
Ja gut, aber wir reden jetzt hier von einem Performance-Unterschied von fünf Jahren.
Ist trotzdem schon nicht schlecht.
Okay, also ich will ja gar nicht ausschließen.
Und man kann ihn ja in so einem Gerät auch viel schneller takten.
Ja gut, aber da frag ich mich halt auch wieder, warum sollten sie das tun?
Das Interessante ist...
Entschuldigung, warte kurz. Dieser Grund, warum ich darauf so rumbohre, könnte es nicht vielleicht auch bedeuten, dass sie tatsächlich auch ein Gerät in der Palpline haben auf dieser Architektur. Was sehr wohl 64 bit unbedingt braucht. Nicht optional vielleicht, sondern was es auf jeden Fall benötigt.
Warum nicht jetzt?
Der Laptop hab ich doch gerade gesagt.
Was ist das denn jetzt im Kopf? So ein Gerät im Handgelenk?
Nein, am Wohnzimmer.
Ach du, mit deinem Fernseher. Nein, brauchst du nicht. Fernseher, Spielekonsole.
Alles was ein Netzteil hat, kannst du auch in einen Intel Prozessor reinführen.
Wie viel RAM hat denn so eine Xbox?
Aber ganz ehrlich, fern gucken kannst du auch mit einem Raspberry Pi.
Außerdem kommt es auch nicht auf die Plattform an, sondern auf das OS, was du da draufpacken willst. Und wenn die da ein Mavericks draufpacken wollen, dann solltest du es mit 64-bit machen.
Wie heißt die aktuelle Xbox 27?
Ich glaube wir haben so...
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht entscheidend. Also wenn du ein Gerät hast, was ein Netzteil hat, was sowieso an der Steckdose hängt, dann ist der Vorteil, dass du vor einem stromsparenden Arm-Chip ja gleich null hast. Dann kannst du auch einen In-Teil reintun. Wärme.
Na ja, das ist doch nur Apple TV 1. Generation, Apple TV 2.
Okay, wir können jetzt ja bald noch eine Stunde reden, wir wissen es nicht.
Also eine Xbox One hat 8 GB RAM. Und die ist halt auch ein Medien-Durchschauffler zwischen Speicher und Spiele, Effizienzspieler etc.
Ja, dazu müsstest du aber erstmal ein Arm-Chip produzieren, wo du überhaupt so viel Speicher ranklemmen kannst. Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Arms mal so eben einen Memory-Controller mit dabei haben, wo du normale RAM-Riegel rankleben kannst. Also sowas müsstest du überhaupt erstmal entwickeln, glaube ich. Also das ist irgendwie...
Ja, da bräuchte man eine Firma, die ihre eigenen System-On-The-Chips und CPUs macht.
Komisch, kennen wir da einen. Macht Apple sowas nicht?
Ja, doch, machen sie.
Das bauen die sich einfach dazu.
Ja, aber das bringt es auch nur bei einem High-Volume-Gerät. Wenn du jetzt von Apple TV oder der Apple TV mit Bildschirm, wie auch immer, redest, weißt du, wenn du ein 32-Bit-Screen hast, dann kannst du da auch einen Intel dahinter tun. Das ist mit Wärmeentwicklung und so. Das ist einfach die Diskussion, halte ich für Unsinn. Ich rede nicht von einem Schachtel.
Ich rede nicht von einem Fernseher. Ich rede von so einem Beistell. Ich rede von dem Apple TV, von dieser kleinen Box.
Ja, aber wozu braucht die 8 GB?
Weil sie so Dinge macht, die sie bisher nicht getan hat.
Die da wären? Spielkonsole sein, oder?
Zum Beispiel.
Also du redest davon, dass Apple eine Spielkonsole in Größe eines Apple TV rausbringen möchte.
Nee, ich sag nur, man kann sich ja durchaus Szenarien vorstellen, wo mehr RAM auch mal nötig ist und wo es unter Umständen einen Zwang gibt auf 64.000.
Ja, aber die Szenarien müssen ja glaubwürdig sein. Also ich meine, das ist ja...
Jetzt soll ich auch noch glaubwürdig rüberkommen, oder was? Ja. Naja, lass uns mal vorwärts machen. Ich glaub, das führt zu alles gar nix.
Ich glaub auch. Jetzt haben wir... Aber für mich als Nerd war das schon der einzige Grund, dass ich schon weiß, ich will so ein Ding haben. Dann setz ich mit.
Ja, irgendwie schon. Lustig ist ja, im Export hast du ja jetzt diese... Du kannst ja dann auch die Simulatoren auswählen. Und du hast halt dann den iPhone 4 Zoll Display 64 Bit Simulator, wo du dann deine 64 Bit kompilierten Sachen drin laufen lassen kannst. Der kann aber nur iOS 7.
Weißt du noch nicht, der Einzige, was mich daran interessieren würde, weil diese ganze Prozessor-Power, ich spiele nicht mit dem Ding, ganz ehrlich, da ist mir die Glotze zu kleben. Ich bin über 40, das geht nicht mehr. Und WoW gibt es nicht für das Ding, und bei der anderen spiele ich nicht. Wir haben ja mal ganz banal gesagt, okay, ich geh jetzt wieder Kommentare für, und es ist mir scheißegal. Aber was mich interessieren würde, wären so Network-Capabilities, und da ist halt das einzige, was hinten rausfällt, ist, dass sie jetzt mal entdeckt haben, dass es außerhalb der USA auch noch andere LTE-Vender gibt. Und da hat er aber in Deutschland immer noch kein vernünftiges LTE-Angebot gibt, mit einem vernünftigen Preis dazu oder sowas. Halt ich mich da derzeit noch ein bisschen zurück.
Es sind ja fünf Geräte, ne? Wenn du in die Tech-Specs guckst, gibt es irgendwie fünf Versionen von diesen fünf S. Und man blickt hinten und vorne nicht durch.
Das ist aber nicht die viel Neues. Vorher waren es nur drei. Ja, vorher waren es nur drei. Aber das ist einfacher erklärlich. Du guckst dir einfach diese Bänder an, was wo ist und wo du dich rumtreibst. Vielleicht kommen wir vielleicht noch dazu, steht im Workflow ein bisschen weiter hinten. Wenn ihr alle wieder kaputt seid, dann muss ich wieder was über Telekom erzählen, dann wird da endgültig einschlaft. Ihr kennt das schon. Aber das ist relativ einfach zu durchschauen. Und ich verstehe immer noch nicht, warum sie das nicht so machen, dass das halt einfach mal überall geht.
Aber eine Frage, ob ihr der Experte bist, die haben ja da iPhone-Modelle, die sagen wir mal fünf Bänder haben. Und dann aber auch iPhone-Modelle, die ein Subset genau der exakten Bänder hat. Also warum bringen sie dann trotzdem zwei Modelle raus, wenn das eine Modell doch exakt die Bänder von dem anderen hat, nur dass das wenige hat?
Du musst mal gucken, die haben da manchmal noch einen anderen Quack dran. Die haben da zum Beispiel noch irgendwie CDMA drin, dass du das bei Verizon benutzen kannst oder so. Es gibt ja nicht nur LTE oder GSM oder UMTS auf der Welt. Da muss man mal gucken, was die drin haben. Ansonsten, wenn das nicht so ist, wäre auch noch eine Erklärung, das Zeug ist natürlich teuer. Das müssen sie von Qualcomm teuer einkaufen. Und wenn du halt ein Ding billig haben willst, guck mal da oben zum Beispiel, der zweite von oben CDMA. Der hat noch diese Dinge.
Also geht es gar nicht um die LTE-Sachen, sondern den anderen Sachen, wo die sich von dort unterscheiden.
Lass uns doch mal kurz die Modelle machen. Das erste ist ein GSM-Modell.
Das kann dann auch T-Mobile USA.
Das ist das erste iPhone, das überhaupt richtig T-Mobile GSM.
T-Mobile USA.
Ja, T-Mobile USA, Frequenzen, also diese 1700 sind ja nur T-Mobile USA.
Aber zum Beispiel, wenn du mal guckst, das kann keine 1800. Also hier zum Beispiel in Deutschland, hättest du Sorgen damit?
Was, Wovi, was?
Ach doch, Entschuldigung, eins tiefer. Aber sie machen keine HSDP-A da drauf? Okay, gut, ist klar.
Was soll ich auf 1800 machen?
Aber sie machen kein... Sie machen GSM-Edger da drauf. Ich kenne mich noch nicht, wenn die nächste halbe Stunde aus ist, wer die Frequenzbänder in den iPhone-Spezifikationen durchgeht.
Aber das ist schon interessant für Leute, die in den USA so einen Unlock-iPhone kaufen.
Da musst du aufpassen.
Ich hätte gerne erstmal die Antwort, für welchen Raum ist denn dieses Modell 1533 jetzt eigentlich gedacht?
1533 GSM heißt es, ne?
Ist das, was wir haben? Ich glaube, ja.
Lass mal gucken, ob man damit alles abdecken kann, was man in Deutschland hat.
Ja, das gibt es auf der Developer-Seite, die Modelle, die man doch...
Ne, da fehlt wieder das Band. Da fehlt wieder das Zimmerband, was wir in Deutschland hier haben. Das LTE-Band wird es wieder...
Da hätten wir ein Zimmerband und da hätten wir auch eins.
Dann ist es das letzte, das 1530.
Oder das da drüber.
Okay, wartet, wir haben es gleich. Es gibt hier nämlich diesen tollen Guide irgendwo, wo es mit Landesflagge und Provider daneben steht. Wir wollen nicht mal so eine URL gerade finden.
So, wir brauchen bei uns... Wir hätten auf jeden Fall in Europa gerne das Zimmerband. Das ist das, was eigentlich alle so haben. Das Zimmer und das Zwanziger. Das sind eigentlich die, die hier nativ sind. Was dann die Telekom sich ja noch gemacht hat, um an dem Spiel mit dem ersten iPhone 5 teilhaben zu können, ist, dass sie auf 1800 auch LTE gemacht haben.
Stimmt, hier gab es ja explizit diese LTE-Seite.
Da gibt es auch diese Model-Numbers und wer was macht und so.
Welche schlagen so vor für Deutschland? Das 1457. Schalten sie wieder zurück.
Das hat nicht so viele Bänder wie zum Beispiel das, was in Japan und auch US angeboten wird auf Sprint.
Schalt mal zurück auf den anderen.
Also nochmal, du brauchst für uns, für Deutschland, für reguläre Zeugs, nicht Telekom Special in Städten, auch so das Band 7 und das Band 25.
Und 3.
20 ist was 800 DD ist noch in den Städten?
Ne, 800 DD, witzigerweise finde ich echt witzig, dass sie DD nennen, ist die digitale Dividende.
Ach.
Das ist nämlich der Teil, der frei geworden ist, dadurch, dass sie das analoge TV. Runtergeschmissen haben. Das wird wirklich so genannt. Das Projekt kommt aus der EU. Die haben damals gesagt, pass auf, wir müssen hier mal ein bisschen die komische TV-Industrie mal ein bisschen featuren und so. Und wir hören jetzt mal auf mit dem analogen Zeugs. Durch digitales, durch DVB-T, kriegst du mehr Sender in weniger analoge Frequenzen rein. Das heißt, du machst effektiv analoge Frequenzen frei, wenn du auf First Analog zu senden. Und das ist die digitale Dividende, sozusagen die Dividende, die ausgestattet wird, dadurch, dass du auf digitale Fernsehen umgestellt hast. Und die wird jetzt wieder für LTE benutzt. Deswegen hast du eigentlich querbete in Europa, standardmäßig, gerade für das Land diese 800 MHz da.
Das mussten sie alle machen. Bevor sie in den Städten LTE installieren durften, mussten sie erst aufs Land, um dort diese digitale Dividende auch dann, was waren das, zwei Jahre oder so?
Was ist Zeit oder Ausbau? Minimum Wattigversorgung oder, ich weiß nicht mehr, aber irgendwas muss man haben.
Genau. Also ich wollte sagen, wir machen jetzt mal hier einen bandbreiten Anschluss über Funk fürs Land, damit wir mal Schnauze halten. Was wollt ihr denn? Ihr könnt doch euer 5 GB pro Monat hier in 10 Minuten runterladen und danach in den Urlaub fahren. Und jetzt machen wir mal richtig schnell in der Stadt.
Und der Witz ist der, dass sie... Also der Grund, warum man das macht, warum man sich jetzt an alte Frequenzen heran klammert, ist, dass einfach die Verbreitung einfacher ist, wenn die Frequenz da niedriger ist. Du kannst größere Zellen damit bauen, als mit dem höheren Frequenzzeug. So, für den anderen Quatsch... Nö, ist immer die Frage, wie voll du eine Zelle machst. Aber du kannst halt sozusagen, das Ding hat heimfach hf-technisch bessere Eigenschaften, was die Verbreitung angeht, gerade auf dem Land, als die anderen Frequenzen. Dann ist das andere native LTE-Band, ich sag jetzt mal nativ, was sich die Europäer als erste gedacht haben, wo wir LTE reinmachen, ist diese 2600 MHz oder 2,6 GHz, das ist das Band Nummer 7, was auch hier bei uns in Europa der Fall ist.
Aber hat nicht im iPhone 5 das 1800?
Richtig, jetzt kommt ja der Knaller. Also, die Europäer haben sich hingestellt, alle Europäer zusammen, sind ja durchaus ein paar Millionen und haben sich gesagt, so, wir machen das jetzt, wir nehmen jetzt 800 MHz, wir nehmen 2600 MHz, dann machen wir jetzt unser LTE rein. Dann kam die tolle Firma Apple letztes Jahr und hat gesagt, we don't give a fuck. Wir bauen iPhones so, wie wir sie wollen. Und hat das iPhone 5 rausgebracht mit einzigem Ding, was überhaupt nur bei uns hier reinpasste, 1800 MHz. Und meiner Meinung nach hat irgendjemand von denen T-Mobile in Deutschland Tipp gegeben. Weil T-Mobile ist der einzige in Deutschland, der 800 MHz macht und hat es auch nur kurz vor dem Betrieb, vor dem iPhone 5, haben sie das überhaupt in Betrieb genommen. Ich weiß das unter anderem deswegen, weil ich hatte jetzt gerade in der letzten Woche eine Begegnung der dritten Art.
Und nur sie haben auch eine Lizenz dafür.
Nein, du hast eine Lizenz, du hast Frequenzband, dort gehört ihnen. Die haben die MHz und ob sie da jetzt LTE, die dürfen natürlich jetzt nicht, weiß nicht, Rundfunk darüber verbreiten, sondern die haben eine Lizenz für Mobilfunk.
Nein, aber ich meine, er hätte auch O2 auf 1800 MHz dürfen. Aber haben sie nun nicht getan.
Haben sie nicht getan, weil wahrscheinlich noch keiner gesagt hat vorher. Deswegen sage ich ja, ich vermute, dass die T-Mobile-Leute in Deutschland einen Tipp gekriegt haben von Apple, weil sie ja ihr Premium-Partner oder wie auch immer rechtzeitig einen Tipp gekriegt haben.
Baut doch mal auf der Frequenz, dann kriegen wir das auch mit einem Gerät, was noch nicht alles kann, hin.
Der Rest der Industrie ist davon komplett überrascht worden, ich wollte gerade von meiner Begegnung erzählen, ich besitze schon seit 2011, Mitte 2011, besitze ich eine LTE-Fritzbox, weil ich die mal auf meinem Landsitz einsetzen wollte, bevor da DSL gab. Hat auch hier funktioniert, also muss man auch sagen. Also diese Landnummer, das geht technisch auf, die Tarife und Dienste, die da angeboten werden in Deutschland, sind immer noch für einen Arsch, aber technisch funktioniert das sehr gut. Und jetzt wollte ich letzte Woche diese LTE-Fritzbox mal in Berlin betreiben, mit dem T-Mobile-Sim, bzw. nicht X, sondern Philipp Banzer. Und die so, pff, nö, ich seh hier kein T-Mobile-Netz. Dann so, kurz so weit nachgedacht, mit auf einmal Rücksprache gehalten, ja, sagten die, als du deine Fritzbox kufft hast, wusste noch niemand, dass irgendjemand in Deutschland mal LTE auf 1800 MHz machen wird. Deswegen kann unsere Box nur, diese alte Box, die du hast, bloß 800 oder 2600, und die geht dann so, das ist aber dumm, und die so, na gut, dann tauschen wir sie dir aus. Was ich schon okay finde, die sind da, die sind auch sonst recht cool, aber das fand ich halt eben, die Begründung ist ganz klar, also wie gesagt, es gibt diverse Leute, die LTE-Equipment gebaut haben, schon jetzt vor dem großen Smartphone-Hype und so weiter und so fort, die fast alle diese 1800 MHz hier in Deutschland nicht unterstützen, weil das halt so ein Special ist, so ein Apple-Special mit der Telekom zusammen, sagen wir mal.
Gut, aber der ist jetzt aufgebrochen.
Der ist jetzt aufgebrochen, ja, weil jetzt irgendwann jetzt hat Telekom für ein Jahr lang ihre Exklusivität für das iPhone 5 mit LTE gehabt. Und jetzt kommen die natürlich wieder nach und schieben das andere Zeug nach. geht denn jetzt einfach so bei allen anderen, die überhaupt LTE machen.
Dann kann man gleich dabei im Thema bleiben. Und zwar, wie man ja sieht, auf der Liste wird nur die Telekom und Vodafone gelistet. Obwohl O2 auch 800 MHz hat. Aber die Legende ist da gerade, dass die bei O2 deren LTE Netz bei 800 noch so neu ist, dass die bei Apple noch nicht komplett durchtesten können, was die ja immer machen. Und deswegen haben sie die O2-Jungs noch nicht aufgenommen. Aber es gibt schon irgendwelche O2-Admins, die in irgendwelchen Foren schreiben, dass es in ein paar Wochen mit einem Update hinterherkommt. Wahrscheinlich kommt dann hier so ein Carrier-Update wieder.
Also O2.
Und dann geht's.
Also technisch gesehen spricht auch überhaupt nichts dagegen. Ja, technisch gesehen spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen. Apple behält sich halt vor über diese Carrier-Settings, die sich auch mal gelegentlich an die Telefone verteilen, einzeln die Länder und die Netze in den Ländern freizuschalten.
Bevor das O2-Netz nicht den Qualitätsansprüchen von Apple genügt, schalten sie das iPhone dafür nicht frei. Das ist im Prinzip die Politik dahinter.
Das ist unter anderem auch ein Grund. Wir haben ja damit angefangen mit der ganzen Diskussion, ob ich jetzt auch Bock habe auf so ein iPhone 5. Ich hätte Bock auf so ein iPhone 5, auf ein Neut in Schweden. Bin ja sehr häufig in Schweden. Da gibt's LTE auch überall und richtig knallt und so. Hab ich mal mit zum Stick gemacht, das geht super. Aber wenn das iPhone mir dann sagt, ich könnte das, aber ich hab keine Erlaubnis von Apple, dir das Dreinetz in Schweden freizuschalten, dann würde ich sagen, fuck you, Apple. Was ist denn hier mit Schweden?
In Schweden ist es noch gar nicht released, ne?
Richtig, deswegen hatte doch Apple ja nicht nötig, ein Carrier-Setting rauszubringen oder das irgendwo hinzulisten. Doch, guck mal, Finnland, Finnland, Finnland, weiter runter.
Drück mal, drück mal AVF hin.
Weiter runter. In Schweden. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich 3. Ja, toll.
Zeig doch mal die Bänder, die dann da bei dem Telefon da.
Als weitere Frequenzen hat das neue iPhone.
Keine 2.600 dabei und keine 800. Du bist also voll am Arsch hier.
Nein, das schwedische Modell macht nur 1,3 und 5, aber das deutsche Modell hat noch mehr.
Und diese Begrenzung ist wie ein Hardware oder ist das eigentlich auch nur Baseband-Firmware oder irgendwie so? Ich meine, bauen die jetzt wirklich fünf verschiedene Phones da?
Ja.
Ja, du musst schon ein bisschen eine HF-Hand-Mäßigkeit, Antennen-Mäßigkeit was machen.
Du kannst nicht alle Frequenzen...
Aber anscheinend ja schon, bei manchen Modellen sind ja wohl...
Viele. Ja, mit Einschränkungen, vielleicht Weißergeier, mit Modi, ich weiß es nicht.
Und dann hast du, wie gesagt, das ganze andere Zeug, hast du noch CDMA mit drin und so weiter und so fort. Da kommt der Qualcomm schon und drückt dir schon einen anderen Käfer für in die Hand.
Da kommt der Qualcomm!
Und drückt dir einen Käfer in die Hand. Wir halten mal fest...
Die verdienen sich übrigens auch dumm und dämlich, oder?
Das 5S und das 5C ist jetzt eben für das iPhone-Line-Up insofern ein riesiger Sprung nach vorne, technisch, unabhängig von dem 64-Bit-Gedusel, weil einfach die LTE-Sache jetzt... fehlt jetzt eigentlich noch was? Also, gibt es noch irgendwelche Frequenzen weltweit, die im Einsatz sind, die dieses iPhone jetzt auch noch nachrüsten könnte, um da noch mehr Verbreitung zu kriegen?
Ganz ehrlich, das sind jetzt zu viele. Ich bin auch nicht so der Freak, dass ich mir jetzt einen riesigen Exegi-Tross bastel. Ja, ganz ehrlich. Ich hab so ein bisschen Tunnelblick für die Länder, wo ich mich rumtreibe.
Das sind schon genug. Dann behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal, dass es jetzt so, mit diesen fünf Modellen haben sie quasi Worldphone-Status erreicht.
Das ist aber eben kein Worldphone. Ich möchte ein Phone.
Das hat sie doch schon dreimal.
Aber als Produkt können sie theoretisch alle nennenswerten, relevanten, zumindest LTE-Zapf.
Das spannende Teil ist immer Japaner. Bisher waren die Japaner immer draußen. Aber die spielen jetzt eben auch mit.
Und jetzt haben sie auch LTE-Docomole.
Genau, zum Beispiel. Die haben auch eigene Zeug gemacht und so. Also ja, könnte immer mal werden. Ich denke mal, das iPhone 6 reißt dann raus. Was mich noch so ein bisschen verwundert ist, jetzt erzählen sie was für eine tolle, wahnsinnig schnelle Computing-Plattform sie haben und tralala und pipapo. Aber warum sie denn nicht hingehen und eh schon so einen modernen Käfer drin haben und dann sagen, wir machen jetzt auch bitte schön WLAN mit AC, also Gigabit WLAN, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Weil jetzt haben sie mal hier noch angeblich genug Power, um auch damit umzugehen, haben sogar einen Professor drin, der das schafft, auch den Datenstrom da on the fly zu n- und d-Krypten, dann könnte man da mal ein ordentliches Lahn da dran bauen.
Ja, da hat der Qualcomm wohl den falschen Käfer in die Hand gedrückt.
Ein ordentliches Lahn.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass der Qualcomm so einen Käfer nicht hat.
Also das 5C und 5S hat noch keinen neuesten AC WLAN-Standard, obwohl Apple das ja in anderen Produkten jetzt schon nachgereicht hat. Aber gut, es muss ja auch noch Steigerungsfähigkeiten geben. Ich weiß eben mal, was die Connectivity betrifft im Wesentlichen jetzt auf dieser Telefonnetzebene. Und da ist es zumindest so, dass wenn man jetzt auf 5S upgradet in Deutschland, kann man mit allen LTE-Anbietern voraussichtlich, also man kann damit rechnen, dass man demnächst mit allen LTE-Anbietern damit auch was anfangen kann. Das wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal ein Upgrade-Grund.
Du kannst aber damit nichts anfangen, weil es in Deutschland keinen vernünftigen LTE-Tarif gibt.
Ja, ich rede ja auch nur von der Technik. Ich bin gespannt, was O2 im Angebot haben wird. O2, ihr nutzt das doch auch teilweise.
In den letzten Tagen.
Ist euch da irgendwie was aufgefallen? Just me.
Noch schlechter als sonst?
Komplett installing und so.
Ich benutze es aus dem Grunde nicht mehr.
Ich hatte stundenlang manchmal kein Netz. Ein, zwei Stunden.
Nö, hatte ich nicht das Problem.
Aber du bist eingebucht, das heißt, es zeigt 3G an, aber es macht nichts?
Genau. Und dann mache ich ein Reboot und es bringt nichts. Und heute habe ich ein Reboot gemacht und es brachte was. Also ich bin mir auch nicht so 100% sicher, was da jetzt der Grund ist. Ich kaufe mir auf jeden Fall erst das 6er. Wollen wir nochmal zurückkehren? Hallo, nicht alle durcheinander reden. Was?
Das iOS 7 hat ein neues Baseband. Ja, das iPhone 5 mit iOS 7 hat ein neues Baseband bekommen.
Und die macht jetzt was besser, anders, schöner?
Aber vielleicht hilft ja bei seinem Problem.
Problem?
Weil ich hab keine.
Ach so, das Problem. Das wird mich doch jetzt nur...
Keine Sorge, dauert auch nur 4 Stunden, weil mein iPad leert jetzt nämlich schon seit einer Stunde auch noch 4 Stunden.
Und dann haben sie 3 oder 4 Mal eine neue Firma und jetzt mit dem GM kamen nochmal von 5.0 auf 5.01.
Hier ist das Update jetzt auch auf meinem iPhone 4. Dieses Update erscheint mit einem attraktiven neuen Design und weist hunderte neuer Funktionen auf.
Einschließlich Kontrollzentrum, AirDrop, iTunes, Radio, sowie Verbesserungen bei der Mitteilungszentrale, Multitasking, Kamera, Fotos, Safari, Siri und...
Ob jetzt das 1085 jetzt auch AirDrop für iOS 7 unterstützt?
Nee, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum das irgendwie zwei Fische im AirDrop gibt.
Damit würden sie ja zugeben, dass es Files gibt auf dem Telefon.
Oh, es gibt ja jetzt AirDrop auf dem iPhone.
Ja, aber es ist nicht kompatibel mit dem AirDrop von einem Laptop. Außer du hast ein ganz neues oder irgendwie so.
Hier in den Applinks...
Mavericks brauchst du natürlich.
In der Release Note steht auch Unterstützung für Wi-Fi Hotspot 2.0.
Die Wi-Fi Alliance ist mal wieder hingegangen, hat gesagt, diese komische Geschichte, dass jeder Kreti und Pleti jetzt hier irgendeinen Scheiß zusammenhemmert und das Hotspot nennt und da irgendwie manche mit Flash-Pages dahinter oder mal verschlüsselt, mal ohne und so. Das muss jetzt mal ein Ende haben. Wir setzen jetzt mal einen Standard dafür, wie diese Hotspot-Geschichte funktioniert.
Welcher Hotspot verhält sich entsprechend?
Keiner.
Was von AVM nächste Programm hat.
Weil das natürlich für die Leute... Du investierst ja drin nicht. Du kannst damit kein Geld investieren. Du kannst damit kein Geld machen. Außer wenn du jetzt noch sowas machst wie, weiß ich, Wi-Fi an Bord von Flugzeugen oder Wi-Fi an Bord von Schiffen, wo du dann sagst, ich nehme hier 50 Euro die Stunde. Ansonsten kannst du mit Wi-Fi-Hotspots kein Geld mehr machen. Das heißt, die Leute sind froh über das, was sie da haben. Das betreiben sie auch weiter so. Und alles, was da neu kommt, ist schön.
Ich glaube, du musst dich drücken, damit man meine Geschmackse nicht hört.
Ah, nee, dieses Mittelding hier.
Hm, Drogen?
Warten. Ja, ich trinke auch mal so ein Halit.
Noch eine Osaf, bitte.
Ein Barcelona.
Oh, jetzt dauert mein Update nur noch 6 Stunden.
Ich kann heute nichts mehr sagen.
Aber ich meine, wenn jetzt irgendwo bei so Hotspot-Betreibern, ich sag mal Stumpf-Hotel geht, wenn die Hardware tauschen, dann werden sie halt neue Hardware anschaffen und dann ist es ja vielleicht nach dem neuen Standard kompatibel.
Das ist die Hoffnung von denen. Die sind ja auch nicht doof, diese Wi-Fi-Alliance-Leute. Sondern die Idee ist, dass die halt sagen, wir spezifizieren jetzt mal was und wenn es jetzt neue Hotspot-Hardware gibt, und damit meine ich jetzt nicht notwendigerweise Access Points, dann würde ich irgendwelche Controller oder intelligente Access Points, die so eine Hotspot-Funktionalität gleich drin haben und so Zeugs, dann machen wir das so.
Aber wenn du sagst, dass man damit kein Geld verdienen kann, dann kann das auch daran liegen, dass es ja unmöglich ist, sich da irgendwie einzubuchen auf eine effiziente Art und Weise und für ein ordentliches Billing zu sorgen.
Ja, ist natürlich selbstverschuldet auch. Oder mit frechen Preisen, ich meine, musst du dir überlegen, was die manchmal nehmen in irgendwelchen Hotels. Übrigens für sauschlechte Anwendungen, richtig, richtig sauschlechte Anwendungen. Aber das war doch Highspeed. Ja, die halten zwei Megawit im Ernst für Highspeed.
Ja, das ist wirklich zum Heulen.
Du weißt ja, dass ich gelegentlich mal so Veranstaltungen und so Zeugs mache und ich komme daher schon mal in die Verlegenheit, mal so einer Hotel-IT mal relativ tief in die Engelweide zu schauen. Und das ist nicht schön, was man da sieht. Das ist gar nicht schön. Das liegt auch daran, dass ein paar von denen haben schon vor vielen Jahren damit angefangen, haben wahnsinnig viel Geld drin investiert damals für ihre unglaublich schnelle High-Speed-2-Megabit-Leitung oder sonst irgendwas. Und zahlen das jetzt noch sozusagen ab. Und wenn du da jetzt hingehst und sagst, ja, aber euer Zeug ist eigentlich für'n Scheiß. Was ihr da habt, das kann man heutzutage nicht mehr brauchen mit 2 Megabit. Hallo, ich hab mit meinem 3G, oder geschweige denn LTE, bin ich x-mal schneller als ihr in eurem gesamten Hotelnetz. Dann sagen die, ja, pff, aber wir haben jetzt eh kein Budget mehr dafür. Das haben wir vor 5 Jahren verknallt. Was halt passiert ist, wenn Leute so richtig Hotels neu bauen, dann siehst du dann nochmal neu das Equipment gelegentlich. Aber dass die Leute, die was zu hängen haben, jetzt nochmal dranlagen, weil sie verdienen damit echt nicht so richtig viel.
Ja, was heißt sie verdienen damit nichts? Der Punkt ist, du kannst heutzutage als Hotel einfach dein Business auch gleich einstampfen, wenn du keine ordentliche Internetanbindung vorzuweisen hast. Ich meine, ich dachte das seit 10 Jahren...
Geh mal hier in Berlin in ein Hotel. Machst du natürlich nicht, weil du hier wohnst. Aber geh mal hier in Berlin ein Hotel. Es ist wirklich ganz finster, was man hier sieht.
Ich bin auch häufig in anderen Hotels. Es ist auch finster und die Finsterheit hat auch einen Namen. Und zwar Deutschland.
Nee, aber auch in den anderen Ländern war das nicht viel besser. Das Problem ist immer dasselbe.
In Barcelona gibt es in der ganzen Stadt kostenloses Wi-Fi.
Eben, es gibt noch besser.
Siehst du, deswegen kümmert sich kein Hotel darum, das ordentlich zu machen, weil die Leute dann einfach vor die Tür gehen. Als Hotel kannst du dir nur den machen, wenn du damit was verdienst. Und dann gehst du hin und sagst, ja lieber Gast, jeder Tag 9,95 Euro. Wenn ich nicht komme, wenn ich lese, dass wir keinen Wi-Fi haben. Genau, dann sagt der Gast ja, dann geh ich halt vor die Tür.
Geht da nicht zu dem Hotel, sondern suchen wir den anderen aus.
Ja, das geht aber nur in Gegenden, wo es überhaupt Hotels gibt, die mal ordentlich Bits haben.
Ja, aber es ist doch so.
Wenn die alle gleichscheiße sind, dann sagt... Nein.
Strom, Wasser, Internet.
Würde man meinen. Aber das ist zu denen noch nicht durchgedrungen.
Das dringt aber zu manchen durch. Also ich meine, wir haben das alle schon mal jetzt gemacht und ich glaube täglich machen das mehr Leute. Die rufen im Hotel an und sagen, Guten Tag. Wir überlegen ja bei ihnen unterzukommen, wie ist das mit dem Internet? Dann fängt es ja einem da irgendwie an zu erzählen, wie denn das so ist. Ja, und mit... Ja, wir haben High Speed und sie können bis zu drei Geräte und so weiter.
Wie High Speed USB. Voll für den Arsch.
Und der Preis ist pro Tag irgendwie eine halbe Zehe. Und dann sagst du ihnen halt einfach, ach nö. Sie wissen jetzt, was ich jetzt mache, oder? Ist doof, wissen wir schon. Aber war so...
Aber es ruckelt schon nicht. Wie mit der Bundesregierung. Der wird auch andauernd erzählt, dass das hier Scheiße ist. Ich interessiere mich für Fische, sagen die.
Oh Gott, der fleischgewordene Internetzugang.
Wollen wir noch bei iPhones reden?
Ja, lass uns über iPhones reden, lass uns über iPhone 5S reden.
Das ist doch deprimierend.
Wie war das? Also Roddy kauft sich eins, weil...
64-Bit.
64-Bit und Clemens kauft sich eins, weil LTE. Ich würde sagen...
Nein, ich kauf mir eins.
Ich kauf mir vor allen Dingen eins wegen 4S, wobei ich mal dran bin.
Du hast gesagt, du kaufst mir keins.
Ach so.
Ich kauf mir keins, weil das ist ein schönes Ding, aber das Telefon würde jetzt folgendet für mich tun. Wenn ich da jetzt meine Kongstar-SIM-Karte reinmache, sagt das nicht das Telefon, aber habe ich das selber, was ich jetzt auch habe. Also... So, zur Telekom-Mutter gehe ich nicht, weil die wollen mir auf jeden Fall ein mindestens doppelt so teuren Vertrag für mindestens 24 Monate Laufzeit aufdrücken. Und da sag ich einfach, nö. O2 kann mich mal, weil das Netz für einen Arsch ist. E plus geht gar nicht. Gibt es nämlich keine LTE und ein Vodafone... Hhmmm, da hab ich ein anderes Problem mit. So, jetzt könnte ich ja noch sagen, auch geil, dann nutze ich es halt in Schweden. Aber dann sagt mir das Telefon, ja, ich könnte hier funktionieren, aber der verstorbene Steve hat mir verboten, auf dem Netz von drei zu arbeiten. Geh weg! So, und dann hab ich mir ein iPhone 5S gekauft, für nichts und wieder nichts.
Ja, okay, versteh ich.
Dennis?
Kann ich nicht gebrauchen.
Ich geh nur auf die geraden Version, ich geh nicht auf die S-Zwischenschritte. Ein iPhone 3, 4, 5 und dann 6.
Nee, ich geh ja nur auf die Zwischenversion. Also, original iPhone, das war ja auch für S, also vor S, also 3G S, 4S, 5S.
Verstehe.
Wir sehen uns bei 6S wieder.
Das heißt, du gehst jetzt mit.
Ich geh jetzt mit.
Du gehst jetzt mit bei 6S, bei 5S.
Ich weiß noch nicht genau in welchem Modus, aber ich geh jetzt mit.
Ich hatte zwei iPhones nicht. Das erste.
Da hast du auch überhaupt gar nichts verpasst. Ich auch nicht.
Du hattest doch ewig keins, oder?
Ich hatte keine Ups, keine 3G, das hat mich nicht interessiert. Aber egal.
Vor allen Dingen, es war zu leise, man hat das Klingeln nicht gehört.
Ja, und Telekom vertracht Only und so weiter, das hat es, glaube ich, gekillt. Die Kopfhörer-Buchse war so, dass man nur den Apple Kopfhörer reinstecken konnte. 4S hatte ich nicht. Worauf ich jetzt hinaus wollte, ist was anderes, nämlich dieses Telefon taugt dir jetzt mal durchaus. Wenn man das aber hat, dann hat man auch Automatisch-IOS-Seam, das ist euch schon klar.
Ja, geil.
Endlich. Kann ich, kann ich ertragen.
Ich habe noch einen Grund, warum ich es haben will. Und zwar kommen wir ja noch hin, nämlich dieses Touch-ID-Zeug. Ich finde es voll geil.
Ja, was findest du denn so super da dran?
Ich muss meine PIN nicht mehr eingeben.
Ich mache mir einen Aufkleber drüber.
Das heißt, man kann dein Telefon jetzt auch anlocken, wenn du irgendwie auf der Party schläfst?
Routen.
Genau.
Das könnte man ja vorher abschalten, wenn man weiß, dass man einschläfst.
Und wie im Zustand ist es, dass du auf der Party einschläfst, dann bist du ganz sicher noch schlau genug.
Ja, aber ehrlich, die meisten Leute, die links und rechts neben mir sitzen, die wissen eh, was ich für einen Code habe, weil der so scheiße kurz ist. Und auf so einen richtig langen habe ich keinen Bock, also will ich so einen Touch-ID.
Ja, aber mit dem Code könnten sie keine Ups kaufen. Und keine Musik.
Aber du kannst wahrscheinlich das getrennt ein- und ausschalten.
Genau, ich könnte es ja auch verbieten, dass es nicht geht.
Also ich würde den Touch-ID Code auch nicht für den Store einschalten. Das würde ich auch nicht machen.
Ich glaube, sie haben nicht für den Store gesagt. Sie haben gesagt für Songs, für 1 Euro Songs. Ich glaube nicht, dass du damit für 70 Euro einen TomTom kaufen kannst.
Bestimmt.
Also wenn ich so was hätte, wäre das das einzige Feature, wofür ich das nutzen würde. Ich würde nicht das Telefon damit entsperren.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob jemand das gehackt bekommt.
Wenn es scheiße ist, kann ich es auch wieder aufmachen, aber ich finde es gut.
Das stimmt, das ist ein Argument.
Ich mache mir einen Aufkleber drüber. Ich werde das komplett boykottieren.
Wer meinte, das wäre eine gute Idee?
In deinem 6.
Hallo, nicht immer alle gleichzeitig reden. Das ist für die Hörer unmöglich.
Denn senden wir endlich mal ein Stereo.
Wir sollten einen einzelnen Spuren senden, dann können sie Leute eins zu einem ausschalten.
Senden wir endlich mal mehr Spuren.
Ich spiele gleich noch mal das Preview, das liebt eben durcheinanderreden.
Ja, so ist es halt, wenn alle da sind.
Also iPhone 5, via Konzentration. Welches Ding bequatscht man jetzt?
Das hat einfach eine ganze Menge Konsequenzen. Beziehungsweise vielleicht auch nicht. Was ja so ein Klassiker ist, mit Fingerabdruck. Dann klauen sie noch den Daumen zu deinem Telefon.
Da meinten sie ja schon, dass es nicht gehen würde, wenn man nur an einem lebendigen Finger funktioniert.
Also wenn ich dir den Daumen abschneide, dann geht der bestimmt noch mindestens eine Stunde für das scheiß Telefon.
Ich würde auch nicht gerne zur Charite gehen, auch wenn sie bei mir um die Ecke ist, um zu sagen, ihr habt mal einen toten Finger für mich, ich würde hier gerne mal was testen. Aber wenn einer so einen Doktore kennt, kann man es schon mal machen, oder?
Die Erkennung funktioniert auf jeden Fall ganz anders, als das bisher die normalen Fingerscanner gemacht haben, indem er irgendwie auf die Hautunterschichten draufscannet.
Und wie macht er das? Ja, ich nehme mich auch nicht.
Also das wird noch spannend.
Aber ich glaube, wir geben auch keine 365 Millionen Dollar für diese Firma aus, wenn es nicht einigermaßen cooler Shit wäre.
Also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wir werden zum Kongressor von was hören. Also war doch jetzt Anmeldeschluss. Hat jemand schon einen Vortrag angemeldet, wie ich das iPhone 5S aufgehackt habe oder so?
Ich meine, das hat ja noch keiner.
Ich glaube, den Vortrag könnte man auch nachreichen. Du kommst dann schon noch durch. Ich vermittel dich dann.
Ja, aber jetzt vielleicht nochmal ein paar Fakten, weil das wird jetzt vielleicht auch nicht jeder unbedingt so genau beobachtet haben. Also das iPhone 5S hat so einen Sensor an der Stelle, wo der Druckschalter ist, der Mainbutton. Und wenn man seinen Fingerabdruck drauf trainiert hat, durch mehrmaliges Aufdrücken und sich das richtig mehrmaliges Aufdrücken in unterschiedlichen Positionen?
Nee, einfach mehrmals immer so draufdrücken. Stupide Wiederholen. Bei den unterschiedlichen Positionen kommt das ja von alleine mehr oder weniger. Wahrscheinlich sagt er so lange, bis er eigenermaßen eine Menge hat.
Aber ich hab so Videos gesehen, wo die Erkennung halt auch noch gut funktioniert hat, mit so einem quergestellten Daumen. Was ist das Telefon, so eine Hand hast, und so mit der Kante. Keine Ahnung, das muss man wahrscheinlich mal ausprobieren, aber es scheint relativ unempfindlich dagegen zu sein, wenn du deinen Finger mal ein bisschen so, ein bisschen so hast.
Da war ja dieses Video, wo der Fingerabdruck auf dem Display zu sehen ist, ne? Und dann wurde immer mehr andersfarbig. Ich weiß natürlich jetzt nicht, ob das so real war und die wirklich, dass so...
Das ist so eine Animation.
Das wär ja cool gewesen, ich meine.
Es ist wahrscheinlich so ähnlich, aber es geht nicht darum, dass Flecken, die noch nicht gescannt wurden, dazukommen, sondern dass du generell durch das Mehrfache-Lesen dir genauer dabei bist, was du da eigentlich tatsächlich gelesen hast. Oder vielleicht messen sie ja auch in unterschiedlichen Sachen noch unterschiedliche Aspekte. Alles mögliche Vorstellungen, das werden wir, glaube ich, sehen. Die Frage ist, was hat das jetzt sozusagen für Implikationen, für so Security- und Hack-Angriffe?
So, was ich hier gelesen habe in der AMV8-Geschichte, der hat Bereiche in seiner Hardware, die Trusted Zone heißen und da drin wird dieser Fingerprint oder Hashes davon irgendwie gespeichert und da kommt halt wohl nichts anderes ran außer der Sensor. Und Software kommst du da wohl gar nicht so richtig ran.
Das ist Teil der Architektur oder Teil des A7?
Teil der Architektur, dieses Trusted Zone war ja vorhin bei dem Slide auch mit drin.
Ah, das heißt die Trusted Zones, die gibt's nur mit 64-Bit?
Ne, du kannst ja auch AMV7 mit 32-Bit machen, da gibt's Trusted Zones auch, aber haben sie ja nun mal nicht gemacht. Aber mit AMV6, obwohl bei AMV6 waren da glaube ich auch schon Trusted Zones. Das ist nicht das Richtige, du hast das Falsche.
Jaja, ich bin hier gerade etwas durcheinander.
Klick einfach auf den Link auf dem Workiflowi.
Welchen denn nochmal?
Ach, hier da oben, ne?
Ja, da. Und dann zwei, drei Seiten runter.
Ja, das mit dem Trusted Code, das habe ich nicht so richtig verstanden, wie das funktionieren sollte.
Es gab irgendwo noch so einen anderen Artikel, wo sie darüber berichtet haben. Die Apple Insider macht ja in letzter Zeit immer so eine Romanreports, da muss man ja mal stundenlang lesen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es da war, aber...
Hier, Trust Zone, da.
Aber den meinte ich gar nicht. Geh mal weiter runter, wo die Architekturen verglichen werden. Oder hoch, je nachdem, wo du gerade bist. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo das war. Ja, weiter oben war es, glaube ich. Weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter. Weiter, weiter. So eine Grafik sieht man gar nicht. Das hier, genau. Da. Da ist sie. Bei Arm-V6 gab es die auch schon.
Das gibt es also schon so bei V7.
Und da kommt man wohl nicht so easy ran. Also es ist jetzt nicht so ganz easy, du brauchst Route und dann kommst du da ran, sondern schon noch ein bisschen komplexer.
Okay. Aber dafür hätte es jetzt auch kein Arm-V8 gebraucht.
Vielleicht hatten sie das vorher halt in ihrem Silicon-Orner-Chip nicht mehr drin, also vielleicht ist das jetzt extra. Ist ja schließlich da auch als extra Modul gewesen. Vielleicht kann man die ja da zumachen oder auch halt eben nicht. Und jetzt haben sie das halt mit aufgenommen, weil wir das mal ordentlich machen wollten.
Aber hier ist das tatsächlich als Teil der 32 zu 64 Bit-Transition gekennzeichnet, hier diese Hypervisor- und Trust-Zone-Monitor-Kram.
Siehst du das hier?
Ja, so richtig hundertprozentig geht das aus den Slides nicht hervor, aber...
Ja, ist ja auch schon zwei Jahre alt.
Gut, das wäre dann, das peil ich jetzt ja auch alles nicht. Das ist irgendwie echt eine ganze Menge Blabla.
Das werden uns dann die Leute in den Show notes um die Ohren hauen.
Oder auf dem Kongress wird es dann einer vortragen, wie easy man dann da doch herangekommen ist und so.
Ich sag ja, aufkleber drauf.
Also sagen wir mal so, die Technik, ich fand's halt strategisch doof. Jetzt muss man allerdings auch dazu sagen...
Was fandst du strategisch doof?
Ja, das Ding jetzt rauszubringen. Ja, aber das war natürlich klar, weil das haben sie natürlich alles vor Juni gemacht. Und vor Juni hieß NSA noch No Such Agency, zumindest für die meisten Amerikaner. Und die ganze Thematik war vollkommen pfff. Und ist auch jetzt noch für die meisten Amerikaner pfff.
Aber was ist jetzt da... Warum ist denn Tatscheid hier ein Problem mit NSA im Zusammenhang?
Nein, nicht nur NSA, sondern der ganzen... Es findet ja gerade so eine Sensibilisierung statt, des gemeinen Volks da draußen auf der Straße. Eine Sensibilisierung. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass die jetzt alle an mit Fackeln und Pitchforks und so ums Kanzleramt ziehen. Aber jetzt immerhin hat jetzt auch mal der Typ auf der Straße mal wat davon gehört. Ob er jetzt wat davon hält, oder sich darüber Gedanken macht, ist nun eine andere Sache. Aber er hat jetzt gehört, dass es nicht bloß eine Sache ist, die sich ein paar Spinner mit Aluhüten ausgedacht haben.
Und du kannst doch davon ausgehen, dass wenn die News rauskommt, dass Apple einen Fingerabdrucksensor ins iPhone baut, dass jetzt nicht nur die Nerds darüber witzeln, dass der garantiert zur NSA geht. Ja, wird auch immer, aber es wird halt darüber geredet.
Da die Deutschen ja alle brav ihr Ding schon eh abgegeben haben, bei den Leuten, die eh metertief im Dingdarm der NSA stecken, ist es der Dropsy Lodge. Und wer auch in den letzten Jahren, seitdem mit Computergib mal in die USA eingereist ist, aus welchem Grund auch immer, hat auch eh schon sein Ding dahinter gelassen.
Ja egal, aber es wird halt drüber geredet, das war mein Punkt.
Ja klar.
Was ja noch ein anderer interessanter Punkt war, der da irgendwie so aufgekommen ist, ist, dass so, wie einer meinte, in den meisten westlichen Zivilisationen gilt so dieses Prinzip, dass man sich selber nicht belasten muss in Ermittlungen. Also man muss keine Passwörter sagen und diesen ganzen Kram. Aber halt, dass Fingerabdrück und Blutabnahme halt schon sozusagen eine Ausnahme ist quasi.
Du musst deinen Finger nicht selber drauf drücken, aber die Polizei kann deinen Finger nehmen, um damit dein Telefon aufzumachen.
Genau, das heißt irgendwie, das ist halt nicht das gleiche wie, ich hab meinen Passwort vergessen, weil du hast halt den Finger, musst halt draufhalten.
Gut in einem Betracht der Tatsache, dass die meisten Telefone heutzutage einfach geroutet werden, indem man sie irgendwie mit einem Kabel ransteckt, könnte sich natürlich in der Zukunft vielleicht mal ändern, wenn ein Gerät total sicher ist.
Man darf ja wohl nochmal träumen.
Hoffnung, Oessan.
Also mit dem NSL-Sammenhang, da denk ich mir auch, das Touch-ID, auch egal, wenn die da ran wollen, dann kommen die da auch mit oder ohne Touch-ID ran.
Ich hab gar nicht gesagt, dass das, was dieser Sensor da ausließt, für sie auch wirklich irgendeine Hilfe darstellt. Also das, was er in dieser Trust-Zone abspeichert, das reicht halt zur Erkennung an dem Gerät. Am Ende sogar nur an dem einen Gerät.
Aber ich find das toll, da können sie denn den richtigen wegsprengen. Da gab's noch mal die Geschichte, dass sie den einen weggesprengt haben, indem er an sein Telefon rangegangen ist und neben dem Telefon irgendwie was drin war. Und so wissen sie dann, dass jetzt nicht sein Sohn ran geht oder so. Schonmal gut.
Ja.
Schön. Wie wär's mal mit so ein paar Real-World-Beispielen? Das ist Real-World. Ich dachte jetzt einfach nur so an nicht die große Weltverschwörung und die israelische Geheimdienste sind hinterher. Ich glaub, wenn du an dem Punkt angekommen bist, dann hilft dir auch.
Am besten gar kein Telefon beiseite. Egal, was für eins. So wie Osama Bin Laden. Der hatte ja in den letzten Jahrzehnten seines Lebens keinen Telefon mehr angefasst. Keins. Vor 9-11 saß er schon mal in seinem Zelt irgendwo in so einem Tal da, in Afghanistan oder Pakistan. Da hat er sich gedacht, nützt du mal ein toller Satellitentelefon und keine 90 Sekunden später kam der Kursmissile auf sein Zelt zugeflogen. Er hat es dann damals überlebt, aber seitdem hat der Typ ja keinen Telefon mehr angefasst. Keins. Gar keins. Wenn der was zu sagen hatte, hat er einen Zettel geschrieben und hat einen Typ auf dem Esel damit losgeschickt. So, Mutti, viel Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag. Zettel in den Vogel hingeschickt. Der hat keinen Telefon mehr, fast die letzten 10, 15 Jahre oder was denn, des Lebens. Aus gutem Grund.
Na einmal dann wohl doch.
Einmal dann vielleicht doch.
Oder der Esel.
Oder der Esel hat ihn verpetzt.
Na gut, aber jetzt mal weg mit dem Esel.
Esel mit GPS-Tracker.
Weg mal jetzt mit Osama bin Laden und in Israel.
Man dürfte auch mal ein bisschen Versperrungsfühlinge.
Die Briten unterdrücken wieder die Diskussion.
Was sag ich meinem Kontaktoffizier? Jaja, also euch fallen jetzt eigentlich auch keine wirklichen Real-World-Bedrohungen aus, außer ich anlock dein Telefon, während du schläfst.
Also ich will einfach keinen Fingerabdruckscanner. Da drin hab ich ein Aufkleber drauf.
Aber der Punkt ist doch schon appealing irgendwie.
Ja, aber mein Trust-Level ist da gerade. Wie wem gegenüber? Ich will nicht, dass Apple meinen Fingerabdruck hat.
Ach, von Harmen, ich glaube wirklich nicht, dass die den abdrucken.
Ist mir egal, was du denkst. Ich würde trotzdem nicht.
Naja, ich sag mal so, man hat halt nur 10 Finger und wenn man 10 Passworte verbraucht hat, dann ist Feierabend.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Kannst du auch deine Schuhe immer ausziehen. Dann muss man auch noch mal probieren, ob das auch mit Füßen geht.
Das stimmt, weil das ist nämlich eine endliche Ressource sozusagen.
Das hat letztens jemand getwittert, dass wenn man seinem Passwort ja irgendwie einem geklaut wird, dass man das ja ändern könnte. Und dass wenn einem aber das Phone geklaut wird, dass man seinen Fingerprint nicht ändern könnte. Aber das stimmt ja auch nicht ganz, weil zum Passwort ändern musst du auch noch an das Gerät rankommen, damit du es ändern kannst. Wenn du es nicht mehr hast, dann ist es auch vorbei.
Ich mach mir von unserer Datenschleuder von Schäuble das Fingerabdruck. Den hab ich noch. Da mach ich mir so einen kleinen...
Wir fassen jetzt nochmal kurz zusammen und stellen klar, Fingerabdruck spielt hier überhaupt gar keine Rolle. Das iPhone hat keinen Fingerabdrucksensor, sondern es hat einen Fingersensor. Das ist was ganz anderes. Na ja, aber das muss ja auch mal...
Was ist die Differenz?
Das muss doch auch noch mal gesagt werden.
Dann erklären wir den Unterschied.
Der Unterschied ist, dass ein Abdrucksensor tatsächlich deinen Abdruck senzt.
Nach deiner Theorie hab ich jetzt auch schon einen Fingersensor.
Das geht sozusagen auf das, was an toter Hautschicht auf deinem Finger draufklebt und irgendwie Welle macht.
Und du meinst, sie gehen vielleicht noch tiefer in deinen Finger rein?
Sie gehen da tiefer in den Finger rein, das haben sie ja auch auf der Keynote ausführlich dargelegt oder zumindest schön registriert. Sie haben einen gewissen Film abschlaufen lassen.
Sie haben einen Film gezeigt, der total echt war.
Da will ich ja erstmal sehen, was sie da so genau machen.
Na ja, das werden wir halt sehen. Aber das ist quasi jetzt die These, dass dieser Sensor, der funktioniert halt nicht, wenn es tot ist, das heißt auch was da quasi an Blut und Wärme wahrscheinlich kann Wärme eine Rolle spielen.
Die machen hier die Scientology-E-Meter. Die messen einfach den Widerstand zwischen Finger und Rest der Hand auf der Rückseite oder so. Deswegen funktioniert das auch nur bei Metallgehäuse.
Diese ganze Abdruck ist einfach nur ein Fake, die messen einfach den fucking Widerstand zwischen vorne und hinten.
Ach du meinst hier, wie die...
Wie die E-Meter halt voll in sein Tollett-Sie so.
Ja, da müssen die Leute halt nicht so schlauer sein, wenn die da irgendwie die Fake-Finger ranhalten. Ich bin gespannt, wie lange es dauert, bis sie das nachgemacht haben.
Wie ein Lügendetektor auch.
Wollen wir Wetten hier aufziehen, wie lange es gebraucht wird, bis die erste Liebwurst kommt, dass es gehackt wird?
Zum Kongress werden sie das vorführen.
Viel früher.
Das würde mich sehr überraschen.
Die ganze Welt würde sich jetzt darauf stürzen. Was gibt es Besseres gerade?
Ja, aber ich denke mal...
Ein, zwei Wochen hat das jemand...
Definier mal, was gehackt ist.
Damit nicht den richtigen Finger aufgemacht wird.
Der eine geht ran mit nicht einem von diesen Fingern und macht das Ding auf. Zwei Wochen, sag ich.
Ich sag länger, weil die werden sich schon...
Nach Antennagate sind sie ein bisschen vorsichtiger. Antennagate war ja schon nur so ein halber Hack. Nur so ein halbes Gate.
Das Einzige, was vielleicht verhindert ist, dass wenn einer probiert, dass sie merken, wenn einer es probiert und nach zwei, drei Versuchen sagt, nee, ist nicht mehr. Das könnte ich mir noch gut vorstellen.
Auch ein geiler D-Dos.
Aber sonst...
So, danach gibst du dir deinen Pin ein. Du gehst auf Klo, ich dreh fünfmal mit meinem Finger auf dein Telefon drauf, sag ich mach jetzt nicht mehr.
Ja, und dann geb ich danach meine Pin ein, dann ist gut, aber wenn ich zuhause bin, brauch ich nicht andauernd mein ewig lange Pin eingeben, sondern...
Alter, den scheiß Pin hast du schon längst vergessen, wenn du deinen Telefon den ganzen Zeit mit dem Finger aufmeldest.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Oder 24 oder so.
Was?
Nach 48 Stunden geht dein Fingerprint-Sensor nicht mehr, dann musst du den Pin eingeben.
Ach.
Und wahrscheinlich kann man das sogar einstellen und ich hoffe, man kann's einstellen.
Das wär noch ein cooles Feature. Hab ich auch gelesen. Im Interdings.
Liegst du kein Internet?
Großen, bösen Internet.
Weitere Security-Szenarien oder Anmerkungen zu Touch ID oder wollen wir das Kapitel abschließen?
Ja, dass man halt damit einkaufen kann und zwar Sachen von Apple, wo Apple halt, wenn du halt einen Song kaufst für einen Dollar und das hat halt jemand beschissen, dann ist für Apple halt kein Problem, weil das meiste davon verdienen sie wahrscheinlich eh selber. Und die 15 Cent, nee, Quatsch, die meisten schieben sie an die Mobil-Dings rüber. Ist egal, ich weiß, die paar Cent können sie sich leisten und wenn es halt wirklich kaputt sein sollte, müssen sie es halt abschalten. Und was noch ein Freund meinte, ist, dass wenn da ja so eine Art Mini-Kamera drin ist, da unten dieser Sensor, weil es muss ja so ein bisschen sowas sein, dass man ja theoretisch mit dem Button auch so scrollen könnte oder so. Das würde ich eigentlich ganz cool finden, wenn du eigentlich nicht mehr ganz nach oben musst, um irgendwas zu scrollen, sondern mit deinem Daumen da unten bleibst, den ganzen Bildschirm sehen kannst und trotzdem so ein bisschen scrollen kannst. Das wäre eine gute Idee, oder nicht?
Ach komm, nach ein paar Jahren hat Apple auch kapiert, dass man mit dem Lautstärke-Lauterknopf auch fotografieren können wollen will. Das hat auch nur drei, vier Jahre gedauert.
Aber mit dem Homebutton scrollen ist dann doch ein bisschen sehr Blackberry.
Ich meine, die werden mit dem Ding... Das kostet ja schließlich 350 Millionen Dollar, dieser Massen da. Da werden die schon ein bisschen was mit machen wollen.
Ja, aber nicht scrollen.
Also ja, irgendwas wollte ich jetzt noch anmerken, aber irgendwie quatschen wir heute aneinander vorbei. Was war denn das noch? Ach ja, genau. Two-Factor Authentication. Ist das nicht auch etwas, was man hier quasi machen könnte? Ist das nicht auch so für Behörden unter Umständen, besonders in den USA, relevant, so ein Sicherheitssystem auch bieten zu können? Du sagst, du kannst hier nur Passwort eingeben, aber du musst auch noch deinen Fingerabdruck auf diesen Sensor drauf geben.
Du musst was wissen und du musst was haben. Du kannst das schon ohne machen. Aber klar, man kann es den Leuten einfach machen, allerdings ist das derzeit nicht in Sicht, weil derzeit gibt es offiziell keine API für das Ding. Derzeit darf bloß Apple das benutzen.
Ja.
Da warten wir jetzt wieder die nächste iOS-Version ab, wenn sich da der Staubgelicht hat, wie mit vielen von diesen APIs, werden sie vielleicht die auch noch mal freigeben irgendwann. Dann kann eine einzelne Abt auch sagen, ich möchte jetzt hier gerne jemanden identifizieren.
Ja, beziehungsweise sie schaffen es auch, da halt so ein ganz allgemein gehaltenes, minimalistisches Framework, was halt Touch ID unter bestimmten Dingen in Protokolle damit integriert, aber...
Ja, oder irgendein Identifizierungs-Framework. User-Authentifizieren und dann kannst du immer noch deine PIN eingeben und dann bist es du.
Oh, was war denn noch toll an dem iPhone 5S?
Zwei Two-Phone-Flash.
Die Kamera mit dem komischen Blitz.
Nee, aber Slow-Motion für Video ist geil. Burst-Mode für Fotos ist geil.
Vor allem der Burst. Slow-Motion für Video würde ich sagen auch benutzen. Und schlägt einem auch gleich das Beste und Schärfste vor, ne? Ja, klar, aber das ist schon gar nicht so schlecht. Das heißt, du kannst immer draufdrücken und so ein paar machen und dann eins auswählen und den Rest, der wird automatisch gelöscht, wenn du willst.
Also das allein ist schon so ein Killer-Feature für viele Leute, glaube ich.
Das ist schon nicht so schlecht.
Also ja, sie haben es, und jetzt sind die Megapixel, sind jetzt noch größer geworden.
Um...
Gleich viele Pixel sind jetzt noch größer geworden.
Sagen und schreiben, 15%.
Ja, 1,4 auf 1,5.
Ja, aber dafür haben sie eine Viertelblende haben sie auch noch besser. Das ist das Lichtempfindliche. Ich bin nicht Fotograf genug, um da jetzt wirklich was sagen zu können.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht.
Da gab es auch so einen Riesen, habe ich glaube ich auch verdienst, oder den da anderen Tag, so einen Riesenbericht, von so einem Fotofreak, der sich so ein bisschen mit Kameras beschäftigt. Da kannst du auch stundenlang lesen an so einem Artikel. Da steht alles da, was man wissen will. Das ist eigentlich ganz, ganz nett.
Und der schreibt zumindest, das ist auf jeden Fall die richtige Richtung. Nicht mehr Pixel, sondern größere Pixel.
Das begrüße ich ihm im Übrigen auch. Also einfach auch nur philosophisch.
Na ja, du hast halt, es rauscht weniger und du hast bessere Abbildungseigenschaften, etc.
Und du hast keine 50 Megabyte-Bilder, sondern die bleiben halt gleich groß.
Ja, eben.
Das mit dem Duoton, oder wie händen sie das jetzt? Duoton, Dualton. Klingt wie eine ganz interessante Idee, um zumindest Blitzlichtbilder nicht total scheiße aussehen zu lassen.
Hast du oft mit Blitzlichtbildern?
Nee, oft nicht, aber wenn man es halt macht.
Weil es halt auch immer scheiße aussieht.
Genau.
Ja, aber es liegt ja nicht an der Farbe, sondern auch, weil es einfach immer scheiße dunkel ist, oder?
Naja, die Frage ist ja in dem Moment, Foto oder gar kein Foto? Aber wenn du schon ein Foto machst, also wenn du schon diesen ganzen Aufwand treibst, dann wärs ja auch nochmal schön, dass es nicht jedes Mal so aussieht, als ob du wie eine Weiße Farbe über den Personen, die du fotografierst, ausgegissen hast.
Mich würde mal die Apple-Statistik interessieren, wie viele Bilder mit Flash gemacht werden. Gibt's nicht bei Flickr vielleicht sowas?
Die haben noch tausende Bilder. Ach so, mit Flash. Können wir mal gucken.
Haben die so Statistik wirklich mit Flash auch?
Also du kannst in allen Ex-Dev-Daten suchen.
Das ist wirklich wenig.
Ja, ich mag Flash eigentlich auch nicht so sehr. Aber vielleicht bringt der Dualtone Flash tatsächlich was.
Und wenn man das Flashlight benutzt von der Kamera, gehen dann auch von dem Phone beide an? Oder wie macht das? Ist da ein Hellhaut?
Gute Frage.
Oder gehen beide mit halber Leistung an?
Also sie haben wohl 1000 verschiedene Kombinationen, die sie da zum Einsatz bringen.
An Helligkeiten?
Ja, also an unterschiedlichen Helligkeitskombinationen. War die Aussage. Also unterschiedlich hell und unterschiedlich farbig. Also kann auch sein, dass der Blitz nicht heller macht, als er muss oder so. Und nicht einfach nur angeht und immer maximal hell drauf hält. Aber keine Ahnung, wie das bei den anderen normalerweise so ist.
Just testing.
So, ist verlinkt.
Das 120 frames per second Video, das finde ich schon ziemlich spannend irgendwie.
Auch wenn das halt nur 27p ist.
Also ich meine, kennt einer von euch den YouTube-Channel Slow Mo Guys? Das Slow Mo Guys, das müsst ihr euch mal angucken. Die machen relativ viel Zeug kaputt und halten mit einer guten Slow-Motion-Kamera drauf. Und der eine, der verletzt sich auch gerne mal dabei. Gut 120 frames per second ist jetzt nicht das, womit man so Sachen machen kann, was die da machen.
Ja, aber das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal cool.
Ist schon mal cool, ja.
Also da kann man auch noch keine Rondklicke.
Klicken auf Groß.
Was?
Auf Groß klicken. Fullscreen. Der schmeißt sich doch nach vorne.
Der schmeißt sich nach vorne, aber das Auto explodiert trotzdem recht amtlich.
Das kann man jetzt also auch mit dem iPhone machen, ist doch geil.
Naja, wie gesagt, nimmst du ein paar Mollis irgendwie, ziehst durch Kreuzberg und dann ist jetzt alle mal Slow-Mo.
Also das ist garantiert Faktor 100 oder so, was sie da nehmen.
Ja, das ist schon richtig langsam.
Aber die haben richtig, richtig cool reingetan. Nee, das sieht aber eher fotografiert aus, weil das Geld ist nämlich weiß. Ah, statt grün.
Ach Quatsch, das ist alles echt.
Bisschen showend.
Steht dann da, wie viel Slow-Motion das ist?
Ja, sie sagen es meistens in dem Video, was sie für eine Kamera verwenden und wie schnell sie das dann aufnehmen.
Aber das stand bei einem 27.000 FPS bei einem der Videos.
27.000?
Ich glaube irgendwo hier unten da Underwater Bullets, 27.000 FPS.
27.000? Ja, es gibt noch welche, die sind noch schneller.
Na, Apple, da müsst ihr aber noch nachlegen, finde ich jetzt mal, ne?
Da müsst ihr nachlegen.
120 so, das ist ja wohl nüscht. Es gibt welche, die so im wissenschaftlichen Bereich eingesetzt werden, auch bei Physikern oder so, die sind noch schneller.
Ja, eine Million, aber dann auch wirklich nur für eine Tausendthal Sekunde oder so.
Ja, reicht ja aus.
Weil es ja gar nicht gerade der Schuss ist. Wie lame ist das?
Naja, es ist im Wasser. Ich meine, dass die Kugel da nicht lange geradeaus fliegt, das ist irgendwie klar.
Dass überhaupt diese Waffe da unter Wasser fährt.
Und dann kühlt es sich wieder ab und zieht sich wieder zusammen, auch cool, oder?
Naja, das ist glaube ich kein Abkühlen, sondern einfach, dass es sich halt...
Das implodiert.
Das ist implodiert, weil die Druckwelle irgendwie...
Die Kugel ist eigentlich voll uninteressant, der Gasausstoß ist viel lustiger.
Wieso soll denn implodieren? Was ist denn implodieren?
Das Gegenteil von explodieren. Explodieren ist, wenn der Druck...
Ja und warum soll das implodieren durch Wasser?
Weil erst durch die Kugel wird das Wasser auseinandergetrieben, dann entsteht ein riesiger Unterdruck und der implodiert.
Also der Schwung, den das Wasser außenrum hat...
Das ist der Gasausstoß.
Das ist der Gasausstoß aus der Waffe. Der ist voll heiß und der kühlt im Wasser ab und zieht sich zusammen.
Das Ding ist, das Show, das Wasser, das sich wegbewegt, hat so viel Impuls, dass es irgendwann auch einen Unterdruck erzeugt. Und dann geht es wieder zusammen. Mit ganz viel Schwung.
Na gut, wir wollten ja eigentlich über Max reden. Ach nee, über das iPhone. Kamera ist toll. Mehr Licht, mehr Farbe, mehr Burst, mehr Slow-Mo, mehr Lametta.
Und man kann jetzt wieder einen Dock für das iPhone kaufen. Für das 5S und 5C gibt es wieder Docks.
Hat jetzt nicht so viel mit der Kamera zu tun, aber so ist es.
Dann sollten wir aber erstmal zum 5C gehen, bevor wir über Docks reden.
Also, welche Frequenzen kann denn...
Nein.
Das Gute ist, 5C und 5S haben dieselbe Kombination.
Das heißt, sie haben dasselbe Baseband-Ship drin, aber das 5C hat noch den alten A6.
Ich glaube, die haben diese FaceTime-Kamera nach vorne, haben sie noch mal etwas verbessert. Sonst ist es im Wesentlichen ein iPhone 5. Und halt Plastikaste drumrum und eben auch dieselbe Basebandgeschichte wie beim 5S. Das heißt, auch mit diesem Produkt decken sie alles genauso gut ab wie mit dem 5S. Es gibt jetzt keinen Reachability-Vorteil vom 5S.
Aber vielleicht vom 5C. Vielleicht. Vielleicht ist sich nämlich Plastikgehäuse.
Ja, ich meinte jetzt, generell geht grundsätzlich oder geht grundsätzlich nicht.
Darf ich noch mal kurz erwähnen, dass die Tarife deswegen trotzdem scheiße sind? Du wolltest nur heute ein paar Mal erwähnt haben.
Ja, das können wir auch gerne nochmal drauf eingehen.
Das ist ein ganz neuer Aspekt.
Ich wollte mich jetzt bloß erstmal an dem, was hier real an Hardware neu ist, auch mal ein bisschen abarbeiten. Also hat kleinen Buchstaben und Farben und...
Den Witz mit den kleinen Buchstaben habe ich nicht verstanden. Kannst du denen erklären?
Das ist ziemlich nicht groß, sondern klein.
Das 5S ist jetzt offiziell mit einem kleinen S und nicht wie vorher beim 4 mit einem großen S. Das C ist auch klein.
Ein kleines S, dann nehme ich es nicht.
Das ist aber auch nur ein kleines C.
Na gut, dann aber doch eher das kleine S als das kleine C.
Aber es ist der große 5.
Ja, was ich aber jetzt hier interessant finde an diesem Move, ist, dass sie quasi ihr Lineup so ein bisschen mit so einer alles ist anders und trotzdem bleibt alles gleich Nummer komplett anders positioniert haben. Also anstatt dass sie nur ein neues Telefon im Angebot haben, haben sie jetzt de facto sechs verschiedene neue Telefone oder je nachdem, wenn man die verschiedenen Modellnummern auch noch kombinieren will.
Und die Farben vom C auch, dann ist man irgendwann bei 20 oder so.
Ja, aber das 5C ist jetzt quasi neu.
Ja.
Und das heißt, ein neues iPhone ist jetzt etwas billiger als es vorher war oder kostet das gleiche, was das 5er vorher gekostet hat?
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen günstiger.
Ist sich das 5S sogar noch ein bisschen teurer geworden? Das heißt, dass sie jetzt einfach viel breiter aufgestellt sind und die meisten Leute wahrscheinlich zu diesem 5C greifen werden. Mal, der das 5S verkauft, sieht besser.
Man kann jetzt zwar darüber spekulieren, wer das überhaupt kauft. Leute, die sich vorher noch gar nichts gekauft hatten von Apple, die jetzt sagen, auch jetzt wäre mal ein Zeitpunkt für einen Einstieg, können sich glaube ich auch durchaus für ein 5C begeistern. Leute, für die das jetzt schon das vierte oder fünfte iPhone ist, die werden da glaube ich nicht hingehen. Weil der Unterschied vom 5 zum 5C ist für die meisten Leute hier in unserem Realm, also hier in Deutschland, nicht so dramatisch, dass sich das lohnen würde, da umzusteigen. Natürlich den Leuten, die gerade eins geklaut wurde, aber die jetzt extra hingehen und sagen, gebt jetzt mal ein 5 auf, um dafür ein 5C zu kaufen.
Das 5 wird aber noch gar nicht aufgegeben, sondern was jetzt aufgegeben wird, ist das 4S, weil die Verträge halt alle über zwei Jahre laufen. Der große Upgrade-Zyklus ist immer über zwei Jahre.
Und?
Naja, das heißt, dass das 5C glaube ich sehr attraktiv ist für diese Gruppe.
Aber es ist nicht wirklich billiger, oder? Also warum sollte man sich das kaufen?
Weil es ein geiles iPhone ist und es gibt es in Grön.
Apropos 4S, das gibt es ja noch, ne?
Sie haben das 4S noch im Programm.
Sie haben auch das 4 noch im Programm.
Nee, das 4 haben sie nicht mehr im Programm.
Ja, China.
Na, es ist ein Programm.
In China?
Also es gibt Märkte, wo sie sogar noch das iPhone 4 anbieten.
Na gut.
In China. Ja, in China.
Wahrscheinlich ist es die China-Variante, die sie noch nicht ganz verkauft haben.
Zufälligerweise der größte Markt.
Ja, also ich glaube, dass das C mehr verkauft wird als das S. Ja, allein schon, weil es diesen iPod-Nano-Faktor hat. Irgendwie so diese... Ich kann mir jetzt meine Farbe aussuchen. Was, du willst blau? Ich nehme noch lieber rot.
Wie, aber das 4S bauen die weiter und das 5er gar nicht mehr?
Ich glaube, dass sie mit der Rückseite vom 5er und den Kratzern auf der Rückseite vom 5er ganz schön viele Probleme hatten. Und dass sie deswegen ein neues Gehäuse designt haben.
Warte, 5s ist doch genau der gleiche Shit, oder nicht?
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie da improved haben. Also wie sie es ja gerne mal machen. Vom 4er zum 4s haben sie ja auch die Antenne improved.
Also ich bin mir da noch nicht so ganz so sicher, aber es geht das Gerücht, dass sie da diesen Anodization-Prozess, also wie man da diese Farbe da in dieses Metall rein kitzelt, dass sie den überarbeitet haben. Und sie haben ja auch...
Aber es ist immer noch Alu und kriegt schnell grundsätzlich...
Grundsätzlich ja, aber es geht wohl auch irgendwie noch ein bisschen stabiler. Und außerdem haben sie ja dieses Schwarz nicht mehr. Sondern jetzt gibt es das nur noch in...
genau.
Space Grey.
Waffengrau.
Und dazu in Gold. Und in Silver.
Das ist Champagner.
Wie heißt Gold?
Ist das nicht Champagner?
Nein, es wurde gemunkelt, dass Apple das Champagner nennen würde, damit sie es nicht Gold nennen.
Aber die aus der Champagner haben sie natürlich gleich beschwert, haben gesagt, könnt ihr voll vergessen, wir klagen euch weg.
Ja, sie haben einfach Silver und Gold. Silver und Gold, das passt auch wunderbar zu diesem High-End-Image, insbesondere im Vergleich mit diesem 5C. Also das ist schon sehr...
Aber ohne Straßsteine, also ich meine... Klug.
Ich frage mich, was jetzt noch da drunter kommen könnte.
Wie da drunter?
Naja, ich meine, das ist jetzt so Second Tier, den sie da eingezogen haben. Sie haben halt jetzt...
Ja, aber statt dem Fünfer. Jetzt haben sie wieder drei Modelle. Das hatten sie die letzten paar Zyklen ja auch schon.
Vorher gab es immer nur ein neues iPhone. Und alles andere war alt.
Richtig.
Und das gab es auch nur in bestimmten Konfigurationen. Du kriegst jetzt das kleinste nur mit 8 GB Speicher.
Das ist ja beim 4S wieder so. Also du kannst das 4S noch kaufen, aber...
Ja, aber es wäre auch mit dem Fünfer jetzt gewesen, wenn sie genauso weitergemacht hätten wie bisher. Du konntest dieses alte Modell des letzten Jahres auch nicht in denselben Variantenbreiten kaufen wie das Neue. Nur das Neue hast du die volle Auswahl.
Die volle Gigabyte Zahl.
Wobei jetzt die Auswahl nicht so groß ist, weil es gibt ja das 5C nur mit 16 und 32 GB, glaube ich. Also es gibt kein 64er. Leider gibt es halt auch kein 5S mit 128. Weil das wäre jetzt mal meiner Meinung nach auch langsam mal in der Zeit gewesen. Wie lange gibt es jetzt schon 64 GB?
Also ich hab das 4S in 64, ich auch.
Das heißt, das dritte Gerät, wo 64 die Maximalausbaustufe ist, in drei Jahren schaffen sie es nicht, den Speicher zu verdoppeln?
Das Problem ist, die können für 100 Euro nochmal 64 GB reinpacken. Also andere Firmen können das natürlich schon, aber für Apple ist da anscheinend nicht mehr genug Marge. Müssten sie ja 200 nehmen.
Ich würde sofort bezahlen.
Ist dir 64 wirklich zu wenig?
Mir auch.
Ich komm mit 32 locker.
Was hast du da drauf?
Bis der Arzt kommt.
Na, man hält halt ein paar Filme vor, für den Fall, dass man mal einen gucken will.
Na gut, das mach ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, auf dem Phone, weil wenn ich im Zug anfange, den runterzuladen, dann bin ich halt schon in München, bevor ich hier auch nur die Antworte machen soll.
Du könntest ja auch ein iPad dafür nehmen.
Das heißt, deine Kinder müssen dann auch der König der Löwen zum 20.000 Mal gucken in der Bahn. Oder Ariel.
Du hast gar keine Vorstellung.
Die schauen sich immer wieder an.
Und zwar locker 10 Mal so oft, als du es aushältest.
Kevin allein zu Hause habe ich bestimmt als Kind schon 10 Mal gesehen. Oder 20 Mal.
Ich glaube, ich kenne sämtliche Folgen Patt und Matt. Ich kenne sämtliche Folgen irgendwie.
Ich ziehe die Frage zurück.
Doch, Patt und Matt ist aber gut. Wenn ihr das mal über den Weg läuft, guckt ihr mal Patt und Matt an. Vor allen Dingen, das gibt es irgendwie bei YouTube, vor allen Dingen in Holländisch. Das ist einfach super.
Jetzt ist hier der Motorroller.
Das sind so zwei Handwerkertypen. So Art tschechischer Stop-Motion-Animationsfilm. Zwei Typen, so Nachbarn, die irgendwie immer wieder was konstruieren wollen und nicht so ganz den straighten Weg nehmen und dabei alles zerstören.
Also ich fasse nochmal kurz zusammen. 5S, 5C kommen jetzt zusammen und ab jetzt haben wir so eine Strategie, wo Apple immer zwei neue Phones hat. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass es nächstes Jahr gibt es halt das 6S und 6C.
Kann man davon ausgehen? Ich weiß es nicht, ob man davon ausgehen kann.
Nur davon werden jetzt alle erstmal ausgehen.
Das nächste heißt 6.
Und wie heißt denn seine bunt-plastik-Variante? Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Nein, nein, nein, genau das eben nicht. Weil jetzt kommt die nächste Generation, die heißt dann 6. Aber es gibt jetzt das Telefon in zwei Ausbringungen. Es gibt in Forward Thinking, The Future, neue Sachen, die die anderen erst ein Jahr später kriegen. Also Touch ID marschiert dann sozusagen ins C rein. 100 Dollar extra für mehr Zukunft. Und dann ist das irgendwie auch alles schon halbwegs abgehangen. Und dann kann man da auch eine Plastikschale drumrum machen. Es funktioniert immer noch. Vorher funktioniert es halt nur in so einem Schnibbitchensack.
Aber wie heißt es, wenn jetzt mal angenommen, du hast recht, nächstes Jahr gibt es ein iPhone 6 und das jetzige iPhone 5S als Color-Variante. Wie heißt es dann?
5SC. Das ist halt irgendwie Metal Gear. Da werden sie auch weiterhin irgendwelche Metalle schürfen und daraus ein Telefon bauen. Und das nächste ist vielleicht dann nicht mehr aus Alu, sondern aus, was haben sie jetzt ausgelassen?
Nein, ich rede nicht von dem Top, von dem, wie du es nanntest, Forward-Thinking-Phone, sondern von dem, wie nanntest du es? Von dem C-Phone.
Das C-Phone ist halt ein 5C mit A7, mit Touch ID und allem, was das 5S halt jetzt hat.
Ja, aber sie können es ja nicht 5C nennen. Nein, sie nennt es 6C.
Das nächste...
Ich verstehe, du meinst, sie haben erkannt, dass sie natürlich nicht so wie früher, aber das tolle Modell vom letzten Jahr mit dem teuren Gräuser, das ist ja wahrscheinlich ein bisschen teurer, das wollen sie dann nicht als billig von rausbringen, sondern deswegen jetzt immer die billige Version mit Plastik und das Design dann tatsächlich neu, weil es ist ja auch egal.
Das ist überhaupt nicht billig. Nein, bei Apple ist es überhaupt nicht so billig.
Ich denke schon, billiger als das Metall.
Nein, das andere ist teurer. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass das andere billig ist. Das ist einfach das Normale.
C steht nicht für cheap.
Ich bin heute irgendwie raus.
Das ist mir alles.
Und es kann durchaus sein, dass wir irgendwann mal fünf noch irgendein anderer Buchstabe erleben werden, was sozusagen noch niedriger ist. Keine Ahnung. Nee, nicht noch mehr, sondern eher noch weniger. Also, dass du quasi so ein Low-Midrange-Phone auch noch hast. Oder vielleicht machen sie auch noch was zwischen C und S. Was können wir mit Buchstaben sagen noch im Angebot?
K, J? Irgendwie sowas?
E, E, vielleicht.
Ich möchte ein E kaufen.
Ich möchte ein S kaufen. Das ist doch sozusagen jetzt das Motto.
Ich will ein iPhone 6. Ich will kein 6S.
Na, vielleicht wirst du nie ein iPhone 6 mehr sehen. Also es wird einfach das 6S geben.
The new iPhone 6.
Und warum nicht noch ein Buchstab? E kann es nicht sein. Schwierig. Ein 6I. Ein Intermediate Phone sozusagen.
I ist doch viel zu Nokia. Ja, das geht doch nicht.
Haben wir noch andere Themen?
Haben wir eigentlich noch andere Themen?
Also wir hatten kurz das Dock gestreift. Interessant an dem Dock fand ich zumindest, dass das Dock für das 5S kompatibel ist mit dem 5er.
Ja, das ist mal interessant.
Nö, steht auf der Apple Webseite.
Was hätten sie denn da reinbauen müssen, damit es nicht kompatibel ist?
Naja, wenn das 5S leicht andere Maße hat, dann passt es vielleicht nicht. Hat's aber nicht. Ich fand's interessant. Mehr wollte ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Die haben nur innen die Sachen ein bisschen woanders hingelegt, aber von außen ist das absolut das identische Gehäuse, also die Abmaßen auf jeden Fall.
Und dann gibt's diese Leder-Etuis, ne?
Ja, richtig. Den gibt's ja auch in Leder. Und für die 5C gibt's dann noch so cheapo-Schlabber-Silikon mit Löchern und äh...
Bei Apples nix. Nix cheapo, das hast du gerade gesagt.
Das ist cheapo. Die sind voll teuer.
49 Euro.
Mit Special Coating.
Nee, die kosten nur 39. Oder nee, 29 sogar.
Nur hinterhergeschmissen.
Von der Gravitie um die Ohren gehauen.
Ich bitte euch, das ist echtes Silikon. Da machten sich andere Leute die Brüste mit.
Und Apple schmiegt es um dein Telefon.
Da kann man schon mal 29 Euro umgezahlt.
Die hätten gehofft, dass sie sich ihre Brüste damit gemacht hätten. Dann hätten sie anderen Scheiß genommen.
Okay, lass uns da nicht so tief reingehen. Das Thema auf jeden Fall.
Ich finde jetzt auch, ich pulle jetzt hier mal den Profaller und sage, erkläre diese Diskussion jetzt mal hier, wird viel beendet.
Wir sind ja schon bei der nächsten.
Ja, aber die auch. Wie Profaller hat es gesagt. Hier NSA und er ja fuck it. Da reden wir nicht mehr drüber. Aber GCHQ auch nicht.
Gut, lass uns über den App Store reden. Aber wir haben ja schon über den App Store geredet.
Ja, wollen wir mal kurz was Heiteres zwischendurch? Jaaa! Darf ich was Heiteres sagen zwischendurch? Nee, einfach mal so was zur Auflockung so mal kurz ausschütteln. Und zwar einfach nur so einen kleinen Tipp für Leute, die die mal die Schakren ausschütteln wollen, zwischen der ganzen harten Arbeit, den ganzen Studieren, der Frequenzbänder.
Den Kapaltunnel ausschütteln.
Ja genau, die halt so mal ein bisschen Ablenkung zwischen diesen ganzen ernsten und trockenen Themen brauchen. Denn ein Arbeitskollege hat mich darauf hingewiesen, es gibt ja dieses Humble Bundle, habt ihr ja alles schon mal gehört, so ein paar Spiele für Mac, Linux und PC, also Windows. Man darf so viel zahlen, wie man will. Und das letzte Humble Bundle, was jetzt gerade rausgekommen ist, das enthält wirklich sehr viele schöne Spiele. Ihr hört schon wieder nicht zu, es macht heute noch nicht so viel Spaß mit euch zu Podcasten.
Ich hab dich nicht unterbrechen, das ist Humble Bundle.
Das ist aktuelle.
Was sind da so viele Games, die man toll finden möchte?
Das eine heißt Trine 2, das sind ja auch alles immer so Indie-Developer. Wie gesagt, für alle Plattformen, das ist das Coole daran. Trine 2 ist super, super cool. Ich hab bisher Mark of the Ninja gespielt, die beiden. Und für die beiden Spiele alleine, also für Trine 2 und Mark of the Ninja, die sind schon beide alleine so cool, dass der Average Price, der hier so ausgegeben wird, das war glaube ich so...
4,64 Dollar.
Genau, der Average Price ist 4,64 Dollar. Da sind die schon locker alleine wert.
Was sind denn denn für Spiele? Sagt mal jemanden, der bloß WoW kennt und...
Da musst du die Prinzessin retten. Und bei dem anderen musst du wahrscheinlich ganz viel ausverfahren.
Nee, Mark of the Ninja ist ziemlich cool. Da geht's so darum, du bist halt so ein kleiner Anfänger-Ninja. Und es ist so, ja, man sagt schon eine 2D-Welt, aber es geht halt darum, nicht die ganze Zeit in deiner Umgebung so zu verstecken, so hinter Pflanzen, Türen, Rahmen und irgendwie dich so durch Levels durchzuverstecken, an den Wachen vorbei. Und es geht eher so dem... Also zwischendurch haust du auch mal einem auf die Mütze, aber es geht so ein bisschen so um den intelligenten Umgang mit dem Environment und so zur richtigen Zeit, das richtige Versteck und so weiter und so fort. Macht Spaß. Und Tryin 2 ist halt so ein... Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt, so ein Spiel. Sowas wie Prince of Persia nur in Awesome. Also in richtig awesome. Also du hast halt so verschiedene Level, musst ein bisschen Rätsel lösen. Ja, hast so drei unterschiedliche Charaktere und so richtig schönes Storytelling, alles superbunt. Also da mit einer Tüte vorsitzen, auf dem Beamer das Spiel.
Und dann so, ja, vielleicht muss hier die Kiste, ey, ey, Mama, die Kiste da rüber.
Und dann gibt's natürlich noch Brütal Legend, das Spiel, was für Tim überhaupt gar nichts ist. Weil das ist ein Heavy-Metal-Spiel, wo du als Roadie in so eine Heavy-Metal-Welt eintauchst und musst dann mit Axt und Gitarre und einem merkwürdigen Auto musst du dann dich da durchschlagen und irgendwie... Ja, das ist so ein Action-Spiel, was so Prügelelemente hat und es hat auch so ein bisschen Tower-Defense-Elemente und so weiter. Aber das Ganze halt in so einer Metal-Welt mit Metal-Soundtrack und mit merkwürdigen Sprüchen und ist das alles sehr cool.
Sie müssen etwas volkstümlicher sprechen, damit sie die Masse auch versteht.
Aber abgesehen von diesen irritierenden Kommentaren. Das Interessante, wenn man... Kannst du dir mal die Seite von Beamer kurz aufmachen?
Welche Seite?
Handelbandel. Weil ich finde ja ganz interessant, dadurch, dass es das für alle Plattformen gibt, wenn man so ein bisschen runter scrollt. Weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, stopp! Da sieht man nämlich zum Beispiel Total Number of Payments, Number of Purchases. Da sieht man auch wie viele von Mac, Windows und Linux gekauft wurden. Und irgendwo, genau, Windows, average Mac und average Linux. Und da sieht man zum Beispiel, dass die Linux-User bezahlen on average erst mal zwei, ne drei Dollar mehr als die Windows-User zum Beispiel. Und die Mac-User sind irgendwo dazwischen. Also es sind irgendwie... Genau. Also du kannst da unten per Default, das ist da auf 25 Dollar gestellt, aber du kannst auch auf Custom klicken, dann kannst du sagen, wie viel die Developer, wie viel an Charity und wie viel an Humble Bundle an die Organisation geben soll. Dann kannst du die Slider auch selber verschieben. Und das machen sie halt nicht zum ersten Mal. Das gibt es ja schon sehr lange. Man kann übrigens auch mit Bitcoin bezahlen, glaube ich. Und wie gesagt, also ich habe da noch nicht viele von diesen Humble Bundles an Spielen gespielt, aber die Spiele, die jetzt der Kollege mir gezeigt hat, da dachte ich, was? Und du hast dafür wie viel bezahlt? Ja, ich habe 15 Dollar bezahlt und irgendwie für 15 Dollar diese super geilen Spiele. Also da dachte ich, habe ich auch mal wieder Bock drauf. Hier in diesem Video gibt es dann den Trailer, was so die ganzen Spiele alle so machen. Und wenn man mehr als den Average bezahlt, dann kriegt man halt noch ein paar Spiele mehr.
Das ist das, was du dazu bekommst.
Was ist das für ein Spiel?
Das ist halt, das ist was du sozusagen mit Support findest, wenn du da auf Charity klickst, glaube ich.
Und das ist alles jetzt für einen Desktop?
Aber eben, wie gesagt, Cross-Plattform, was halt schon cool ist.
Ach so, und wenn man mehr als den Durchschnitt zahlt, dann kriegt man noch mehr 6 dazu. Ah, das ist ja interessant.
Ich glaube, ein paar von denen waren im vorigen Bundle drin, aber das weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Das ist ja eine coole Strategie sozusagen.
Und alle, die jetzt mehr als ihren Durchschnitt zahlen, schieben den Durchschnitt hoch, ja?
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Und sie hoffen, dass die Leute alle nicht so schlau sind, nur 4,65 Dollar zu bieten.
Das ist ja mal wirklich pfiffig.
Ja, also die machen wirklich coole, also dieses Humble Bundle ist eigentlich immer cool. Und die haben auch coole Ideen. Und die machen das alles wirklich sehr, sehr sympathisch so mit diesem Geld verteilen und so.
Gibt's 5 Dollar aus, kriegste alles, kriegste auch alle Soundtracks.
Und kann man mit Paypal zahlen?
Ja, die Soundtracks sind ja komischerweise nur 3 von Free. Unten rechts?
Ganz unten nochmal?
Oder sind die auch unlocked, wenn ich mehr als die Average bezahle?
Paypal, Amazon, Cardcard.
Wollen wir ein bisschen hoch die Plattformverbreitung?
Du kannst ja selber nochmal klicken, aber es ist halt...
Buy with Bitcoin, was passiert dann?
Du musst erstmal die E-Mail-Adresse angeben.
Warum das denn?
Na, das ist Step 3. Du bist sozusagen... Du hast da 3 Steps wie viel?
Ach so, ich hab... Ich liess die Verteilung.
So viel zum Thema anonyme Sachen kaufen.
Irgendwohin müssen sie dir halt die Unload-Codes und so schicken.
Auf meinen Bildschirm.
Vielleicht willst du die ja auch nochmal merken, dir.
Bildschirm, Kassen und Pest.
Also ich zahle jetzt 5 Dollar, sagen wir mal.
Nee, 4 Dollar 65 ist der Ideal.
Du bist ja ein Cheapskate.
Er will nur testen.
Kannst du dir sagen, wie viel mich von diesem Programm interessieren?
Nicht mehr ähnlich.
Aber immerhin, du kriegst alle Soundtracks.
Also ich glaube, wenn du sowas wie Mark of the Ninja oder Tryin 2, also Tryin 2 zum Beispiel, das könnte dir gefallen, weil da sind halt schon ganz coole so environmental Puzzles drin. Du musst halt irgendwie...
Fez ist wohl auch ganz cool.
Ja, das soll auch ziemlich cool sein, habe ich auch gehört.
Das ist eigentlich so ein 2D-Plattformer-Ding, aber du kannst, also es ist genau genommen auch 3D und du kannst dann immer diesen Turm irgendwie immer rotieren. Also ich hab's nur, ich hab's nur in Videos gesehen.
Was ist ein 2D-Plattformer-Ding?
Na, sowas wie Mario Bros.
Nur so auf Plattform hoch und runter.
Genau, und bei Fez ist es aber so, das ist eigentlich dreidimensional, du kannst immer die ganze Struktur drehen. Und dadurch ändert sich aber, weil du die Struktur gedreht hast, ja auch wieder in 2D alles.
Klar.
So, das ist so halb 3Ds.
Also das Spiel denkt in 3D, die Welt ist in 3D, du siehst aber immer nur 2D.
Ja, und alles, was du in 2D siehst, kannst du auch 2D spielen. Irgendwie. Also das ist...
Wenn man den Trailer sich anguckt und so, da...
Ich hoffe, ich hab das richtig erklärt...
.da gibt's dann auch für die Spiele, glaube ich, jeweils so ein bisschen Intro und...
Und das ist alles für Nokia?
Also alles für Mac, Linux, Windows.
Alles?
Alles.
Ach, ich kaufe auch Windows-Versionen damit?
Du kaufst halt die Lizenz für die Spiele und du kannst sie spielen, wo auch immer du willst.
Das ist ja mit Steven, da kannst du halt dann wechseln.
Das sind alles Games, die es auch auf Windows gibt.
Heutzutage, diese ganzen Indie-Studios, die machen halt eh ihre Spiele mit Unity und so. Die Cross-Platform hinzukriegen, ist einfach nicht so schwierig.
Das heißt, das läuft dann alles auch auf Linux? Stimmt ja, hier steht es ja sogar auch.
Das ist halt das Coole daran, weil sonst hätten sie da wahrscheinlich sehr viel weniger. Ich glaube, viele von denen machen tatsächlich so etwas wie Unity oder irgendwelche Cross-Platform-Frameworks, wo es dann eben die Portierung relativ einfach ist.
Wenn das Cross-Platform ist.
Ich will Native Games haben, die irgendwie die Plattform voll nutzen.
Die brauchen ja nicht. Die brauchen OpenGL, that's it.
Anyway, Humble Bundle haben wir jetzt erwähnt, ausreichen, kauft euch das, wenn ihr Bock auf hat.
Du musst mal zum Arzt oder so, das ist nicht mehr normal denn.
Das find ich echt wieder lauter.
Vaderspeak, hast du irgendwie so ein Polypen oder sowas drin?
Ja doch, vielleicht musst du echt mal dir die Nase durchputzen lassen.
Mach mal das Mikrofon nach oben, das nach unten.
Kannst du auch irgendwo hin machen, das ist völlig egal.
Das kommt wahrscheinlich aus dem Ohr raus.
Ich krieg einfach besser Luft als ihr.
Anyway, so, Upstore haben wir schon erwähnt. Keiner weiß so richtig, was dahinter ist, dass jetzt man auf alten Plattformen, also wenn ich jetzt hier mein iPhone, mein iPad 1...
Da haben Leute, die haben das evaluiert, wollte ich vorhin vorlesen.
Ja.
Bin ich von mir selber unterbrochen worden, wie sich das gehört? War bei, wo ich ganz einfach bei Highes & Mackent Eye stand drin. Die haben das mal einigermaßen dichter beleuchtet. Sekunde, finden wir sofort wieder. Dummerweise, Browserfenster schon kaputt gemacht. Offensichtlich kann man jetzt, also Apple stellt erstmal wieder die alten Dinge, die sie noch irgendwo haben, ja, zur Verfügung. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt draufklickst mit deinem alten 3GS, was halt heute ja auch zum alten Eisen gehört und so, und du klickst auf eine neue App, dann sagt dir der Store wohl, nee, die neueste App kannst du nicht kriegen, aber ich würde dir noch eine ältere anbieten. Was da auch schon mal was ist. Also, ihr gibt sogar einen Screenshot davon, Apple Store erlaubt nur den Download einer älteren App-Version auf iOS-Geräten, die die nötigen Voraussetzungen für die aktuelle Version der Software nicht mitbringen. So, Nutzer eines iPads der ersten Generationen können dadurch beispielsweise die ältere Version einer abinstallieren, die inzwischen mindestens iOS 6 voraussetzt. Bla, bla, bla und so weiter und so fort. Mal sehen, gar nicht installieren. Ich hatte irgendwo anders noch gelesen, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das da auch war, dass jetzt irgendwelche Entwickler sich darüber wohl irgendwie ärgern würden. Wobei ich das jetzt nicht verstehe, wenn jemand jetzt noch ihre Software kaufen kann, verdienen sie ja jetzt damit Geld. Also warum sollten sie sich darüber ärgern? Ist mir nicht ganz klar. Da stand jetzt aber nichts dazu, ob Entwickler diese Altmessungen auch noch mal pflegen dürften.
Das finde ich nämlich auch interessant. Ich bezweifle es aber stark. Allein schon, weil diese Xcode-Environments dann auch irgendwann den Support für diese ganzen alten Plattformen doch auch...
Vielleicht hast du ja die Alte noch. Da du deinen Mecke anzwischen virtualisieren darfst, spricht ja nichts dagegen, sich das alte Zeug aufzuheben, wenn man noch genügend Kunden hat.
Als Developer kannst du auch das alte Zeug, wie du so schön sagst, noch runterladen. Wenn man das unbedingt will, ist es möglich...
Achso, das heißt, die nehmen diese Xcode auch nicht raus. Ihr könnt mir jetzt immer noch irgendwo einen schönen Snow Leopard installieren und da ein altes Xcode drauf machen und dann...
Dein Notebook pfeift.
Ja, der ist irgendwie am Schwitzen. Keine Ahnung.
Kannst du noch hier auf das Podcast stellen, dann pfeift es nicht so laut.
Oh, mein iOS 7 Update ist in ungefähr 80 Stunden fertig.
Aber vielleicht hört es dann 80 schon.
Ich bitte 80. Was hast du, bist du immer noch bei 20?
29.
Ja, ich bin schon bei 80.
Scheint aber noch kein bisschen.
Also, das finde ich jetzt, beim ersten Mal hat er abgebrochen nach 2 Stunden.
Das finde ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen hart. Das habe ich noch nie erlebt, dass wirklich Apple nicht in der Lage ist, ein Update-Performant draus zu spucken. Und das, obwohl es hier über WLAN kommt. What's happening?
Das kann auch durchaus sein, dass jetzt auch mal durchaus der Link zwischen Telekom und Akamai, wo die Akamai ist ja nicht Akamai. Die haben ja nicht überall alles. Die haben ja verschiedene Rechenzentren, wo sie wahrscheinlich nicht jeden Content überall hosten. Wahrscheinlich, weiß ich nicht. Aber es kann durchaus sein, dass jetzt auch mal der Telekom-Link dahin langsam saturiert ist.
Also das EZIX meldet gerade Traffic Record heute. 219 Gigabit.
EZIX. Jetzt können wir mal beim DEZIX nochmal gucken, was da so geht.
219 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Die haben halt zumindest heute einen Traffic-Record.
Ja, aber 200 Gigabit ist ja so.
Ja, die sind halt klein, aber ist ja egal. Trotzdem haben die Traffic.
Was haben sie denn normalerweise?
Ich glaube der Graph war so plus 100%.
Wird bestimmt erst gebrochen von Windows 8.1.
Also angeblich hier im Twitter heißt das immer so irgendwie 91% mehr Traffic in Europa gerade. Und es gab so eine Heatmap und Europa war so ein hot glowing Spot und im Rest der Welt war es so hier und da ein bisschen orange.
Weil sie in den USA wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht realisiert haben.
Ja, wach sind sie jetzt ja langsam eigentlich, stimmt.
Das kann sein, dass sie jetzt erstmal alles wo Takt über ist.
Also es gibt so eine Graphik, die hier so gepostet wurde. Ich packe es mal gerade in den Chat. Copy Ure, da einmal draufklicken bitte.
Wäre es nicht klur gewesen, dass irgendwie überall immer...
Achso, das linkt jetzt auf den Tweet. Ach, dieses scheiß Twitter, ey.
Twitter geht gar nicht, oder?
Es gibt auch ein... Guck mal, das ist viel besser.
Ja, da haben wir angefangen zu streamen.
Ja, genau.
Aber wir streamen über die Deutsche Telekom und die hat mit B6, mit Kröten, Internet Exchange...
Jetzt macht mir doch nicht mein Witz kaputt.
In so einem Mini-Dorf wie Berlin spiert doch die Telekom nicht.
Akamai Real-Time Webmonitor.
Amsterdam glüht. Amsterdam braucht jetzt im Moment gerade nicht heizen. Das Akamai Rechenzentrum heizt für Amsterdam.
Aber das ist doch jetzt nicht Apple, oder?
Das ist Akamai.
Na doch, klar ist das Apple.
Aber wieso denn nur in Westeuropa? Weil die anderen schlafen?
Aber da steht ja auch, dass da, wo rot ist, gerade mal 12% mehr als sonst, oder wie sehe ich das richtig?
Roddy, der Amerikaner, der sich ein Telefon leisten kann, arbeitet jetzt. Und darf in seinem Firmennetz wegen Socks keine Downloads machen. Noch Fragen? Da waren wir doch schon mal.
Ja...
Deswegen siehst du, wenn überhaupt ein bisschen was tut, dann US-Ostküste. Jetzt sind nämlich da die Leute, die schon früher nach Hause gehen und jetzt dann mal dürfen.
Wieso, wie spät ist es denn jetzt gerade in New York?
Also in New York ist es jetzt...
16.22 Uhr. Genau, in San Francisco ist es 13.22 Uhr. In San Francisco müsst ihr auch trotzdem gelöhnt. Da sind noch so viele Nerzen, ist doch egal, wie spät ist es.
Darum geht es nicht. Die arbeiten und dürfen an ihrem Arbeitsplatz so was nicht tun.
Oh, diese armen Menschen.
So, 111% above normal. Das heißt also mehr als doppelt so viel. Das ist doch schonmal was.
Aber darunter, diese Legende, verstehe ich auch, trotzdem noch nicht, warum da 0 bis 12% dann wiederum steht. Also der Gesamttraffic ist 111% über normal, oder was?
Und dann noch mal...
Es sind dann noch mal 12 mehr als...
Also ich meine, da unten siehst du ja auch Kalifornien plus 34%, also...
3,4.
3,4? 1,8, 2,2.
Das kommt alles noch.
3,4% ist jetzt nicht so doll.
Ok, also wir halten fest, Apple released ein Software-Update und die Welt kriegt ein Content-Delivery-Problem. Das ist auch mal interessant. Das ist ein neues...
Nein, das soll auch sein, dass noch andere Content noch geht. Ich könnte jetzt ja spaßeshalber nochmal irgendwie eine neue Fernsehserie laden, pass auf. Ich hab nämlich gerade eine mitgeteilt gekriegt, die wieder fertig sein soll.
Du meinst nur, ihre Server sind über...
Ich nehm jetzt mal den Apple-Dings, allerdings nicht für die Apps, sondern ich nehm jetzt mal hier eine TV-Show. Ich find mal sofort raus.
Ach, du kaufst jetzt mal eben einen HD-Film oder was? Überlastungserscheinungen.
Ich meine, es gab ja neulich auch so ein Ding, da ist der Google mal weg gewesen, für so drei Minuten oder so. Und da hat dann auch 40 Prozent des Internetverkehrs gefehlt. Also das fand ich jetzt mal in Sachen erschreckend, fand ich dann auch ein bisschen erschreckender, wie abhängig doch das Netz oder die Nutzung des Netzes gerade von Google ist.
So, haben wir das Thema denn jetzt irgendwie durch hier? Upstores software update, also wir werden jetzt über iOS 7 nicht so richtig viel reden können, mit Ausnahme das, was wir letztes Mal schon erzählt haben.
Mein Fernsehserien-Download saturiert gerade dein VDSL. Das heißt, das geht noch. Und das kommt aus dem selben Rechenzentrum.
Also Akamai ist nicht das Problem, sondern das Problem sind die Zuleitungen zu diesen iGeräten.
Nochmal, ich gehe jetzt auch gerade, ich lade jetzt gerade mit Full Speed, mit über 5 Megabyte pro Sekunde lade ich diese Fernsehserien aus dem Akamai.
Warum laden wir nicht mit dem selben Speed?
Das ist eine spannende Frage. Das, was ich vorhin gerade sagte, dass ich vermute, dass eben Apple nicht allen Content in allen Rechenzentren hostet. Man könnte jetzt mal snoopen. Wenn du das gerne wissen willst, müsstest du mir jetzt mal Zugriff auf deine Fritzbox geben, dann würde ich jetzt mal snoopen, was hier mein iPad gerade runterlädt, von welcher IP-Adresse das runterlädt. Und dann kann man mal gucken, ob das überhaupt aus Europa kommt oder ob das aus Timbuktuhausen kommt.
Timbuktuhausen. Also wenn du das Dream abreißt, Freunde, ne?
Nein, mach mal slashcatchup.lua hinten dran.
Live sein sie dabei. Kann ich also noch ein kleines Zwischenthema...
Erhalte uns noch mal ein bisschen, bitte.
Was?
Erhalte uns noch mal ein bisschen, dass wir eben mit diesem stumpfen Zeug-Thema wegkommen.
Also Handelbanden haben wir jetzt alle installiert, hoffentlich. Aber das Workflow lädt jetzt nicht, weil deine Fernsehsendung irgendwie das Internet saturiert. Genau. Irgendwie hat ein Freund von mir einen Kollegen heute versucht, sein iPhone aufzunehmen und hat sich gefragt, wie er das macht, weil er hatte gerade nicht diesen Adapter dabei und ist dann auf eine Software gestoßen, die heißt AirServer, wo du sozusagen irgendwie so einen AirPlay-Server auf deinem Rechner hosten kannst und dann schickt dein iPhone das hin und es wird auf deinem Rechner angezeigt und du kannst es dann captchern. AirServer, das hatte ich als Server schon früher auch schon mal.
Das ist älter, gibt schon eine Weile. Ewig nicht benutzt, aber gibt schon eine Weile.
Fand ich auf jeden Fall mal ganz schnuffig, weil kannte ich vorher noch nicht. Wollte ich an der Stelle mal zumindest kurz erwähnt haben. Und, ja, fällt mir noch irgendwas ein, was Heiteres?
Eine heitere Kleinigkeit am Rande. Charles, wer benutzt den? Da kam jetzt gestern oder heute, weiß ich nicht genau, ein Update durch. Manchmal lese ich ja doch, was denn so neu ist in den Update-Notizen. Und da stand da drin, ja, unterstützt jetzt One Password 4. Es gibt aber noch kein One Password 4. Entweder haben sie da was reingeschrieben, was sie noch nicht hätten reinschreiben sollen.
Das kommt doch demnächst, oder? Das gibt es doch schon als Beta.
Das ist schon ganz lange als Beta draußen.
Gibt es schon ganz lange als Beta?
Okay.
Dann war das jetzt nichts besonders Neues.
Worüber reden wir jetzt eigentlich noch? Wir sind noch beim Mac. Siehst du das richtig?
Wir könnten Fusion 6 noch erwähnen.
Wer hat denn dieses Logic X-Thema hier überhaupt aufgeschrieben?
Ich hatte es nur draufgeschrieben, weil in den Show Notes, in den Kommentaren jemand gesagt hat, wir hätten noch gar nicht über Logic X geredet. Aber ehrlich gesagt kann ich da auch nichts zu sagen, weil ich hab's nicht und kenne auch niemanden, der irgendwie dazu mal was Schlaues gesagt hätte. Insofern habe ich das jetzt dahingeschrieben, aber ich kann nichts dazu sagen.
Ja, dann hättest du es gar nicht erst hinschreiben sollen. Außer unter Feedback zu letzter Sendung da oben.
Also wir wissen nichts.
Ich hab's aber gekauft.
Echt? Einfach so? Ich finde das echt eigentlich, ich finde das unverschämt, dass sie einfach keine Try-Version haben, weil das ist ja schon jetzt kein...
Ja, es war auch ein totaler Fehlkauf.
Kleiner Betrag. Ich kaufe mir noch nicht ein Software für 52 Euro, um die vorher mal getestet zu haben. Wie viel kostet es denn jetzt? Immer noch zu viel für, irgendwie probier ich mal aus.
Ja, dafür ist auf jeden Fall nicht genug, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Hammerpreis für diese Suit. Also das muss man mal dazu sagen.
Ja, wenn man weiß, dass man sie haben will. Aber zu Logic gab es noch nie eine Trial-Version. Also zumindest nicht in den letzten zehn oder fünf Jahren.
Ja doch, die Trial-Version gibt es ja im Internet. Muss man nur an der richtigen Stelle klicken.
Bei Isohunt oder was?
Pirate Bay, wer klickt ja noch bei Isohunt?
Ja, gut, dann verschieben wir mal dieses Logic-X-Thema. Ich habe es mir geladen und festgestellt, dass es immer noch nicht Kapitelmarken exportieren kann. Und dann war meine Reise zu Logic-X beendet.
Eine Sache habe ich jetzt noch...
Sehr schmale Anforderung, aber wenn es die nicht erfüllt, dann erfüllt es die nicht.
Bevor ihr da jetzt sozusagen in den nächsten Themenkomplex noch eintaucht, eine Sache haben wir über Phon-Blocks schon mal hier gesprochen.
Werden wir vielleicht nachher noch sprechen, wenn wir über A haben wir hier in der Liste.
Ich hab's reingeschrieben irgendwo.
Da oben ist es doch. Das ist der nächste Punkt, wenn wir hier diesen Bereich überschritten haben.
Den Apple-Foo. Fusion 6 ist rausgekommen und unterstützt jetzt Mavericks.
Du bist jetzt schon wieder ganz woanders.
Da unten bei, wo wir da waren. R-Server, One Password. Das ist ganz interessant, wenn man Mavericks installiert, dann macht er erstmal seine eigene Installations-CD. Weil irgendwie das Installations-Image, was da normalerweise dabei ist, das kann er auch nicht verwenden. Und danach installiert er es aber schön. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe ja von Fusion 5 auf Fusion 6 Pro geupdatet, weil das fast der gleiche Preis ist, als wenn man auf nicht Pro updatet. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das bei Fusion 5 Pro auch schon so war, aber man kann bei einer laufenden VM einfach das Fenster zumachen. Und dann sagt er einem im Hintergrund weiterlaufen lassen. Gibt es so einen Dialog. Klickt man im Hintergrund weiterlaufen lassen, kann man sich abmelden und dann läuft die VM weiter. Obwohl man sich schon abgemeldet hat. Fand ich ganz witzig. Ist jetzt technologisch nichts Neues, aber es geht das erste Mal irgendwie einfach so auf der Oberfläche.
Also mein iPad bekommt den Software-Update per HTTP ohne S aus Cambridge, Massachusetts. Und die geschicke Million von doppelten, also von repetierten Achs. Also es kann auch sein, dass einfach die Gegenrichtung verstopft ist, witzigerweise. Also mein Telefon muss mehrfach sagen, zur Gegenseite, ja habe ich, habe ich, habe ich, ich hab's, ja weiter. Und wie gesagt, ich kann die IP-Adresse hier mal gucken, wo das hingeht. Nochmal, was da so für Pingzeiten drauf sind. Aber das kommt jedenfalls nicht aus Europa. Das kommt per HTTP unverschlüsselt aus Cambridge. Das wird immer lustig. Wenn das jetzt richtig unverschlüsselt durch die Glasfaserkabel an England vorbei läuft, dann knallen heute mal die GCHQ-Platten auseinander. Weil die zeichnet ja alles brutal auf. Egal, ob sie damit was anfangen können oder nicht. Und wenn jetzt die ganzen Europäer alle ihre Updates daran vorbeiziehen, dann haben die heute mal was zu lesen.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Hack.
Dann haben die heute mal was zu lesen. Das finde ich mal interessant.
Und morgen klingelt es dann bei Tim. Wir haben da mal eine Frage.
Wie viele Geräte haben Sie eigentlich?
Ich habe übrigens noch ein Update zu dieser AVB-Diskussion, die wir letztes Mal hatten. Zur Erinnerung, AVB ist das Audio-Video-Broadcasting auf Internet und es gab ja diesen Hinweis, dass unter Mavericks dann so ein User-Interface-Element ist bei der ganzen Netzwerkkonfiguration, wo man das quasi einschalten kann, auch wenn keiner so richtig wusste, was das bedeutet. Ich habe angefangen, mich da mal ein bisschen reinzulesen. Ich bin leider mit diesem einen Dokument nicht ganz zu Ende gekommen. Aber die interessante Information ist, dieses AVB-Zeug gibt es jetzt schon in Mountain Lion.
Das ist schon drin, in 10.8.
Ja gut, das hatten wir irgendwie festgestellt schon letztes Mal.
Na, wir hatten festgestellt, dass es da ein Framework gab, aber es war nicht so klar, ob das Framework dasselbe tut und ob das Ding jetzt was Neues macht. Es sieht nur so aus, als ob jetzt irgendwas da noch einen Schritt weitergeht. Tatsache ist, du kannst auf der Kommandozeile diesen AVB-Kram auch in der Mountain Line einschalten. Und es heißt da in der Doku, wenn du jetzt AVB-kompatibles Zeug verwendest in deinem Netzwerk, dann ja dann sollte es tatsächlich automatisch auf deinem Mac, auf einem Enabled-Interface auftauchen. Das heißt, das ist eine Technologie, wenn du entsprechende Audio-Devices über irgendwelcher Hardware hast, auf Ethernet, und die können mit deinem Rechner kommunizieren und du hast für dieses Interface AVB eingeschaltet, dann erscheinen dort automatische Audio-Interfaces. Was an sich ganz cool ist. Also die Frage, ob Mavericks das dann macht, ist eigentlich, ich hab's jetzt noch nicht laufen gesehen, aber es geht zumindest die Kunde, das geht im Prinzip jetzt schon unter Mountain Line. Du brauchst halt nur ein entsprechendes Device, das sich richtig im Netz anmeldet. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, kannst du auch nur dann auf dieses Device zugreifen, wenn alle Switches, über die du gehst, auch entsprechende Standards unterstützen. Also im Wesentlichen diesen QoS-Kram in verschiedenen Varianten unterstützen. Clemens, kennst du dich da eigentlich mit aus?
Mit diesem Zeugs, mit dem AVB-Zeugs nicht. Aber sonst mit den Switches war mein täglich Brot.
Ich meine, sagt ihr so was wie 802.1 AS, Clock Synchronization was?
Ich weiß, dass es das gibt, aber ich hatte bisher nie eine Anwendung, weil ich kein Gerät dafür in der Hand hatte.
Und sowas wie Traffic Shaping und Resource Reservation?
Resource Reservation gibt es schon länger. Ob jetzt diese QAT ist was anderes, Resource Reservation gibt es schon länger. Das gibt es schon länger auf IP-Ebene. Das hat man sich mal überlegt, als die Bandbreiten noch weniger dünn, weniger dick waren und man dann schon anfing, so ein bisschen IP-Telefonie oder so was zu machen oder Videotelefonie. Und man sich überlegt, na wie kann ich denn mal hingehen und quer durch mein Netz mal ein bisschen Bandbreite reservieren, dass mein Telefon nicht immer ruckelt oder mein Video nicht immer ruckelt in meinem Telefon und so. Das ist aber ein bisschen Vergessenheit geraten. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen der selbe in Grün nochmal für Layer 2. Dass du dein Switch sagst, ey, hier, icke, von dieser Source an diese Destination so und so viele Bits pro Sekunde, garantierst du mir die ja oder nein?
Genau. Wenn er sagt gibt's, dann zack. Und dann wird das halt innerhalb einer bestimmten Priorität sichergestellt. Du kannst also höheren Prioritäten da immer noch unterliegen. Aber das stellt dann eben sicher, dass du über solche Protokolle dir quasi in deinem Netz so eine Domain, so eine AVB-Domain frei stoßen kannst.
Wie ich dir aber in deinem Abdecknet-Kommentar schon geschrieben hab, diese ganze Priorisierung von dem ganzen Zeugs findet nur dann überhaupt Sinn, wenn du irgendwann mal irgendeinen Link saturierst. Solange du einen Switch unter dem Tisch zu stehen hast, der sowohl auf seinem Backplane als auch auf seinen Ports sich die ganze Zeit die Bit schaukelt, brauchst du keine Priorisierung oder und wat. Das ist Quatsch, weil es gibt nichts zu priorisieren. Es ist eh mal bloß einer da und der wird sofort bedient. Fertig. Zack.
Ja, aber bei diesem AVB ist es, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, so, dass wenn der Switch nicht explizit sagt, dass er hier bereit wäre, so eine Reservation auch anzunehmen, dass dann eben diese Kommunikation, also das hinterliegende Device, selbst wenn es noch so toll AVB spricht, nicht in deiner AVB Domain ist und dann nicht entsprechend durchgereicht wird.
Halt dich aber für schade. Man kann ja auch sagen, hallo, du bist der Einzige auf der Welt oder ich bin nur ein Kabel oder ich hab jetzt hier irgendwie nur einen stumpfen Netgears-Switch dazwischen. Ansonsten bist du alleine. Ich find das blöd, wenn die Software sagt, wenn ich nicht reservieren kann, lauf ich gar nicht. Wär schön, wenn du sagst, ich kann dir die Bandbreite nicht reservieren, mach dein Audio auf eigene Gefahren und sagst, ja ja, mach mal und gut ist. Aber sich einfach hinzustellen und gar nichts zu machen, in deinem Fall, ist jetzt auch nicht fair, find ich.
Kann man so sehen, kann man auch anders sehen, weil in gewisser Hinsicht weißt du, wenn überhaupt eine Verbindung zustande kommt, dann sind auch alle Voraussetzungen für Überlastfälle dazwischen auch gegeben. Also du weißt, dass dein Equipment das entspähe.
Dann weißt du auch, dass du 2000 Euro für einen Switch ausgegeben hast, die du hättest eigentlich gar nicht ausgeben müssen, weil du gar nicht so eine Anwendung hast.
Ja gut, so läuft es ja derzeit mit meinem Dante, da muss der Switch noch gar nichts unterstützen, sondern entweder es geht oder nicht.
Der hämmert raus oder es geht oder nicht.
Der hämmert raus, aber dafür habe ich halt auch jetzt das Problem, dass ich eben 100 Dollar für einen Klein zahlen muss, auf meinem Rechner, weil ich sonst halt den Treiber da nicht anlockt bekomme.
Das ist halt... Verrate das, aber ein Switch, der sowas kann, das ist so ein Special-Ding, das interessiert nicht größere Mengen der Telekom-Industrie oder sonst noch was, die fokussieren gerade auf andere Sachen. Das heißt, das ist ein Switch, der wieder speziell für diese Audio-Industrie gemacht wird und das lassen sich die Leute bezahlen.
Also du sagst, diese Standards werden jetzt nicht sowieso irgendwie mal implementiert.
Ach, irgendwann mal. Aber nicht dann, wenn das für dich spannend ist. Also nicht in den nächsten paar Jahren. Also doch, die werden implementiert, aber sie werden in Nischenprodukten implementiert. Das ist das, was ich sage. Das, was die Leute jetzt alle rausglauben, diese ganzen Billions-Switches, auch was du unter dem Tisch hast, diesen SG300 oder so Zeug, diese Sachen, die sind gemacht für einen Massenmarkt, auch für einen Telekom-Massenmarkt zum Beispiel. Deswegen haben die so Features drin, TV-V-Lans, die dann sozusagen das Multicast drüber schwappt in deinen V-Lan, wenn du da einen entsprechenden IGMP-Request rein down hast. Also das ist so für die Leute, wir tun so ein Ding in die Wohnhäuser, wir tun so ein Ding in die Verteilerkästen draußen hin, damit die Leute fern gucken können und telefonieren können. Dafür sind die Features ausgelegt. Das, was du hier hast, richtig breitbandig mit Resource Reservation, Audio und Video und so weiter und so fort, das ist eine solche Speziale Anwendung derzeit noch, dass die länger daraus nicht interessiert. Die machen best effort und best effort ist gut genug. Solange du mehr Ports und mehr Bits auf dem Backplane hast, als du Usage hast, brauchst du nämlich diese ganze Reservierung nicht.
Warum eigentlich nicht? Da haben wir glaube ich vor einem Dutzend Sendungen mal drüber gesprochen. Und du hast dich mit Händen und Füßen geweigert, irgendwie das Teil mal direkt an den Rechner anzuschließen? Und ich habe nicht verstanden warum.
Nein, diese AVB-Ding, das weiß ich ja erst seit Kurzem, dass das überhaupt hier geht. Das war ja die Rede davon, dass bei Meverix das Feature ist. Jetzt habe ich ja erst rausgefunden, dass das schon bei CNR8 einschaltbar ist. Ich habe es eingeschaltet. Ich bin aber jetzt noch nicht dazu gekommen, hier mal direkt ein Kabel zu spannen, weil ich einfach unterwegs war.
Wäre eine Empfehlung. Andererseits, wie gesagt, diese Standards sind auch noch so neu, du musst überlegen, dass so ein Switch, ja eigentlich normalerweise Sachen, die ihr nicht kennt, die schaufelt einfach von links nach rechts durch. Es gibt im Layer 2 nicht so einen Mechanismus, wie eine Time-to-Live, wo ein Gerät sagen kann, hallo, ich möchte hier was senden, das geht aber nur an meinen Switch, das geht auf gar keinen Fall auf der anderen Seite des Switches wieder raus. Sowas gibt es im Purenprotokoll nicht. Es gibt ein paar Protokolle, die so gedacht sind, wie zum Beispiel gut der alte Spanning Tree-Algorithmus oder was weiß ich, Cisco CDP oder LLDP. Das sind so Discovery-Protokolle, wo jetzt Geräte einander gegenseitig erkennen. Die sind aber vom Protokoll her so designt, dass der Switch sagt, oh ja, das kenn ich, das beantworte ich selber, das leite ich nicht auf der anderen Seite wieder raus. Alle anderen Sachen, die du in so einen Switch rein donnerst, haut er einfach aus den anderen Ports wieder raus. Das heißt, er ist eigentlich für Sachen, die er nicht kennt, transparent. Eigentlich. Was es denn noch gibt, ist, dass er Sachen kennt, aber nicht kann. Das wäre zum Beispiel bei einem Switch, der diese AVB, oder 800, was war das, 3QAT oder solche Sachen, dass er weiß, dass das existiert, aber selber nicht mitspielt. Dann filtert das raus. Aber wenn du jetzt einen normalen Switch, einen Netgear-Switch nimmst, oder meinetwegen auch diesen SG300, der kennt das nicht, der wird das da reinhustest auf der einen Seite, kommt auf der anderen Seite wieder raus. Dann verhält es sich wie ein Draht.
Der SG300, der kann doch ziemlich viel.
Der kann ziemlich viel, aber er kann kein QAT oder QAS oder solche Sachen.
Ja, es gibt halt diese Migration hier von Dante. Heißt halt, im Prinzip machen wir das alles schon richtig. Wir müssen bloß auf unserem Clocksync-Protokoll den richtigen Stempel drauf machen. Und das gleiche auch beim Audiotransporter und das gleiche auch bei dem ganzen Quality-of-Service-Kram, wo er derzeit halt diese VoIP-Features im Wesentlichen benutzt. Und dann, wenn es mal die entsprechenden Updates gibt, dann gibt es das irgendwann mal vielleicht. Aber solange muss ich noch für Kleines zahlen. Sauerei, alles zu teuer.
Was ist die Abkürzung von dem AVB?
Von dem AVB die Abkürzung?
Also es gibt halt drei Standards, die hier wohl eine Rolle spielen.
Genau, und QAV. Also es gibt halt auf der einen Seite das Traffic Shaping definiert das als eine, und das andere definiert diese Reservation. Und der dritte Standard, der da eine Rolle spielt, ist diese Clonk Syncing. Also überhaupt diese hochgradig, hochakkuraten Syncing zwischen Rechnern hinzubekommen, brauchst halt 802.1 AS. Das ist im Wesentlichen nichts anderes als dieses IEEE 1588, was sie halt damals für Military erfunden haben, was eben Audinet heute schon verwendet. Die sind dem halt so ein bisschen voraus. Ich werd mir das nochmal genauer anschauen, aber ich wollte nochmal da so ein Update geben, es könnte spannend werden, auch wenn es vielleicht noch dauert, bis wir solche Geräte sehen.
Also nur kurzer Update noch, weil ich das jetzt inzwischen mal analysiert habe. Da, wo mein iPad sich derzeit in immer noch 80 Stunden den Update gerade herholt, das ist nachweislich USA, ist Akamai. Aber hinter Quest, also die Verbindung von uns hierhin, geht einmal durch den Quest-Backbone dahin und da fängt es an zu hacken. Also es ist, wie ich vermutet habe, so eine Sache mit dem Peering, mit den Leitungen auf der Telekom. Die Akamai-Leute peeren ja mit Gott und der Welt, offensichtlich nicht direkt mit der Telekom, sonst müssten wir da nicht durch Quest irgendwie durch wackeln und sobald wir das Quest-Netz berühren, fängt an die Latency sich zu verdoppeln und zu verdreifachen und dann wird das schlimm. Also das ist irgendwie ein Peering-Thema. Und wie gesagt, die Tatsache, dass es überhaupt aus den USA kommt, statt aus Amsterdam.
Du hast doch einen amerikanischen iTunes-Account.
Nee, aber den weißt du doch bei der Software-Aktualisierung nicht. Ich hab ja nicht gesagt, meinen Film. Meinen Film, den hab ich ja garantiert aus Europa geholt. Der lief ja auch durch. Nur das Update, wie gesagt, kommt aus Amerika.
Wie gesagt, die ganzen GM-Bilds liegen alle bei Isohan, Pirate Bay, wie auch immer. Man sucht sich die richtige Nummer aus, lädt es da über Torrent runter, macht schwuppschwuppschwupp, dann ist es da. Die sind ja auch nicht allzu groß eigentlich. Ein Gigabyte bei meinem Fümmer für die älteren Telefone eher kleiner und dann geht es halt viel flotter. Dann warte, wenn die Leute nicht warten können und da 10 Stunden stehen, hast du 20 Minuten. Zum Noten kann man ja woanders noch gucken, ob irgendwie die Hashes stimmen und so, dass diese Images da auch okay sind. Außer wenn die nicht okay wären, heißt es, es würde schon ein Jailbreak geben und es gibt ja noch keinen. Also brauchen sie sich da keine Sorgen machen.
Gut, was hat es jetzt mit den Phonenblogs auf sich? Phonenblogs? Du wolltest doch die Phonenblogs.
Ja, also ich dachte mir, als ich das gesehen habe, also wenn ich mir mal nochmal eine Alternative zum iPhone besorgen sollte, dann würde ich ja glaube ich am allerersten mal das probieren. Das klingt irgendwie ganz witzig. Und Phonenblogs, also wie Blogs nur mit K statt CK geschrieben, das ist halt so ein Telefon, wo man so modulare Komponenten hat, wie der Name Doppelt-Gemobelt schon sagt. Das heißt, man hat irgendwie so einmal sein Hauptgerät und kann dann so Kamera und alle möglichen anderen Komponenten halt so zusammenstecken, wie man es gerade braucht. Und der Vorteil, den sich davon versprechen ist, dass es dann vielleicht irgendwann mal ein Modul gibt mit einer viel besseren Kamera oder wenn man eine größere Kamera will, dann kann man irgendwie die draufstecken und kann irgendwie dafür sich ein Stück Batterie weglassen oder keine Ahnung. Ist halt ja im Prinzip so ge-crowdfunded, wie man auch auf der Phonblogs-Webseite schon sieht. Ist also noch nicht real, aber war auf jeden Fall mal eine ganz spannende Idee. Ich meine der Formfaktor ist jetzt natürlich sehr Lego-like. Sehr Lego-like, aber so als Idee trotzdem irgendwie ganz schick. So dass man eben diesen Verfall der Geräte vielleicht auch dadurch ein bisschen stoppt oder was auch immer, indem man eben die Module, wie man sie braucht und wie sie neu rauskommen, dann eben draufstecken kann und dann auch für einzelne Updates nicht sozusagen mehr bezahlt, sondern eben nur das Kameramodul sich neu kauft.
Das wird bestimmt gut funktionieren.
Ja, ich meine, ich trotzdem, also... Das ist auf jeden Fall mal, wenn es schon ein Frickel-OS und so, dann auf Frickel-Hardware und dann kann man wenigstens mal so ein bisschen rumspielern, also ich finde das ja schon ganz schick. Und dann kannst du halt, ist ja dieser Traum, so vorm Smartphone als Trikorder, dann kannst du halt wirklich so ein Modul bauen, was jetzt irgendwie Gamma-Strahlen messen kann, also Geigerzähler oder was auch immer, kannst du dir halt auch ein, wie heißt denn das nochmal, ein Geigerzähler-Modul da ranstecken oder...
Als Musiker kannst du dir ein Geigenzähler einbauen?
Ja, Thermometer, irgendwie so ganze Wetter, diese ganzen Wettersensoren, alles da dran kleben, fände ich zum Beispiel total geil. Ich wäre immer noch den Trikorder als Smartphone und so.
Was ich toll finde an der Idee ist, dass du halt eben sagst, wenn dir mal was kaputt geht, musst du nicht das ganze Scheißding wegschmeißen. Oder wenn du halt eben mehr Storage brauchst oder Display mal wieder mit einer neuen Resolution rauskommt, dann kann man das halt eben auch austauschen. Also die Idee einfach, dass man nicht dauernd so viel Müll produziert, nur weil einem ein Feature nicht mehr passt oder weil es kaputt ist, finde ich halt eben auch ganz nett. Wo ich gerade das Mikrofon habe, jetzt noch abschließender Update dazu. Der Film, den ich lade, kommt im Übrigen von, und das ist sehr erstaunlich, habe ich auch nicht gewusst, der kommt von Akamai, aber nicht aus Amsterdam, sondern aus Hamburg. Und zwar über eine direkte Anbindung der Telekom. Das heißt, die Telekom hat in der Tat Anbindung an Akamai, direkte Anbindung an Akamai Hamburg jedenfalls. Da kommt der Paid-Content her von Apple. Offensichtlich, ich bin ja auch frech, ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal, dass der Apple sich sagt, die Leute, die hier was kaufen und Geld ausgeben, die kriegen auch gerne unseren dichtesten, tollsten Server, den wir haben. Und der Rest, der hier bloß Updates für umsonst schnauern will, der soll sich mal bitte da an der Ubers-Ostküste mit dem Scheiß-Ding da bei Quest rumärgern. Naja, das ist ganz deutlich, ist beides Akamai. Und wie gesagt, der Paid-Content kommt hier direkt aus 200 Kilometer weg, der Rest kommt über 6000 Kilometer weg.
Vielleicht würde ja das Image auch, also ein paar Leute haben ja gesagt, im iTunes lädt das Image viel schneller runter.
Das kann durchaus sein, wenn mir mein iTunes endlich mal anbieten würde, dass es da für ein Update gibt. Aber mein iTunes meint, hat keinen Bock darauf.
Vielleicht ist es einfach nur ein Fuck-Up. Also ich meine, das ist auch immer noch möglich.
Weil sie machen es ja auch alle zum ersten Mal.
Tja, wo wir bei Telefonen waren, das hatten wir letztes Mal nicht besprochen. Es gibt eigentlich auch heute nichts Neues dazu zu sagen, aber es gibt dieses Fairphone noch. Irgendwie, das sind irgendwie Jungs aus Holland, die sind der Meinung, sie wollten ein Telefon bauen, wo möglichst viele Komponenten unter fairen Bedingungen, also keine Kinderarbeit usw. hergestellt werden. Das klingt alles fürchterlich interessant. Das Phone ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht zu schlecht, aber so richtig angemacht hat mich das jetzt nicht. Also ich weiß nicht, ob jemand eine Meinung zu hat.
Ich finde Phoneblogs geiler.
Also ich finde auch nicht, dass die Webseite einem irgendwie dieses Telefon auch irgendwie verkauft. Also es ist so, ja, sie sprechen davon, wie fair sie sind, aber das eigentliche Phone bekommt irgendwie auch nur so einen kleineren Teil da an Share. Was ist denn jetzt das Tolle damit? Und was kann ich damit machen? Sondern nur, was habe ich damit nicht gemacht?
Ist ein bisschen unklar. Es ist halt ein Projekt, was eben im Wesentlichen dafür gegründet wurde, dass man eben demonstrieren will, dass es auch anders geht. Hier mein Freund Bicycle Mark, der hat da auch schon mal ganz früh vor zwei Jahren schon Interviews gemacht, wo man kann, wie das irgendwie alles gestartet ist, bis wir halt wirklich dieses Fairphone als solches auch vorgestellt haben. Aber, keine Ahnung, also ich finde ihn, die Idee finde ich irgendwie ganz interessant, aber dass das jetzt eben wirklich eine konkurrenzfähige Plattform wird, das sehe ich so nur sehr eingeschränkt. Muss ich, muss vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt sein, deckt halt einen bestimmten Markt ab.
Naja, sie haben jetzt gerade eben erst von 20.000 auf 25.000 Stück, die sie bauen wollen, geupgraded und haben davon jetzt 15.000 verkauft. Also es klingt jetzt nicht so, als wäre es der große Killer von was auch immer.
Ja, na die Frage ist, was läuft da drauf?
Na ein Android 4.2, soweit ich weiß.
Ja.
Ohne irgendwas über Android sagen zu wollen, weil wir machen das ja eh immer falsch.
Ja, in dem Zusammenhang auch, ich war hier gerade auf so JavaScript-Konferenzen oder einer viel mehr und da waren dann auch so real-life Firefox-OS zu sehen auf entsprechenden Phones, wie zum Beispiel dem Geeks-Phone. Das verfolgt jetzt eben nicht unbedingt dasselbe Umfeldsziel, aber eben, wie ihr euch denken könnt, einfach den freies Device. Das ist halt so eine Art iPhone-Klon in JavaScript. Naja, eben, also die Software, die da drauf läuft, die Apps, die machst du halt in JavaScript.
Das war doch damals irgendwie bei, wie hießen sie, Palm? Doch auch schon so eine tolle Idee, die nicht verfangen hat.
Ja gut, seitdem ist aber auch wirklich viel Wasser in Jordan runtergegangen. Die Situation ist schon jetzt eine andere.
Du überschenst den Jordan gleich.
Ja, Jordan ist ein totales Gerinnsel geworden. Um ehrlich zu sein, wenn du so ein Telefon in der Hand hast und benutzt, dann fühlt sich das auch so ein bisschen an wie Gerinnsel. Ja, Victoria Falls Versus so ein von den Israelis ausgetrockneter Jordan. Ich kann das gar nicht schlecht machen. Ich meine, das sind halt so Telefone, die kannst du jetzt eben mal so kaufen und dann hast du da dein Firefox-OS drauf und dann kannst du da eben deinen Javascript-Climb im machen. Das ist insbesondere für so webaffine Entwickler aus der Javascript-Szene ist das schon eine ganz interessante Plattform, weil das eben wirklich von Idee zu Running Code, da musst du halt nicht durch sonderlich viele Ringe springen und musst auch nicht dieses ganze Java-Desaster mitmachen, was du halt bei Android erstmal vor der Nase hast, sondern du kannst halt in der...
Du musst ja bei Android gar nicht mehr Java machen.
Mono?
Oder ist die Sharp?.NET? Zum Beispiel das Cocos 2D und so. Es gibt auch hier diese Cross-Plattform-Compiler, die Objective-C-Code nehmen und nach Android sozusagen mehr oder weniger eins zu eins translaten und die benutzen auch LLVM dafür und haben so ziemlich die gleiche Compiler-Infrastruktur.
Aber ich rede von, du tippst etwas JavaScript in eine TX-Satei und es läuft.
Also ehrlich gesagt, I'm not convinced.
Du musst nicht nur, ich sage nur, dass du auf Android nicht notwendigerweise das Java-Drama hast.
Ja, aber wenn du da wirklich jetzt seriös für develops, dann machst du das halt in Java.
Ich glaube, du machst das nicht in Java.
Also wenn du seriös developst, dann machst du es nicht in Java.
Ja, ich glaube so ist das tatsächlich eher.
Nochmal zu dem Geeks-Pod. Also diesen Blog-Artikel, den ich ja jetzt irgendwie seit zwei Sendungen schon unterbringen wollte. Hier ist jetzt der Punkt mal gekommen. Why mobile web-Apps are slow? Das ist nämlich genau dieses Java-Skript auf dem Mobile-Device. Das ist halt was, was ich überhaupt nicht davon überzeugt bin, dass das in irgendeiner Weise Zukunft hat. Weil das wird nie richtig laufen. Also es gibt diesen Blog-Artikel, ich hab ihn gerade in den Chat geschmissen. Also der macht mal einmal so richtig das Fass auf, was es eigentlich bedeutet, Java-Skript auf dem Mobile-Device. Und der fängt bei der Hardware an, geht über keine Ahnung, wie schnell läuft Nativa-Code, wie schnell läuft denn Java-Skript-Code, auch bei guten Engines, geht über, wie ist das denn mit dem Speicher, wie ist denn das mit der Garbage Collection und. Und zum Schluss hat man so das Gefühl, ja, eigentlich hat er so alle Winkel, eigentlich hat er alle Winkel irgendwie einmal ausgelotet. Also der lässt so richtig die Fundierungssau raus und man hat nicht das Gefühl, es gibt noch irgendwas dazu zu sagen, zu dem Thema, wenn man das gelesen hat. Und deswegen, ich sehe das nicht so richtig.
Ja, ich meine, dass das langsamer ist, ist mir vollkommen bewusst.
Mann, Jungs, jetzt macht doch hier mal nicht so einen Scheiß die ganze Zeit.
Die Caspern, ne?
Casper wenigstens, ohne dabei in die Sendung zu quatschen.
Wir schauen jetzt hier, warum das nicht update. Mein iPad darf jetzt nicht updaten, sagt mir Apple.
Nicht das Thema wechseln.
Wie auch immer.
Ich wollte nochmal darauf hinweisen, weil es mir nicht so ganz klar war, ist, dass dieses Firefox ist real. Also man kann das bekommen und benutzen. Und es mag durchaus interessant sein, so JavaScript-basierte Sachen auszuprobieren. Und das mit der Performance ist halt sozusagen etwas, was sich hier später einstellt, aber irgendwann dann eben auch nachkommt. Ja, ich hab so auf dieser Reject.js, wo ich war, ich meine, Astro hat da einen BitTorrent-Streaming-Client in JavaScript in Chrome präsentiert.
Auf einem mobilen Device?
Nein, nein. Aber auf einem mobilen Device gab es immerhin einen Nintendo Retro-Simulator.
Also der schreibt hier in dem Artikel, man muss davon ausgehen, dass auf einem mobilen Device JavaScript ungefähr um Faktor 10 langsamer ist als auf einem Desktop.
Diesen riesen langen Artikel von vor mehreren Wochen, den hatten wir doch schon bei der Sendung hier.
Und ungefähr Faktor 50 langsamer als Nativercode auf einem nativen Rechner. Also auf einem Desktop-Rechner. Also ein ganzes OS um JavaScript rumzustricken, halte ich für ein heeres Ziel, aber Unsinn.
Ja, das ist halt Low End.
Die sind dann halt immer zwei, drei Jahre hinterher, ne?
Ja, du hast halt einen Browser und der ist jetzt nicht in JavaScript geschrieben und du kannst aber mal so eben kleine Wecker-Ups und Tra-La-La und Wetter-Auskunft-Dinger und so weiter. Also einfach so dieser Standard-Kram, den kannst du damit irgendwie auch machen.
Ganz ehrlich, also derjenige, der mit einem mobilen OS kommt, wo nicht JavaScript oder Java oder irgendeine andere Scriptsprache drauf läuft, sondern wo mal jemand irgendwie eine ordentliche Programmiersprache sagt, das hier ist unsere zentrale Entwicklungsumgebung mit einer ordentlichen, kompilierten Sprache, den nehme ich als erstes ernst. Und alle anderen können einfach erstmal weitermachen. Also da muss ich sagen, finde ich den Ubuntu-Ansatz noch am brauchbarsten. Die haben zwar auch gesagt, hier JavaScript könnt ihr machen, aber wenn ihr richtige Apps schreiben wollt, dann macht ihr das unter C. Und wir haben hier eure API dazu. Gut, C ist jetzt natürlich nicht jedermanns Sache, aber... Aber da kann man wenigstens ordentliche Apps schreiben.
Gut, wie auch immer. Geeksfone kann man kaufen, kostet irgendwie Geld. Und dann hat man Firefox OS, wenn man es haben will.
Kann man so machen.
Genau.
Und ansonsten kann man so anderes drauf spielen.
So, wie sind wir denn so in der Zeit?
Ganz kurze Update nur.
Wir haben schon drei Stunden durch.
Wenn man das macht, was ihr gesagt habt, nämlich den Update runterladen über iTunes, nicht über das Gerät selber, braucht er nur 18 Stunden statt 80. Und lädt es nicht aus Cambridge, sondern aus Chicago. Mit demselben Problem. Bricht zum Quest-Backbund zusammen.
Mit deinem US-Account?
Mit meinem deutschen Account.
Ja, was erlaube Akamai?
Nicht Akamai.
Was erlaube wer denn?
Warum routet die Telekom zu Akamai USA über Quest?
Vielleicht weil du kein Telekom-Kunde bist.
Wir sind hier Telekom-Kunde.
Aber warum routet sie nicht zu Akamai Europa?
Das entscheidet ja jemand anders. Der Akamai stellt ja sozusagen nur den eigentlichen Content da. Die Entscheidung, ob du upgraden darfst oder nicht, und vorher diese XI Accepted Terms-Trader gedrückt hast, das macht ja noch ein anderer Goken-Server.
Das ist so ernsthaft, dass so was wie ein iOS 7-Update nicht auf europäischen Servern liegt. Warum sollte denn das nicht da liegen?
Wir haben jetzt hier vier Versuche gemacht und alle davon kamen aus den USA.
Über V4 oder V6?
Das Ding, Apple spricht bloß V4. Wenn ich nächstes Mal in Cupertino vorbeikomme, klebe ich den so einen großen Aufkleber drauf, den ich neulich schon von ITF hatte, mit diesem Horse Carriage da, so warning this device contains irgendwie alten Scheiß und so. Obwohl die Geräte alle V6 können, aber Apple selber ist voll auf V4. Ich hab noch keine einzigen V6-Adresse im Apple-Universum gesehen. Keine.
Null. Die haben doch auch ein A-Netz. Klaas A-Netz.
Ein was? Warum sollen die denn V6 machen?
Ja, du weißt, was ich meine.
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Aber es mag sein. Nichtsdestotrotz, Apple doesn't give shit. Übrigens, Akamai kann V6. Das heißt, wenn Apple sagen würde, hier hast du einen Namen, greif dir mal die Daten, und dann passt das schon, würden sie das auch machen. Würde gehen. Aber Apple selber, ich hab noch keine einzigen Adresse gesehen im Apple-Universum, die V6 hat.
Nun.
Ich kann auch noch eine Konferenz erwähnen.
Ich hab ja meine noch gar nicht erwähnt. Soll ich das nochmal machen? Ich war auf der Reject.js. So ein ganz interessantes Teil.
Wofür steht das? Reject JavaScript?
Ja, JS steht für JavaScript. Und das Ganze ist eigentlich die JS Conf, die in Berlin stattgefunden hat am letzten Wochenende. Das ist schon eine renommierte JavaScript-Konferenz. Da laufen wirklich gute Leute auf. Das ist auch wirklich eine ganz coole...
Aber warum Reject?
Naja, es gibt halt eingereichte Vorträge und manche werden halt abgelehnt. Und die JS Conf selber ist halt am Samstag und am Sonntag. Und am Donnerstag davor gibt's erstmal einen Tag die Reject JS, wo du halt nochmal abgelehnte Vorträge kriegst. Das ist sozusagen nochmal eine Prä-Konferenz zum Warmwerden.
Klingt ja sehr verlockend. Nur abgelehnte Vorträge.
Ja, ich hab sie aber, hab ein paar, die Hälfte davon gesehen und fand mich durchaus entertaint. Also das war jetzt nicht schlecht. Sondern das Angebot scheint auf der JS Conf so gut zu sein, dass da eben auch noch genug übrig bleibt. Und ich meine, nur weil sie abgelehnt waren, heißt es ja nicht, dass sie schlecht sind. Es heißt nur, dass sie abgelehnt sind. Wie auch immer, ich finde das ein schönes Modell, um so eine populäre Konferenz herum nochmal so eine Starter-Sache zu machen, wo sich nochmal separat was abspielt. Aber eben mit zeitlicher Nähe. Und am Donnerstag liefen auch so diverse Sachen hier mit NoteCopter und so, weißt du, diese JavaScript auf... JavaScript steuert Drohnen und so. Also nicht auf, also auf Drohnen ist wohl der nächste Schritt. Jetzt ist es erstmal JavaScript steuert Drohnen. Wie auch immer. Ich fand das sehr nett, sehr nett gemacht. Ja, ich hab noch eine Frage. Achso, du wolltest noch diese andere...
Eine andere Konferenz, auf der ich war, während die Reject oder JS-Conference oder was auch immer lief, Baruku. Es gibt ja sehr viele Ruby-Konferenzen. Mittlerweile auch wirklich tatsächlich überall auf der Erde und zu jeder Tages- und Jahreszeit gibt es irgendwie gerade eine Ruby-Konferenz auf Hawaii, in Argentinien, Kolumbien. Die Sprache hat es so gemessen an den Konferenzen, die so im Jahr stattfinden, tatsächlich echt weit gebracht. Ja, aber ich meine, es heißt ja trotzdem schon was, wenn es überall Communities gibt, die es organisieren. Und bei der war jetzt auch der Mats da, der sonst ja eigentlich nur auf die Großen fährt und auf die Euroku, die European Ruby-Konferenz.
Also der Mats ist derjenige, der Ruby mal erfunden hat.
Genau, und das war auch ganz witzig, der hat gesagt, gleich am Anfang, also jetzt so nach all den Jahren und irgendwie haben ihn mal Leute gefragt, warum er sich jetzt für Mats als Nickname entschieden hat, weil er eigentlich Yuki Hiro, Matsumoto heißt so, hey Yuki, was geht? Und er meinte, so in Japan ist das halt so, dass man sich nie beim Vornamen nennt, wenn man nicht gerade richtig Family und Close Friends ist. Deswegen ist es ja komisch für ihn in Europa, wenn ihn alle so mit Yuki Hiro ansprechen würden und dann hat er sich halt schon relativ früh dafür entschieden, einfach auf so Mats zu gehen, weil das dann so die Europäer zufriedenstellt, weil das klingt wie so ein westlicher Name oder so, westliche Kultur. Und er findet es halt trotzdem auch cool, weil es halt sein Nachname eigentlich ist und nicht sein Vornamen.
Der lässt dich sozusagen von allen sitzen.
Genau. Auf jeden Fall war ich da letztes Jahr schon, das Programm war da schon relativ gut und es ist halt in Berlin, im speziellen Brach, auch dort schon der Herbst aus, also hier brach der Herbst aus und dann bin ich da rübergefahren. Strahlender Sonnenschein, 30 Grad, leckeres Essen und so weiter. Das war so genau der richtige Punkt, um nach Barcelona zu fahren. Dieses Jahr war das Programm der Konferenz noch besser, also wirklich, ich weiß nicht, ob die 20 Talks hatten und einer von den 20 Talks war irgendwie so medium, alle anderen waren richtig gut. Also vom Programm her kann man das empfehlen und dann ist es halt eben, was ich gerade schon sagte, wir waren dann auch noch zwei Tage länger da, wenn man schon mal in der Sonne ist und die Füße ins Meer steckt, dann sollte man das natürlich machen, während in Deutschland gerade 16 Grad oder Kälter und Regen.
Das hab ich Anfang des Jahres gemacht, im April als hier noch irgendwie 5 Meter Schneelagen in Berlin.
Genau, also Barcelona, Baruko kann man für die Leute, die sich so ein bisschen für Ruby interessieren oder interessieren wollen, ist das eine wirklich sehr schöne, die Konferenz, die Location war auch wirklich extrem gut und alle toll. Also super. Ich hab ja schon viele Ruby-Konferenzen gesehen und die ist schon mit einer der tolleren.
So, ich hab noch eine Frage und dann haben wir noch so ein Thema vom letzten Mal. Ich hab grad so das Problem auf den Tisch bekommen, mir Gedanken darüber zu machen, was man sich so für Hotspot-Devices kauft, wenn man so was braucht. Also so kleines, mobiles, akkugetriebener 3G, Slash LTE.
Früher nannte man die Mi-Fis.
Oder Mi-Fi, genau, ja Hotspots.
Mobile Wi-Fi Kombinator.
Ja, Mi-Fi, stimmt, genau.
Weil das ist ja ein Name. Ein Name für eine Firma, für ein Produkt?
Nee, die nennen das dann auch so. Also das ist wirklich genauso wie die Amis ja WLAN, Wi-Fi nennen, nennen sie diese Dinger Mi-Fi, so viele ich weiß. Also vielleicht ist das auch ein Produkt.
Genau, also Mi-Fi.
Rempo sagen.
Hast du da irgendwie eine Meinung, Clarence? Also es gibt da diverse Geräte, die wohl auch recht populär sind, von Morawie, von Huawei? Huibu, genau.
Ich habe zwei von den Dingern aus der UMTS beziehungsweise HSDA-Ära, die ich sehr sehr selten benutze. Nicht deswegen, weil sie jetzt richtig total scheiße sind. Eins ist ein bisschen nervig, das neuere Device hat eine beschissene Firmware als das alte. Das crasht nämlich, wenn man Skype benutzt. Ja, crasht dann einfach. Bootet dir der Router weg, willst du auch nicht unbedingt. Ja, wenn du selber weißt, ist es okay, aber die Dinger scheren ja für mehrere Devices. Ich hatte die Dinger dann so mit, weißt du, auf so Tanzevents im Ausland oder so, wo dann auch andere Deutsche da sind, die nicht so geekig sind wie ich und jetzt mit einer schwedischen SIM-Karte rumrennen. Hab dann gesagt, hier bucht euch da ein. Das erste, was die launchen, ist Skype. Weil sie nach Hause telefonieren wollen. Ja, funktioniert, kannst du machen. Ich finde, es gibt so ein paar Sachen da dran, die sind irgendwie komisch. Also zum Beispiel diese affige Begrenzung auf fünf Devices. Kann doch sein, dass es inzwischen Geräte gibt, die zehn gibt. Es gibt keinerlei Grund dafür, wirklich aus technischen Gründen. Was soll das? Was soll diese Begrenzung dafür? Ist mir nicht ganz klar. Ansonsten sind die verhältnismäßig easy to use. Das funktioniert wie so ein Plastorouter zu Hause. Da machst du deine SIM-Karte rein, startest das Ding mit Wifi, buchst dich da erst mal ein. Manche von denen kann man sogar per USB ansprechen. Die HuiBu-Dinger, die ich hatte, konnte es auch wie so ein extern, weißt du, wie so ein Dongel, das jemand früher hatte, oder wie so ein USB-Stick, kann man die auch benutzen. Was denn vielleicht von der Stromversorgung her netter ist, als das Ding jetzt irgendwie an der Batterie die ganze Zeit nuklen zu lassen, während du mit deinem Laptop am Strom surfst. Dafür brauchst du wieder einen Treiber. Ja, den liefern die mit. Und zwar, das Ding ist auch gleichzeitig ein Storage-Device. Und manche von den HuiBu-Dingern haben sogar noch an der Seite so einen kleinen Micro SD-Slot, da kannst du unerwart reinstecken. Aber wenn du den Ding reinsteckst, dann meldet sich per USB, dann mountet dein Betriebssystem dieses Virtual Storage-Device und da ist ein Treiber für Windows und für OS X drauf.
Ja, wenn er dann halt nach zwei Jahren total outdatet und es nicht mehr aktualisiert wird, beziehungsweise man die Seiten nicht findet.
Es gibt was viel Schlimmeres. Die Sachen bestehen immer aus zwei Sachen, genauso wie diese Sticks, finde ich leider sehr lästig. Nämlich einerseits den dreien Treiber für das Device, dass man sich überhaupt mit dem Ding unterhalten kann. Der ist okay, den finde ich vollkommen legitim, den da hinzumachen. Zweitens, irgendeine Einwahl-Software. Kann bitte mal irgendeiner, diesen Dosseligen Chinesen da hinten klar machen, dass ein Mac eine Einwahl-Software mitbringt, die nennt sich OSX. Ich brauche nicht nach irgendeiner Scheiß-Plastesoftware, die scheiße übersetzt ist, wo ich denn irgendwie sage, ich möchte jetzt eine Internetverbindung herstellen. Das kann mein OSX von Hause aus.
Also hast du gleich noch das User-Interface dazu, wo du dann auch deine Prepaid...
Nee, kannst du eben nicht. Weil das, was du gerade sagst, Prepaid-Karte aufladen, nämlich mit USSD. Das sind diese Stern-Doppelkreuz-Codes, mit Werten über 100. Das nennt sich USSD, Unstructured Supplementary Service Data. Damit lädt man üblicherweise diese Karten auf. Also ich sehe Stern 1, 2, 3, Stern und dann irgendwie diesen Code. Doppelkreuz, damit lädst du ja deine Prepaid-Karte auf und so. Genau diese Sachen kannst du über diese Software natürlich nicht machen. Die kannst du übrigens über das nackte Device machen. Nur so nebenbei. Also diese Software bitte weglassen. Das Ding wie ein ganz normales Modem in Gänsefüßchen einbuchen. Unter OS X. Und das tut es in der Regel auch schon. Es gibt dann noch so ein paar spezielle Modems, so GSM oder 3G Modems oder sowas, wo man noch den APN setzen kann. Das ist für manche Sachen wichtig. Aber ansonsten die Parameter einfach alle so lassen und eine Verbindung aufmachen über das ganz normale Teil ab vom OS X. Und dann geht das. So, wenn du die Dinge aber in diesem Myfile-Modus betreibst, dann machen die ja selber einfach einen WLAN auf. Dann musst du dich mit dem ganzen Scheiß gar nicht kümmern. Das heißt, du gehst da einmal mit dem Browser drauf, konfigurierst das Ding, sagst da, weiß ich, hier steckst du die Karte ja, wie gesagt, da rein, definierst dort diesen APN. Den sagt ja der Betreiber deiner SIM-Karte mit dazu. Wird allerdings heute nur noch selten benutzt, weil die meisten Netzbetreiber haben festgestellt, dass die EU damit nicht klarkommen und haben ihr Netz so eingestellt, wenn jemand mit einem kaputten APN ankommt, dass sie den einfach auf den richtigen APN, auf den Default-APN umstellen und in den Suite. Zum Beispiel O2 macht das in Deutschland so. Bei O2 kannst du reinschreiben, in den APN, was du willst, außer wenn du jetzt spezieller Firmenkunde bist, landest du immer auf dem richtigen Ding, das passt dann schon. Weil sie leid sind, das kostet ihnen auch zu viel Hotline-Zeit, die ja teuer ist. Und ja, ansonsten diese Dinger funktionieren. Die haben diese komische Beschränkung. Die Dinger von Huawei haben noch einen anderen komischen Gag, den ich auch nicht verstanden habe. Vielleicht ist der inzwischen weg. Wenn du die lädst, ans Lade-Dings dran machst, dann kannst du zwar auch eine Verbindung aufbauen, aber den lädst du nicht. Also sie können entweder nur den Strom aus dem Netzteil benutzen, um zu funken, also um zu Mi-Fi'n, oder um zu laden.
Also nicht wie so ein iPhone, was gleichzeitig rottet und brotelt.
Richtig, macht das nicht. Du betreibst das Ding im Hotel, toll am Netzgerät, denkst, sehr geil, jetzt nehme ich es in die Hand, gehst vor die Tür, der Ding hat inzwischen nicht ein Funken geladen, gehst aus der Tür und nach 10 Minuten ist es tot. Aber gibt es auch, wie gesagt, von anderen Herstellern, vielleicht hat Hui Budit inzwischen auch mal gefixt, das Thema. Aber ist, ja, ansonsten, also ist nicht fancy, wohl von Sachen wie V6 oder Ähnlichem oder VPN, da wollen wir gar nicht reden. Aber ist klein, ist so Handteller groß. Ich hab sogar eins dabei. Willst du eins sehen?
Ist das dieses E5 oder was?
E585832 oder so, was das für Detail ist. Aber hab ich wie gesagt ewig nicht benutzt.
Die so oben schwarz und unten silber sind oder so, wo diese runden Eier drin sind.
Übrigens www.apple.com hat eine IPv6 Adresse. Watt? Kommt aber von Ackermai.
Na ja, das war ja das, was Clemens wollte.
Aber das ist neu, da hast du einen.
Ja genau, das ist dieser E5 oder diese E5 Familie, welches Gerät ist das konkret?
E585832 Mit so einem OLED-Display vorne dran schon.
So, das macht 3G. Und dann macht es auch den ganzen HS-UPA und HS-DPA-Gramm.
Na ja, da gibt es ja verschiedene Stufen von, aber das macht, eigentlich geht das. Eigentlich kann man das so benutzen.
Und wie lange würdest du meinen hält so der Akku?
Wenn er auch voll ist und der surft jetzt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche...
Wenn du nur normal rumklickst und rumsurfs und streamst, so 2-3 Stunden. Wenn du jetzt anfängst irgendwie zu skypen, also das Ding stürzt ja ab, wenn du den mit Skype belaberst, den du da hast. Und wenn du jetzt irgendwelchen anderen Streaming oder einen anderen Quack damit machst oder so, dann geht der relativ schnell in die Knie. So eine Stunde, anderthalb vielleicht.
Ich meine, wenn du mit Skype abstürzt, ist das Ding natürlich zu nichts zu gebrauchen.
Ich könnte jetzt mal wieder ein Firmware-Update probieren. Wie gesagt, ich hab das Ding seit eigentlich ein Jahr oder einem Jahr nicht benutzt.
Vielleicht mal eine gute Frage hier an die Hörer. Vielleicht habt ihr ja Lust, euch da in den Kommentaren mit einzubringen. Also so MyFi-Geräte, die wirklich zuverlässig funktionieren, brauchbare Akku haben. Und überhaupt erst mal auf Akku laufen, weil ich finde gerade einen der Vorteile von diesen MyFi-Teilen, dass du sie ja im Prinzip überall hinlegen kannst.
Dein altes iPhone 4.
Das ist auch ein gutes MyFi.
Das ist wahrscheinlich von all den Geräten immer noch das beste. Und du hast es schon.
Und du kannst es per Bluetooth ansprechen, weil wesentlich weniger Strom verbraucht als MyFi.
Ja, ich weiß ja nicht, wie eure Erfahrungen mit iPhone Hotspots sind, aber so ein iPhone, das legt sich schon mal echt die Karten. Was willst du mir denn zeigen?
Wahrscheinlich weniger als das Ding. Die alten Dinger hatten nur vier Leuchteidioten und das Ding schreibt jetzt richtig was hin. Ach so, ich verstehe es sowieso.
Ja, klar, funktioniert im Prinzip schon so in etwa, aber ich hab das ja am laufenden Meter mit meinem MacBook Air und meinem iPhone. Ich benutze mein iPhone am laufenden Meter als Hotspot für mein Air. Deswegen will ich ja auch unbedingt 3G im Air. Oder mein Ding jetzt auch LTE. Gibt's aber nicht von Apple. Weil...
Dumpfbankenbande.
Dumpfbankenbande. Also benutze ich die ganze Zeit dieses Teil. Und ich hab so Probleme im Bereich von ich kriege auf meinem iPhone Daten, aber ich kriege irgendwie auf meinem Mac keine Daten. Oder ich kann mich nicht in das WLAN von diesem scheiß iPhone einbuchen. Kann nicht verbinden. Ja, dann nehme ich Bluetooth. Aber manchmal willst du ja vielleicht auch ein Gerät benutzen, was über Bluetooth diese Fähigkeit so nicht hat oder was eben mal schnell da reingehen soll, was du nicht noch pären willst und so. Aber selbst dann geht aber bei mir.
Das ist nämlich, deswegen benutze ich meinen MiFi nicht, weil ich jetzt inzwischen doch sage, ich schleppe lieber irgendwie nochmal eine extra Stromversorgung mit mir rum oder sowas und benutze meinen Personal-Hotspot sehr häufig.
Ja, aber das ist okay, wenn man noch ein altes Telefon rumliegen hat, aber man kauft sich jetzt nicht ein iPhone, um so einen Hotspot zu haben. Also wenn jetzt jemand mich fragt, deswegen bringe ich das ganze Thema jetzt ja nicht auf.
Ach naja, auf Ebay, wer weiß. Wie viel kostet so ein Ding?
Ja, bestimmt mehr als so ein neu erwärtiges Teil.
Die alten Dinger würden jetzt unter 100 Euro.
Ja, aber die alten Dinger, die bringen dir halt auch nicht dasselbe Haar ist, UPA und demselben Speed.
Dazu musst du überhaupt erst mal einen Tarif haben. Mein scheiß Kongstar-Tarif hört eh bei 7,2 Megabit auf und das Ding kann 14. Also was soll ich mir da jetzt ein teureres Gerät kaufen?
Na gut, das ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Also du hast auch keinen richtigen Tipp.
Ich hätte mich damit befasst, wenn ich in irgendeiner Art und Weise will, ich wäre mich dem Tarifdiktat in Deutschland hinzugeben und mir mal eine ordentliche Telekom-Business-Tralala-Schießmichtot-Karte zu kaufen hier. Wie das, was Philipp da einsetzt jetzt. Die dann halt eben 80 Euro im Monat kostet. Und dazu bin ich einfach ausgenutzt, nicht bereit. Gib mir so eine SIM-Karte, dann fupse ich dir die Hardware dafür raus.
Gut, aber so mit LTE könnte das ja auch ganz interessant werden. Wobei, da kann man ein iPhone 5S kaufen. Als Hotspot. Das neue MiFi-Device von Apple. iPhone 5S.
Ne, da reicht auch ein C.
Da reicht auch ein C, da hat er recht.
Ja, wir können ein iPhone M rausbringen, was für ein MiFi, was nur ohne Display.
Das Headset macht mal schon wieder Probleme hier. Nächstes Mal gibt's neues? Du holst dir ein neues?
Wir bringen alle Lötkolben mit, ja?
Nächste Sendung neue Lötkolben mitbringen, super.
So Clemens, du hast die letzte Sendung damit begonnen oder beendet, dass du nach E-Mail Full-Names geschrieben hast und wir sollten das alle benutzen.
Die E-Mail wird ja immer wieder totgesagt, aber trotzdem gibt es immer noch sehr viele Leute, die sie benutzen. Und wir haben jetzt 2013 und ich kriege immer noch E-Mails von Leuten, gerade aus Firmennetzen, die lauten bla.fasel.labar.de als Absender.
Ja, schreiben keinen Namen rein.
Richtig. Die haben einfach keinen Namen drin. Oder es gibt Leute, die tragen sich in ihren Full-Namen ihre E-Mail-Adresse ein. Deswegen dachte ich, ich leiste dir jetzt nochmal 30 Sekunden Aufklärungsarbeit und sage den Leuten, dass es zwei Felder gibt in deinem E-Mail-Programm, die man da einstellen kann. Nämlich einen, wo du deinen Namen reinschreiben darfst. Namen und nicht deine E-Mail-Adresse. Und einen, wo du deine E-Mail-Adresse reinschreiben darfst. Und dieser Name, wir sind übrigens in Deutschland, wenn man irgendwie einen Namen hat mit einem Umlaut drin oder einem SZ, darf man den da reinmachen. Das bringt niemanden um. Das können auch Amerikaner empfangen und so. Und Chinesen können das alles empfangen. Also bitte schreibt doch euren Namen in die E-Mail-Absenderadresse rein. Das Ding nennt sich übrigens Full Name, also im Übertragungsstandard. Und bei den E-Mail-Programmen, weiß nicht, wie heißt denn das bei Apple Mail? Wir können ja gerade mal schauen, obwohl mein Ding steht schon wieder auf Englisch. Hat jemand, der hier sein Apple Mail auf Deutsch zu laufen? Du nutzt gar keine Apple Mail, ne?
Gerade nicht zu laufen, aber ich starte es mal.
Starte es mal bitte und sag mir doch mal bitte, wie bei einem Account. Im Englischen heißt das übrigens wirklich Full Name. Die haben die Unterscheidung zwischen E-Mail-Adress und Full Name.
Vollständiger Name heißt das auf Deutsch?
Na bitte. Und da schon das Wort vollständig schon ein Umlaut enthält, kann man ja vielleicht das sich als Hinweis entnehmen, dass man da... Man muss sich da nicht irgendwelchen Leuten anbieten und sich Mueller nennen oder so, wenn man Müller heißt.
Was soll ich jetzt sagen? Das eigentliche Drama, unter dem du leidest.
Nee, ja. Ich finde es interessant, dass das so was gerade aus Firmennetzen kommt. Sie kriegen das am allermeisten aus Firmennetzen. Wo höchstwahrscheinlich denn nicht der User selber sich seinen Rechner einrichtet, sondern den über irgendeine Gruppenrichtlinie oder sowas, den von seinem Admin vorgebatzt kriegt. Und das finde ich besonders bitter, dass die das nicht gebacken kriegen. Und ich finde das einfach blöd. In meiner E-Mail-Übersicht sehe ich eigentlich immer, wo was herkommt. Zwischendurch stehen immer irgendwie s.tralala at schießmichtothausen.de drin. Und ich denke immer, wer ist denn das jetzt? Was steht im Subject? Meistens auch nichts bei solchen Leuten.
Oder nur am Subject steht Hi, wie geht's? Und dann nichts mehr.
Es gibt aber auch Leute, die selbst das auch nicht verstehen. Ich kenne zum Beispiel Leute, die schicken mir Mails grundsätzlich ohne Subject. Das steht ja in den ersten Teilen von den Mails.
Wer hat sich da überhaupt einfallen lassen mit dem AW? Da muss es doch jemand bei Microsoft geben.
Ich kann dir genau erklären, wie sowas funktioniert. Oder funktioniert hat früher. Da ist eben eine Firma hingegangen, die hat eine tolle Software geschrieben. Und wenn man weiß, wie diese Internationalization von so einer Software funktioniert, ist, dass du alle Strings, die irgendwie spannend sind in so einer Software, die hast du in einer separaten Datei. Das heißt, die kannst du jemandem geben, zum Lokalisieren, ohne dass er die Software dazu sieht. Oder dass er die Software dazu hat, notwendigerweise.
Oder irgendeine Ahnung hat, was diese Software eigentlich wirklich tut.
Und wenn ihr denn jemanden hinsetzt, der vielleicht irgendwie in Informatik oder wie auch immer eine 6 hatte, aber in Englisch eine 1, dann setzen sie den halt eben hin und der übersetzt stumpf das, was er da sieht. Ob das Sinn macht oder nicht. Wie auch immer. Und vielleicht haben sie sich auch mal gedacht, in der deutschen Industrie ist das vielleicht viel toller.
Das war doch nun wirklich irgendein Typ bei Microsoft in München.
Vermutlich. Oder irgendeiner von diesen Millionen ausgewanderten Deutschen, die alle in Kalifornien rumhängen, sich nachts eine Tüte reinziehen und tagsüber zu Apple, Microsoft gehen, die Zeugse übersetzen.
Aber das ist doch nur das deutsche Outlook, was das macht.
Vielleicht machen sie das im Französischen auch. Du könntest den locker zutrauen, dass du das im Französischen...
Nein, im Französischen heißt es natürlich auch Re.
Was heißt denn irgendwie?
Antwort.
Das ist hier jemand, der das Reply und AV ist Antwort.
Aber Anser hat ja auch AV.
En français. En français, s'il vous plaît.
Nicht statt Reply, Anser.
Gibt es jemanden, der Französisch das Windows betreibt und das mal gerade mal ausprobieren kann, bitte? Von unseren Zuhörern, die jetzt eh schon alle weggeschaltet haben. Aber, ja, aber das ist so. Manche Sachen will die Industrie einfach eindeutschen. Ich erinnere mich noch daran, dass zum Beispiel ich hatte mal ganz entfernt irgendwie mit VW zu tun und die hatten immer sehr lustige Sachen dafür. Zum Beispiel ist das, was man üblicherweise in der IT-Industrie, sozusagen die Änderungen einer Software kommt, per Change-Request. Das heißt bei VW, Évou. Das ist ein Änderungswunsch.
Évou.
Wir haben doch noch ein Évou.
Ja, also vielleicht ist das auch so ein Spleen, dass die das ja unbedingt alle übersetzen. Évou.
Also auf Französisch heißt die Antwort einfach Repens oder Replik. Das heißt selbst, wenn sie das übersetzt haben, sind sie bei RE geblieben. Meines Wissens, ich kenne die Weltsituationen kaum, aber ich hab noch von keinem anderen Land gehört, was sich einen anderen Prifix für eine Antwort gewählt hat in einer Software, außer RE. Das ist nur in Deutschland, nur mit Outlog, oder?
Wir werden es sehen. Unsere Hörer werden uns jetzt zu knallen mit Antworten auf China und so.
Wer auch immer dafür verantwortlich ist, sollte auch nachträglich.
Ohne dass das verfrügelt wird.
Nö, verfrügeln finde ich jetzt bis zu gemein.
Was, da steht jetzt was?
Das letzte Link für mich, da stehen die deutschen Download-Firmwörs, da kannst du klicken, das kommt wahrscheinlich schneller rein.
Ach, hier gibt es auch noch einen Wikipedia-Link. Ah, es gibt noch andere Abkürzungen.
Na, bitte.
Habe ich das auch schon mal gesehen?
Polnisch ist auch ganz toll.
YNT.
Versuch gar nicht, das auszusprechen.
Türkisch find ich gut. Ja, stimmt, jetzt wo es da steht, wenn ich so Sachen reserviere in Schweden oder sonst was krieg, manchmal E-Mails, da steht SV drin. Jetzt wurde es da, aber hat dich echt verdrängt.
Dann hätten wir das ja auch geklärt.
Na gut, dann ist zumindest der Typ jetzt irgendwie davon gekommen. Weil ich hätte jetzt schon vorgeschlagen, dass man ihm mal in Honig taucht.
Und dann auf einen Ameisenhügel legt, oder was?
Dann einfach federn.
Honig und federn?
Ja, Honig und federn. Ich wäre jetzt nicht so fies und würde ihn jetzt teeren.
Und dann aber auf den Ameisenhügel.
Stell dir mal so ein Fass mit Honig vor.
Sommerblütenhonig?
Ja, das ist ein bisschen teuer, aber jetzt nur so übertragen. Du kannst ja auch Honig nehmen und das so auftragen auf die Haut. Und dann halt federn und dann...
Sprehen?
Honig-Spray. Und dann vor einem Wespen-Nest?
Nee, dann einfach federn und durch die Straßen treiben. Einfach eine halbe Stunde so. Dass einfach klar ist, was wir davon halten. Von AW.
Danach ist es gut.
Also kann auch duschen wieder und wird auch wieder reintegriert. Darauf ein Supermarkt einkaufen, alles. Software runterladen.
Dafür hinterher auch wieder Software übersetzen.
Ich finde, sowas muss auch mal einfach gutiert werden. Absolut.
I'm totally for it.
Der Ding können sie gleich mitlaufen lassen. Die können ja hier so einen Wettrennen machen. Der Grieche und der Skandinavier. Irgend so ein Typ ist das doch hier. Der Türke mit dem Y und ein T und der ODP-Pole, die dürfen alle durch die Straße rennen. Und wer irgendwie das Rennen gewinnt, der kriegt auch einen Preis.
Also um es wie gesagt abzuschließen, mein Plädoyer an die Leute, schreibt einen ordentlichen Namen bitte rein. Das ist auch schön und ihr dürft ihn auch richtig schreiben. Ja und der darf auch Leerzeichen enthalten.
Huckel, du musst deinen Sitz höher machen.
Diese Stühle, die...
Die Stühle sind wunderbar. Die sind genau dafür gemacht. Du musst die so höher machen.
Huckel ist der mit Abstand Jüngste von uns und der hat echt keinen Sitzfleisch. Oder Hummel im Hinteren, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Du musst dich betätigen. Baue mal einen.
Muss noch fahren.
Wir sind durch mit unseren Tüten, mit unseren Themen.
Tüten, Themen, Temperamente.
Ich hätte mich ja gerne zu iOS 7 geäußert, aber ich hab noch keinerlei Kenntnisse.
Bei mir ist der Download wieder abgebrochen. Er ging von 80 Stunden plötzlich auf 15 Stunden zurück und war darüber denn so schockiert, dass er eine Minute später abgebrochen hat.
Ja, und jetzt haben einige Leute wirklich drauf gehofft, dass man von dir einen iOS 7-Rant zu hören kriegt.
Ja, ihr müsst noch zwei Wochen warten.
Ich glaube, wenn es erst mal zwei Wochen dauert, bis es runtergeladen ist.
Heute ist nicht alle Tage. Wir ranten wieder, keine Frage.
Ja, ich bin...
Wir freaken wieder.
Das auch.
Aber Früchte an Delle war gut.
Erklärt mir doch mal, warum schlägt dieses Bild... Könnt ihr mir das mal erklären, wie das so bei den Apple Fanboys gerade so läuft?
Was?
Na... Ist das jetzt so ein Release, wie als das iPhone rauskam? Sind die jetzt alle total excited?
Hast du nicht das Bild von diesem Altar gesehen?
Kapieren die jetzt vor ihrem Server die ganze Nacht? Ja, aber das ist doch ein Witz mit dem Altar.
Nö. Ich glaube, es ist ein Witz. Ja, aber ich glaube, dass genauso viele Leute, die genau das machen, die schlagen sich jetzt die Nacht um die Ohren, starren dabei auf diesen Download-Balken.
Ja, aber ihr könnt mir das vielleicht mal geschichtlich einordnen. Also ist jetzt irgendwie iOS 7, ist das so ein neuer Geschichtsabschnitt? Indem wir irgendwie die ganze Schrift unleserlich gemacht haben und dünne Fonts, die man nicht mehr erkennen kann und die ganze spaziale Ordnung des iOS geopfert haben, um das ganze darzustellen. Ich meine mal ehrlich, iOS 7 zeigt seine Apps jetzt so an, das sieht aus wie Netscape Navigator 1.0, ja, wo es noch keine Tabellen gab.
Da gab es noch keine Tabellen.
Ist auch keine Kurier.
Ist egal, aber wenn du das irgendwie mit weißem Hintergrund gemacht hast, einfach blaue Schrift auf weißem Hintergrund und alles steht untereinander und du hast noch nicht mal Tables, um das irgendwie in irgendeine Struktur zu kriegen. So ist es doch.
Wir sprechen uns in zwei Wochen nochmal.
Das ist alles durcheinander. Du schattest diese blöden Contacts und alles, was vorher schön links, rechts sortiert war, das ist der Typ.
Einfach das Licht noch nicht gesehen.
Ich hab das Licht noch nicht gesehen, ich hab das scheiß Licht in Adressbook schon mit 107 gesehen und ich sage dir, das Licht lässt mich kotzen. Aber, ja, das ist einfach agli es hell useless dieses Adressbook, das ist einfach gestorben in dem Moment, als irgendwie alles nur noch so diffuser Kack war.
Einfach nicht updaten dann.
Ja, also geht ja auch gar nicht.
Es ist tendenziell bleibüßig. Also es ist eine Typoschlacht.
Ja, sie können es ja da noch...
Kannst du mir das mal auf deinem iPad mal zeigen? Da ist jetzt iOS 7 drauf, weil ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es auf einem großen iPad irgendwie alles funktioniert. Weil das ist riesige Abstände. Aber jetzt hast du halt so diese Fortfahren, weitermachen.
Also hast du ein iPhone in Deutsch?
Nein, ja, ich meine aber so was passiert. Na ich nicht, aber du hast halt potenziell jetzt diese mega langen Texte in diesem riesigen Font, weil der Font das einzige ist, was von dem Button übrig geblieben ist. Und das nimmt einfach mal 50% deines Titelspaces ein. Und der eigentliche Titel, also das, was beschreibt...
Das ist doch noch Beta 3, wo haben sie alle schlechter geändert.
Und dann ist dieser Titel nicht mehr in der Mitte, sondern wird irgendwie nach rechts geschoben.
Ich finde, die sollten die Vokale da rauslassen. Das ist überflüssiger Ballast, wir können das alle auch ohne Vokale lesen.
Also es gibt da jetzt Emoji, da gibt es auch genug Symbole wieder als Fund.
Dann kannst du ja auch gleich anfangen, richtige Button zu malen.
Emojis sind wieder bunt und dann kriegt John wieder das Kotzen.
Also ich fand ja auch sehr enttäuscht, dass es in iOS 7 keine neuen Emojis gab.
Aber es gab neue Klingeltöne. Und die sind teilweise gar nicht so verkehrt.
Es gibt über das eine Feature, was ich selber noch nicht gesehen habe, weil wie gesagt meine 15 Stunden, die abgebrochen sind, sind noch nicht um. Aber es gibt Leute, die haben sich wahnsinnig über das Feature gefreut, dass man jetzt Anrufer blocken kann. Anrufer und Messager, dass man sagen kann, ich will von diesem Spack keine Nachricht sehen und auch nicht, dass mein Telefon nicht klingelt.
Und iOS 7 zeigt mir immer noch eine Wettervorhersage für UTC.
Eine Wettervorhersage?
Ja, haben wir bei mir auch eingestellt.
In UTC ist wolkig mit 12K.
So ist es.
Wenn du UTC, was man auch GMF nennt, als Timezone einstellst in der Weltuhr, dann zeigt er dir auf der Weltkarte da unten vor Afrika das Wetter von UTC.
Aber jetzt noch mal zu dem Blog-Thema. Ihr habt es ja alle schon drauf. Wie macht man das? Wenn man eine Telefonnummer hat, kann man da drauf drücken und sagen, die möchte gerne, dass mich da nie wieder jemand anruft.
Oder wie funktioniert das? Telekom-Hotline machen ist eine gute Idee im Moment. Ich probiere das mal gleich aus. Mich ruft seit Tagen schon wieder die Telekom-Hotline an. Nein, nicht im Phone.
Also die Visual-Voice-Mail funktioniert bei mir nicht mehr.
Ja, das kann aber sein, dass du da wieder deine Betreiber-Einstellungen runterladest. Die sind gerade wieder neu gekommen.
Wo lade ich die runter?
Da gibt es hier Block-Dis-Caller.
Mit iTunes machst du ein Update und dann kommt ein Carrier-Update aus.
Kannst du langsam den Slider runterziehen?
Jetzt kann ich ja noch mit meinem Themenkommen hier. Bitcoin ist nicht viel passiert eigentlich.
Ich will nach Hause.
Außer dass die Asics jetzt alle doll ausgeliefert werden, aber das wissen die alle. Aber es gibt jetzt hier OpenZFS. Die haben sich jetzt alle zusammengetan und wollen jetzt an ZFS ordentlich weitermachen. Also haben sie vorher auch gemacht, aber jetzt machen sie es so ein bisschen mehr offizieller und zusammen und als Team und Einheit. Mit eigener Webseite und so.
Das sind nicht nur Leute, die das für BSD oder Linux oder Mac machen, sondern das sind Leute, die das für alle zusammen machen.
Diese Illumnos, Delphics, FreeBest Linux und US 10 sogar auch.
Stellt euch doch mal vor, ihr hört diese Sendung.
Ich kann es dir jetzt nicht vorstellen.
Stell dir vor, du hörst das auf dem Land oder so. Und du denkst, du bist jetzt einfach bei einer Nerdparty. So ist das halt. Wir haben jetzt alle ein Bierchen in der Hand.
Hallo, wir sind keine Nerdparty. Wir sind eine Freak Show. Das ist halbwegs koordiniert. Da, da gibt es irgendwie einen Direktor, der sagt, wo es langgeht.
Und das möchtest nicht du sein.
Aber auf dem Kirmes wird auch ganz viel durcheinander geredet.
Das ist nur, weil ich mal ein bisschen die Züge irgendwie hier lockerer lasse, dann dreht ihr gleich alle durch.
War zu viel Zucker drin in der Pizza. Die Schoki, die Schoki. Seitdem wir hier an der Schokoladerumme geknabbert haben, drehts hier ab. Ich sag's euch.
Die Schokolade.
Die Schweizer, die haben uns sowas in die Schoki geschwiezt.
Das ist bestimmt von Albert Hoffmanns Spezialschokoladenmanufaktur.
Wir kommen jetzt noch mal kurz zum Abschluss der Sendung. Schreibt mir mal kurz zu Herrn Ahrens. Und er wird uns jetzt noch mal in ruhigen Wort sagen. Ja, aber es ist einfach, es kommt einfach nicht rüber.
Noch mal das gleiche erzählen?
Ja, spul mal zurück.
Nein, du sagst es natürlich nicht. Du sagst es mit anderen Worten.
Ich müsste ja wissen, wie die gerade waren, damit ich andere wählen kann.
Und Worte, wo Freak drin vorkommt.
Es gibt jetzt auch ein Zetterfest, da stammen sich die Leute von FreeBSD, Illumos. Illumos? Wer ist denn Illumos? Ich kann den mal nicht merken. Und Delphix, ihr habt mich weggedinkst. Nur ihr nicht mehr. Auch nicht schlecht. Haben sich zusammengetan, um jetzt mal unter einer Foundation zusammen irgendwie alle ein Open Zetterfest weiterzuschreiben. Und die wollen demnächst auch Krypto machen. Und was war noch? War noch irgendwie ein Feature, was auch die bei Oracle haben, was die bei dem normalen Zetterfest noch nicht haben? Krypto. Sie wollen irgendwie, dass man die Vices wieder entfernen kann, indem sie da ein bisschen was basteln, dieses berühmte Block-Pointer-Rewrite. Aber sie wollen es anders machen. Aber das ist ja ein Feature, was sie auch noch gerne hätte. Aber jetzt mal ernst.
Sie nehmen jetzt mal einen aktuellen Stand von Zetterfest.
Das geht ja nicht. Weil Oracle ja nichts mehr rausrückt. Das heißt, der letzte Stand, den die da bei Freebase hatten und die anderen wahrscheinlich auch, waren irgendwie Version 28. Weil Krypto kam nämlich, glaube ich, mit Version 30 und den Stand haben die nicht.
Also sie können ja in einem wieder einbauen.
Die mussten sie danach alles dann irgendwie selber coden. Haben sich aber auch schon tierisch gefreut, dass bestimmte Sachen, die sie da rein coden, dass die das bei Oracle dann nicht mit aufnehmen können, außer es landet halt auch wieder in Open Source. Dann müssten die ja forken bei Oracle, wenn sie das machen wollten. Weil die programmieren halt weiter unter dieser CD-DL, die halt frei ist. Und die von Oracle können da nichts aufnehmen, was dann nicht auch frei wäre. Da sie aber das nicht gemacht haben, ist das ein bisschen ein Problem wohl, irgendwie so.
Aber ich finde das schon mal sehr begrüßend, dass es jetzt mal eine Aktion gibt, die plattformübergreifend ist. Dass man vielleicht sogar irgendwann mal in die Verlegenheit kommt, mal was jetzt nicht 100.000 Mal vorkommt, aber dass man mal eine Platte umstecken kann. Und dass es dann immer noch geht und keinen Panic erzeugt.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt hier eine Developer-Organisation. Im Prinzip gab es diese Zusammenarbeit schon immer, nur jetzt haben sie da mal ein Label drauf gezählt.
Jetzt haben sie es mal ein bisschen offizieller gemacht und irgendwie auch ein Domain, ein Einstiegspunkt, wo man mal gucken kann. Das war früher alles immer so ein bisschen bei diesem Illumos. Illumos. Und jetzt ist es halt bei OpenZFS, finde ich ganz gut. Und einer der Hauptentwickler von damals, Matt Arendts, heißt der, ist da auch irgendwie, macht da weiter.
Matt Arendts.
Entfernter Verwandter.
Illumos, das kann man sich doch anmerken. Das ist so wie Super Illu. Super Illumos.
Super Illumos. Ja, nee, kann ich mir nicht merken.
Wir sind ja auch so ein bisschen die Super Illu des Techbroadcasts.
Meine Update-Notification ist eben hochgepoppt. Mavericks ist draußen.
Wirklich? Deswegen ist heute alles so platt.
Ich wollte mal gucken, ob ihr noch aufpasst.
Ben 10 nach 5 ist draußen, richtig? Du bist da wieder voll hinterher.
Ich weiß, nein. Hab ich vorhin schon weggeskippt.
Wenn sie jetzt noch Mavericks releasen, dann ist das Internet wirklich down.
Das wär mal ein interessanter Doss.
Wir machen heute einfach mal alles. Dass die Film ist heute rausgekommen.
Hast du eigentlich irgendwie noch die, siehst du eigentlich noch eine Chance für ZFS? Auf unseren Plattformen.
Dieses Projekt hat ja der Roddy auch letztes Mal schon erzählt, dass da einer wieder anfängt irgendwie. Es gibt immer wieder, ja, es gibt eine Menge Versuche leider. Das heißt, dass immer wieder Leute von vorne anfangen, wohl auf dem Mac. Also so richtig toll ist es irgendwie nicht. Die Bude, die dieses offizielle hier gekauft hat, da ist ja auch nie wieder was gekommen seit letztes Jahr September. Also auch ein bisschen komisch.
Nee, aber dieser Lundmann, der ist jetzt schon seit zwei Monaten, drei Monaten oder so wirklich dran. Also ich kriege da immer wieder Mails von Bugs, die er da irgendwie geclosed hat auf Gitarre.
Ja, kann man nur hoffen, dass es mal gut wird. Aber der braucht natürlich, ich weiß nicht, ob er Colonel Support oder irgendwas braucht. Er hat es natürlich, da rennt vielleicht bei bestimmten Problemen gegen die Wand und dann ist es natürlich doof.
Ach, Colonel Support, das Problem ist diese ganzen Specials, die OSX da reinbusseln. Da meine ich jetzt nicht mal Resource Forks oder irgendwas, aber dass da ein Spotlight auch drauf geht und das ist ja alles auch so scheiße dokumentiert. Das kommt ja noch erschwerend hinzu.
Colonel selber ist ja Open Source, insofern haben sie es da noch halbwegs einfacher, weil sie da wenigstens reingucken können.
Ja, aber wenn sie was ändern müssen, weil irgendwie muss sein, dann stehen sie doch doof da, was die anderen da nicht haben. Die können sich da mal schon... Na ja, sagen wir mal so.
Wie gesagt, sie haben ja den ZFS-On-Linux-Code genommen und versuchen den jetzt für OS X anzupassen. Aber im Moment, es sieht ja ganz gut aus. Sie sind da eben sich am machen und fixen da einen Bug nach dem anderen.
Wie OS X-isch ist denn das? Kann das schon Resource Forks und Access Lists und Extended Tools und so?
Na ja, Resource Forks gibt's dem Sinne sowieso nicht mehr. Also das ist ja...
Du musst das anbieten nach oben. Und wie du das nach unten machst, ist da wurscht.
Ja, so wie ich glaube, das HFS Plus auch macht.
Sag mal so, wie ich die Resource Forks finde, glaube ich gar nicht mehr so spannend. Aber Extended Attributes sind zum Beispiel spannend. Und zwar nicht nur für uns scheiß, weil zum Beispiel, wenn du eine komprimierte Datei hast, steckt das alles in so einem Ding da hinten drin.
Also die genauen Dinge weiß ich auch nicht, weil es gibt jetzt noch kein offizielles Release, wo jetzt irgendjemand mal gesagt hat, wir fangen jetzt mal an, Bugs, jetzt mal irgendwie einen stable branch auszurufen oder so.
Gibt es da irgendjemanden Feature List, auf die man mal starren kann, wo drauf steht, hier, das ist das, was wir auf der ZFS drauf machen, damit das für OS X tofig ist?
Also wenn ich hier auf den GitHub-Ding ans klicke, also wenn du...
Baue doch den nochmal in den Chat rein.
Ja, wenn du bei OpenZFS gleich die Mainpage... Mir sieht die Mainpage anders aus. Doch, da, bei ZFS OS X, da auf GitHub klickst, dann kriegst du da eigentlich das, was die da gerade basteln. Genau, und da steht Experimental, also insofern...
Ja, das ist jetzt der Status, aber ich will wissen, was das für Features hat.
maczfs.org ist hier angegeben nach wie vor als...
Vielleicht steht da... Das steht da maczfs.org. Also da ist es ja so, dass sie quasi beide, ich nenne es mal Branches, irgendwie inzwischen, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, müssen wir in den FAQs gucken oder so. So genau. Wie gesagt, es ist halt experimental.
Also die Dokumentation ist wie immer in Read the Source.
Naja, ich hatte doch letztes Mal auch diesen Link gepostet zu dieser Tabelle in Google Docs und wahrscheinlich steht da noch am ehesten drin, was für Features es hat. Ja, aber Features heißt in dem Sinne jetzt mehr ZFS-Features als als OS X-Features. Also du würdest dann wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung, würdest du das dann schon rausfinden?
Also das ist alles nicht drin in Mac ZFS.
Ja, aber das ist wiederum die ganz alte Version. Hier. ZPool Version 8. Das ist dieser Stable-Branche von Mac ZFS und diesem Uralt-Code, der damals noch von Apple ist.
Okay, dann muss man hier, aber hier steht wiederum nichts.
Er schickt immer auf das ZFS-Repo.
Vielleicht gibt es da Seiten, meinst du?
Also um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, damit wir zu alle nach Hause gehen können, tut sich da noch was? Ich glaube, da muss ich was tun, weil Apple kann einfach nicht weiter groanen auf Basis von HFS Plus.
Ob wir nochmal ein ordentliches Fallsystem kriegen.
Hier, ich paste nochmal das Google Docs-Ding in den Chat.
Es gab übrigens einen schönen Podcast bei dem Podcast Debug.
Ja, den hab ich auch gehört.
Mit, ich hab den Namen vergessen, aber einem ehemaligen Mitarbeiter von Apple, der damals für die Releases von OS X zuständig war. Also der ist derjenige, der quasi gesagt hat, jetzt ist OS X fertig, so darf es raus. Und der immer so die Builds gemacht hat, also er hat nicht developed, sondern er hat dafür gesorgt, dass es zusammen ist. Und da gab es einige interessante Diskussionen. Das ist die letzte Version, der letzte Podcast von Debug, glaube ich, der aktuelle gerade noch. Und er kam auch auf HFS zu sprechen. Irgendjemand hat mich da auf diesen Podcast verwiesen mit, es würde da auch was über ZDFS gesagt werden, aber ich konnte ehrlich gesagt nichts finden, wo etwas über ZDFS gesagt wurde. Er hat aber viel darüber gesagt, warum, wie er das findet, dass immer noch HFS im Einsatz ist. Nämlich, dass generell dieser Wechsel auf ein anderes Fallsystem natürlich sehr schwierig wäre und dass ich HFS ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch wirklich bewährt habe. Also für die Unmengen an Installationen, die es davon gibt, ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt keinerlei Verbreitung hat. Wär toll. Hat noch diverse Loblieder übrigens auf NTFS gesungen. Meinte, das wäre ja wohl richtig cool. Über ZDFS hat er sich leider so konkret nicht geäußert. Und leider meines Wissens, also wenn ich es nicht überhört habe, falls das jemand rausgehört hat, das würde mich nochmal interessieren. Also ich glaube, dieses Schicksal von ZDFS und warum ZDFS nicht den Weg in Snow Labart gefunden hat.
Ja, aber dazu hat er eigentlich nichts gesagt. Er hat mehr was dazu gesagt, was für ein Pain das ist, eigentlich ist, für den User ein File-System zu wechseln.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich auch. Aber ich meine, Apple hat das schonmal geschafft, mit HFS auf HFS Plus.
Ja, ja, darüber haben sie auch gesprochen.
Ja.
Du, keine Ahnung, also...
Kann man wahrscheinlich heute nicht mehr so machen, mit dieser riesigen Zielgruppe, aber in gewisser Hinsicht fände ich das nach wie vor wünschenswert.
Interessant fand ich, dass er halt gemeint hat, ja, unter iOS gibt es das halt auch, das HFS Plus, da benutzen wir das auch. Und ich glaube, er sagte sogar auf den meisten Geräten dieser Welt, überhaupt ist HFS Plus drauf, so schlecht ist es ja doch. Aber es gibt doch nicht dann die meisten Geräte. Naja, ich meine, wenn du die ganzen Macs und die ganzen iOS-Geräte zusammenzählst, auf denen ja auch allen HFS Plus drauf ist, dann kommst du natürlich auch auf eine ganz schöne Gemenge von Geräten, auf denen HFS Plus im Einsatz ist. Ja gut, aber nicht die meisten. So hat er argumentiert.
Nicht die meisten.
Mehr Windows-Geräte als Mac und iOS zusammen?
Ja, es werden nicht mehr verkauft.
Wahrscheinlich mehr USB-Sticks mit FAT. FAT, FAT, FAT, irgendwas als...
Na ja gut, USB-Sticks, wenn du die mit rein rechnest.
Ja gut, da zeigt sich ja auch die Probleme. Naja, wie auch immer. Ich glaube, wir haben unseren Pulver verschossen hier, oder? Ist durch. Wir sind durch. Mehr können wir nicht dazu sagen. Alles andere müsst ihr selber rauskriegen. iOS 7 werden wir dann in der nächsten Sendung, glaube ich, noch mal durchnehmen, oder?
Haben wir ja erst die letzten drei Sendungen gemacht.
Zumindest auf meinem iPhone 4 werde ich es dann irgendwie mal ein paar Stunden ausprobieren.
Wir wollen den epischen Rent noch dazu hören.
Naja, ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab einfach Schiss. Gab es irgendwo jetzt irgendwelche Gerüchte dazu, wann wir vielleicht jetzt auch noch mal Mavericks sehen, oder nicht? Oder sind wir da komplett in the dark?
Die Gerüchteküche sagt Oktober, was ich so... Herbst. Ich nehme mal an, Oktober.
Ich schätze mal, wir sehen jetzt noch zwei Events. Wir sehen das MacPro-Event. Und das Mavericks-Release und MacBook Pro. Also MacBook Pro und... Also MacBook Pro Updates, MacPro Release und Mavericks Release. Ob sie da ein Event zu machen, im Sinne von wie iOS, weiß ich nicht. Aber das wird sozusagen ein Tag sein.
Also einmal alles Mac?
Einmal alles Mac OS 10. OS 10 mit Mac Pro und MacBook Pro.
Und Zwiebeln.
Ob sie da für ein eigenes Event machen, weiß ich nicht. Dann kommt noch ein iPad-Update. Da machen sie definitiv ein Event zu. Ähnlich wie mit iOS. Und dann werden sie vorstellen, ein neues iPad 5. Vielleicht gibt es ja auch ein iPad 5S.
Mini 2?
Mini 2 mit Retina, hoffentlich.
Hoffentlich nicht, das wird teuer.
iOS 7 noch mal revisitet. Und was es doch schon für tolle Applikationen gibt. Und wie geil das doch jetzt hier auf dem iPad ist. Und guck mal hier. Und wir haben auch eine neue Version von iBooks. Und wir haben auch was, was, was, was brauchen sie noch?
Und noch ein iPhone 4C.
Nein.
Und das neue iMovie jetzt irgendwie geil mit hast nicht gesehen und Climbim und Bling Bling.
Alles in der iOS 7-Optik.
Genau. Und vielleicht, ja, vielleicht kommt noch mal irgendwas Sinnvolles. iPad Mini Retina kaufe ich sofort. Ohne auch nur mit der Wimper zu zucken. Ist sofort gekauft.
Wo ich übrigens...
Schon lange kein sinnloses Geld mehr in iPads versehen.
Wo ich übrigens nochmal, nochmal zum Thema iOS 7. Das ist ja eigentlich mal designt worden für Retina. Das haben sie irgendwie in der WWDC, in vielen Movies immer gesagt, so ja, hier Retina und so weiter. Und iOS 7 nimmt endlich mal Retina und hier und so weiter. Aber das iPad Mini ist ja gar nicht Retina. Kriegt trotzdem ein iOS 7.
Das iPad 2 auch nicht.
Und ich muss sagen, ich war ja sehr gespannt, funktioniert das überhaupt mit nicht Retina? Und es sieht eigentlich ganz okay aus, obwohl es kein Retina ist. Also daran liegt es nicht. Naja, wie auch immer. Wir sagen Tschüss.
Richtig, wir müssen ja noch Tschüss sagen. So, ich hoffe, wir waren hier nicht zu grumpy.
Manchen Leuten werden wir nicht grumpy genug gewesen sein.
Also ich würde sagen, übernächste Woche sind wir dann wieder grumpy. Und dann geht es richtig ab, oder?
Grumpy Cat Tim macht dann...
Kannst du übrigens bei mir mal ausprobieren, wenn du das mit dem Essen vorher weglässt? Ich werde dann relativ schnell grumpy. Ich werde wie so eine W-Figur. Dann ganz schnell über Gelb wechseln, ich zur Rotröhre wandern, bin ich ziemlich grumpy.